HEALTH WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES.
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICE
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
THE ALLOTTED TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-363-6443 SEVEN AGAIN. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN THREE THREE SIX
FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX
EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT AGAIN.
EIGHT TWO SIX EIGHT FOUR TWO
EIGHT FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES THEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE. COULD COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY THE
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER.
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'LL HAVE TO WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU'LL BE ON MUTED AND YOU'RE
NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING. THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM THIS
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE.
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THE
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT HEARINGS AND IT'S
CLOSE TO THE USUAL MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. HERE MAYBE LAG TIMES
FOR PARTICIPANTS TO ADJUSTING
TO NEW USE OF ONLINE. TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. WE HAVE TWELVE BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY THREE SIXTY NINE
BY CENTER COM LOGGER WILL BE. I
HEARD TODAY FOR TESTIMONY AND
DISCUSSION BUT WILL BE HELD FOR
A VOTE AT THE FOLLOWING HEARING
SO THEY'LL BE A VOTE ONLY- AT
THE NEXT HEARING SO WE'LL BE
JUST TAKING TESTIMONY ON.
FOLLOWING NUMBER THREE EIGHTY
THREE SIXTY NINE AS WELL AS THE
PRESENTATION FROM THE AUTHOR
AND THEN DOING A VOTE NEXT
WEEK- WE DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE
ANY BILLS ON THE PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR. PLEASE NOTE
THAT CENTERS GROWTH AND CENTER
WEINER WILL NOT BE PRESENT AT
TODAY'S HEARING. THE BILLS WILL
BE HEARD AND FOLLOW ORDER
HOWEVER THAT ORDER MAY BE
MODIFIED BECAUSE AVAILABILITY
BILL AUTHORS TO PRESENT AND THE
NEED TO COMMIT COMPLETE THE
HEARING AGENDA AND A TIMELY
MANNER. BEFORE YOU HEAR
PRESENTATIONS OF THE TEAM TWO
OKAY- AT THIS POINT I DO NOT
KNOW THE PRESENCE OF A QUORUM
SO- WE WILL CONTINUE AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE- TO HEAR
TESTIMONY- FOR BILL TESTIMONY
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. HI IS THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN INSTITUTE
TIME LIMITS ON BILL TESTIMONY
EACH SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED IN
EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME TO BE
DETERMINED BY THE CHAIR. BUT
THE PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OUT
PERMIT UP TO TWO WITNESSES FOR
TWO MINUTES PER WITNESS OUR
MAXIMO FOUR MINUTES ON EACH
SIDE. ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MOST LIMIT OUR COMMENTS
TO THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURES. I
HOPE TO HEAR FROM EVERYONE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY. HOWEVER
BECAUSE WE HAVE A DEFINITE TIME
IN TIME FOR THE HEARING I MEAN
LIMIT THE TOTAL TIME FOR ALL
COMMENTS ON A BILL TO ENSURE
THE COMMITTEE'S ABLE TO
COMPLETE OUR HEARING AGENDA
TODAY. EVERYONE ALSO HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUBMIT TESTIMONY
ON ANY BILL BEING HEARD ON THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE WEBSITE. BUT
THAT WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
WITH OUR FIRST AUTHOR AND I'M
PLEASED TO SEE THAT WE HAVE ARE
NOT- SUMMER SOLID SO WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH ITEM NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY SEVENTY BY SEMI
RISALA SO WELCOME. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU- MEMBERS I
WOULD START BY SAYING THAT IT
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS- TODAY AND I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL. I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
TO THE COMMITTEE WHICH WILL
ADDRESS MAJOR BIO SECURITY
CONCERNS WITHIN THE GENE
SYNTHESIS INDUSTRY. A. B.
SEVENTY WILL MAKE CALIFORNIA
THE FIRST STATE IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY TO ENSURE THAT PUBLIC
SAFETY SCREENING GUIDELINES.
ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED BY GENE
SYNTHESIS COMPANIES WHO SELL.
MANUFACTURE DNA ONLINE. JUST
LAST YEAR SCIENTISTS HAVE SHOWN
THAT IT IS POSSIBLE TO
RECONSTRUCT VIRUSES LIKE COVE
IN NINETEEN. AND EVEN WORSE
DISEASES LIKE EBOLA. BY USING
MAIL ORDER DNA THAT CAN BE
PURCHASED THROUGH THE INTERNET
FROM GENE SYNTHESIS COMPANIES.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE NO
REQUIREMENTS OF GENE SYNTHESIS
NEED TO SCREEN THEIR CUSTOMERS.
AND THEIR ORDERS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE NOT CRIMINALS WHO
MIGHT BE PURCHASING THE
BUILDING BLOCKS OF A DEADLY
PATHOGEN. AB SEVENTY- WITH AB
SEVENTY CALIFORNIA WILL BE THE
FIRST STATE TO ESTABLISH A SET
OF BEST PRACTICES WITHIN THE
GENE SYNTHESIS INDUSTRY TO
ENSURE THAT THE BAD ACTORS
CANNOT ASSEMBLE DANGEROUS
DISEASES. FROM PRODUCTS SOLD BY
COMPANIES DOING BUSINESS IN OUR
STATE. THIS BILL IS A
COMMONSENSE. SAFETY MEASURES
THAT HAVE SUPPORT FROM BOTH THE
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY AND THE
GENE SYNTHESIS INDUSTRY AS THIS
BILL HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION WITH ME TODAY BY
PHONE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. IS
DOCTOR GIGI GROVEL A SENIOR
SCHOLAR AT THE JOHNS HOPKINS
CENTER FOR HEALTH SECURITY. AND
AN ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH AND ENGINEERING. AT THE
JOHNS HOPKINS BLOOMBERG SCHOOL
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. ALSO ON THE
LINE TO HAVE AARON SMITH SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS AT TWIST BIOSCIENCE A
GENE SYNTHESIS. COMPANY
OPERATING IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A MEMBER
AND THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
WHAT WHAT THE COMEDIAN TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS WILL NOW-
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON THE
LINE OR TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT A DOCTOR GIGI
GROUNDBALL FROM JOHNS HOPKINS
CENTER FOR. HEALTH SECURITY AND
ERIN SMITH FROM PUBLIC POLICY
TWIST BIOSCIENCE BEGIN WITH.
DOCTOR GIGI GROWN OF ALL YOU
HAVE TO MINUTES- TO GO OVER
I'LL GIVE YOU THE TWO MINUTE
WARNING BUT THEN THAT WILL COME
OUT THE TIME THAT THE
SUBSEQUENT SPEAKER. SO PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE. THANK YOU FOR
ADDRESSING BY SECURITY CONCERNS
ABOUT GENE SYNTHESIS WITH THE
SPELL IT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER MY
SUPPORT- MY NAME IS JUDY GROUND
BALL AND MY BACKGROUND. IN THE
BIOLOGICAL SCIENCES AND I SERVE
ON FEDERAL ADVISORY COMMITTEES
FOR AN AGENCY- T. ON EMERGING
BIOTECH AND SECURITY. I'VE ALSO
SERVED AS A COMMITTEE MEMBER
FOR THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NATIONAL ACADEMIES REPORT ON
BIODEFENSE IN EGYPT BACKGROUND
G. WE CONCLUDED THAT ONE OF THE
MOST PRESSING BY A SECURITY
RISK. WE FACE IS THAT A BAD
ACTOR USE GENE SYNTHESIS
PRODUCTS TO MAKE PATHOGENS
PARTICULARLY SMALL VIRUSES.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD REQUIRE
BACK HE SAID THAT HIS COMPANY'S
CLEANER ORDERS. AND THAT
CUSTOMERS ONLY USE COMPANIES
THAT PERFORMED BY A- BY A
SECURITY SCREENING. THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD MAKE IT
HARDER FOR NEFARIOUS ACTORS
ACCESS NOW TO MAKE SURE YOU
DON'T NEED IT T MAKE VIRUSES
LIKE SMALLPOX A BOWL OR
INFLUENCE THAT. THE ON GOING
COPING NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS A
CLEAR DEMONSTRATION OF WHAT CAN
HAPPEN IN THE SOCIETY AFFLICTED
BY A HEALTH SECURITY CRISIS.
THIS BILL CAN HELP TO MAKE THE
FIELD LOOKING PANICKY IN A
SAFER. AND ENSURE RESPONSIBLE
MANUFACTURING PROCESSES WITHOUT
LIMITING IMPORTANT BIOLOGICAL
RESEARCH. MANY COMMERCIAL GENE
SYNTHESIS COMPANIES ALREADY
VOLUNTARILY SCREEN CUSTOMER
ORDERS BUT IT'S BACK ON TIME
AND MONEY. THOSE RESPONSIBLE
COMPANIES HAVE BEEN AT A
COMPETITIVE BUSINESS
DISADVANTAGE. THIS LEGISLATION
LEVELS THE PLAYING FIELD SO
THAT ONLY HIGH UALITY
ORGANIZATIONS TAKE PART IN THE
EMERGING BIOTECH FIELD. IT'S MY
HOPE THAT CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
WAY FOR THE U. S. FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND OTHER
GOVERNMENTS TO PUT REGULATIONS
IN PLACE TO ENSURE THAT DNA
SEQUENCES OF PATHOGENS. DO NOT
FALL INTO THE WRONG HANDS.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
INCLUDING ME HERE AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP TO GUARD.
AGAINST THE THREAT. THANK YOU
THAT'S A MOVE ON EARN SOME.
FROM TWIST BY US PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU SEVEN FOR AN ME. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY ON
BEHALF OF TWINS AND THE OTHER
COMPANIES THE INTERNATIONAL
GENE SYNTHESIS CONSORTIUM.
CHRIS IS A COMPANY BASED IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE PROUD Q.
U. B. BASED IN CALIFORNIA AND
ARE A GLOBAL LEADER IN THE
FINTECH SPACE AROUND GENE
SYNTHESIS THE ANYTHING THAT
THAT. ANDWE HAVE BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT WORKING WITH DOCTOR
GRANVILLE AND OTHER GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES TO ENSURE THE BIO
SECURITY SAFETY FOR COMPANIES
LIKE TWITTER. THE RECENT
GUIDANCE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
GOES BACK TO TWENTY TEN AND
THERE HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLE
ADVANCES. RAPIDLY SINCE THEN
TWIST GOES ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
TWENTY TEN PANDERED ANTONIO THE
COMPANIES IN THE IGST WHICH IS
AN INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATION
FOR COMPANIES ACROSS THE WORLD.
WHERE MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA. THE END. YOU KNOW
COME ARE MAYBE. PRODUCT FOR BUT
MANY MANY ESPECIALLY FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES THAT RUN DNA
ACROBATIC DNA INTO THE COUNTRY.
OUR COUNTRY ARE NOT MEMBERS AND
DO NOT ADHERE TO THE ADDITIONAL
BIOSECURITY SCREEN PLATFORM. IN
MY ROLE AT TWISTED THE HEAD OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AND POLICY
AND WORK WITH MEMBERS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND THEY'RE
HEARTENED TO HEAR THAT THERE
WERE ALREADY IN CALIFORNIA
MARYLAND ON THIS ISSUE. AND
HAVE CONTINUALLY ASKED US IF
THE FEDERAL DILUTION IF NEEDED.
SO IT IS. DEFINITELY SOMETHING
THAT WE SUPPORT- HAVING THE
DIALOGUE AND YOU KNOW WITH MANY
OF OUR CLIENTS IN THE
PHARMACEUTICAL AND BIOTECH
INDUSTRY. THAT WE PROVIDE
RESOURCES FOR A DEBUT
INCREDIBLE R. AND D. CRITICALLY
HE PLANS FOR GOOD AND WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PLATFORMS
FOR GOOD ARE USED THAT WAY. AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO BEING A
CONTINUED RESOURCE AND WORKING
WITH. REPRESENTATIVE SOLITUDE
AND ANYONE ELSE TO MAKE SURE
THAT COMPANIES THAT ARE DOING
THE RIGHT THING FOR BIO
SECURITY BOTH AT HOME AND
ABROAD ARE NOT DISENFRANCHISED
FROM A BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE.
THANK YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU-
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
SEVENTY BEGAN WITH THE PUBLIC
GALLERY SEE NO ONE AT THE
MICROPHONE PUBLIC GALLERY-
LET'S MOVE TO. MMHM- SEE WHICH
FROM THIS ONE TO SIGNALING
TWELVE- MY PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR WHAT THE WHICH TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVENTY NAME
OR TAKE A POSITION ONLY. THANK
YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH A SPECIAL SUPPORT FOR A.
B. SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE. ONCE AGAIN FOR SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. JUST
ONE MOMENT. WHEN YOU GO TO THE
LINE NUMBER FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE FORTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS GREGORY TOLD ONCE I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT TWO EIGHTY
SEVENTY ON BEHALF OF THE
SCIENTISTS WORKING GROUP ON
BIOLOGICAL CHEMICAL SECURITY AT
THE CENTER FOR ARMS CONTROL AND
NONPROLIFERATION. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. AND ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A. B.
SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
CHAIRPERSON OF THE TIME I HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. OKAY THANKS
VERY MUCH BOB REITER. WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY SEVENTY
THERE'S NO REGISTERED LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS TO TESTIFY-
SO WILL THEN GO TO THE PUBLIC
GALLERY SCENE KNOWN. PUBLIC
GALLERY TESTER- THE FEMALE
OPPOSITION WAS MOVED TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE C. KNOWN ROOM TWELVE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO SHOULD
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
SEVENTY. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU ARE NOT POSITIONED AB
SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. OPPOSITION TO AB
ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. ONE
CAN MEASURE OF OPPOSITION AB
SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEY'RE ALL. ENSURE PERSON AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY SAYING
NONE- AGAIN WE ARE STILL
OPERATE AS A SUBCOMMITTEE SO
JUST MAKE NOTE FOR THOSE
WATCHING IF I HAVE ONE MORE
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE SHOW UP
I CAN TAKE I THINK WE CAN
ESTABLISH CORE- BUT SINCE WE'RE
NOT THERE YET. I WANT THANK
YOU- SIMILAR SOLACE FOR.
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE AND FOR
WORKING THE COMMITTEE ON THE
AMENDMENTS- I DO HOPE THAT
THERE IS FEDERAL ACTION I THINK
IS PERHAPS MORE OF A-
ULTIMATELY GO TO A FEDERAL
ISSUE BUT- YEAH. CALIFORNIA IS
A LEADER IN BIOTECH SO. IT
MAKES SENSE FOR CALIFORNIA TO
TAKE THE LEAD AND HOPEFULLY
ESTABLISH A STANDARD AT THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY WILL FOLLOW
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. FRANKLY ASK FOR AND I
HAVE A ONE TIME TO PROCREATE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
AS WELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR SOLACE AND AGAIN ONCE
WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM WE'LL BE.
WE'LL TAKE IT UP FOR A VOTE.
ALRIGHT LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO- EIGHTY THREE
FORTY SEVEN BY SOME MEMBER AND
ALLOW WELCOME. JUST GIVE US A
MOMENT TO TIDY UP THE PODIUM
HERE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE AND FURTHER
RECOMMENDED IMPROVEMENTS AND I
AM HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. I'M HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT ON AB THREE
FORTY SEVEN A BILL DESIGNED TO
TREAT PATIENTS AS UNIQUE
INDIVIDUALS. THANKS TO MORE
QUICKLY PRESCRIBE MEDICATION
EFFECTIVE FOR THEIR SPECIFIC
CONDITIONS. CURRENT UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT IS THE PRIMARY
SYSTEM IN PLACE TO GUIDE
PRESCRIPTION DECISIONS AND
INCLUDES BOTH PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION AND STEP THERAPY.
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION ALLOWS
INSURERS TO DENY COVERAGE OF
SPECIFIC MEDICATIONS AND STEP
THERAPY ALLOWS INSURERS TO
DESIGN TREATMENT REGIMENS WHICH
RELY ON A FAILED FIRST APPROACH
STEPPING THROUGH ALTERNATE
MEDICATIONS BEFORE LANDING AT
THE RIGHT MEDICATION. COUCHED
AS A COST SAVINGS MEASURE THIS
SYSTEM TAKES US FURTHER FROM
THE IDEAL APPROACH OF
INDIVIDUALIZED TAILORED
MEDICINE. EIGHTY THREE FORTY
SEVEN MOVES US IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND EMPOWERS
PHYSICIANS TO IMMEDIATELY
CONNECT PATIENTS TO THE RIGHT
MEDICATIONS GIVEN THEIR MEDICAL
HISTORY AND DISTINCT SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES. TO DO SO THIS
BILL CREATES A PATHWAY FOR STEP
THERAPY EXCEPTIONS AND
IDENTIFIES A NUMBER OF
SITUATIONS WHERE AN EXCEPTION
TO STEP THERAPY COULD BE
REQUESTED. FURTHER EIGHTY THREE
FORTY SEVEN CREATE A FRAMEWORK
THROUGH WHICH EXCEPTIONS ARE
EVALUATED AND DECISIONS
CONVEYED TO THE PHYSICIAN OR
PRESCRIBER. FINALLY THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT APPEALS AND
REVIEWS OF EXCEPTION DENIALS
ARE CONDUCTED BY PROFESSIONALS
IN THE SIMILAR FIELD WHO CAN
PROPERLY EVALUATE THE CASE.
SIMILAR EXEMPTIONS HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED IN MORE THAN TWENTY
STATES BUT TO BE CLEAR THIS
BILL DOES NOT PROHIBIT STEP
THERAPY OR USE OF GENERICS.
RATHER IT ESTABLISHES A
STANDARD TRANSPARENT PROCESS
FOR PHYSICIANS TO EVALUATE THE
PATIENT'S CIRCUMSTANCES
IDENTIFY IF AN EXTENSION COULD
APPLY AND REDUCE HARM BY
IMMEDIATELY PRESCRIBING THE
BEST MEDICINE FOR THE PATIENT.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AND I'M JOINED TODAY
BY JENNIFER APPEL A GRAND DR
SAMI MATTEL YES. OKAY THANKS
VERY MUCH SENATOR RANDALL AND
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS- WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF-
EIGHTY THREE FORTY SEVEN- SO
WE'LL BEGIN WITH. BECAUSE WE
HAVE WELL WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES
WHO ARE TESTIFYING SO DR SAMI
MATUS PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA RHEUMATOLOGY
ALLIANCE SO MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING BACK THE DETAILS ON THE
LINE AS WELL AS- JENNIFER
TELEGRAM. FROM THE NATIONALS
THRICE'S FOUNDATION I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S ALSO ANOTHER
WITNESS WHO'S JUST AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS HE'S NOT
TESTIFYING BUT THERE'S
QUESTIONS IN COMMITTEE THE
FIELD FROM THE THRICE
FOUNDATION SO. LET'S GO AHEAD
AND- BRING ON TO THE LINE BOTH-
DOCTOR PATEL YES AND JENNIFER
GRAND AND WE'LL BEGIN WITH DR
MATTEO S. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
TOTAL FOR MINUTES BETWEEN BOTH
OF YOU. THANK YOU THE DOCTOR
SAY MEDIA THINK TEACHER AND
MEMBERS OF HIS COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS DOCTOR SAID MAKE IT A
LITTLE MORE POLICY CONSULTING
CALIFORNIA AND CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA WITH
ALL THE ALLIANCE. THE GREATEST
CHALLENGE WE HAVE AS A
RHEUMATOLOGIST IS BEATING WAS
BATHERS. TO OBTAIN PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION TO START OUR
MISSION ON CONFLICT MITIGATION.
IT CAN TAKES WEEKS OR EVEN
MONTHS. TO GET THE MEDICINE
APPROVED. MANY TIMES DUE TO
BALE'S LACK OF RESPONSE.
SOMETIMES WE MUST ACCEPT PLAN
EFFECTIVE MEDICATION OR EVEN
MEDICATIONS THAT'S NOT SUITABLE
FOR THE PATIENT CONITION AND
FOR PUTTING THE STEPS UP. THAT
THE BABY IS MANDATED FOR
PATIENTS CONDITION EVEN IF THAT
PEACE AND PRIDE AND FEELS THE
MEDICATION BEFORE WITH OTHER
INSURANCE. THIS PROCESS IS
LENGTHY AND EXHAUSTING. AND IT
CAN TAKE A FEW MONTHS UNTIL OUR
PATIENTS GET THE RIGHT
TREATMENT ABOVE ALL IT TAKES A
LOT OF TIME FOR THIS INTO RIGHT
FIELD. AND SOME QUESTIONS IN
BETWEEN SEEING PATIENTS AND
NEED MULTIPLE EMPLOYEES TO FILL
OUT FORMS. I WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT ONE OF MY POSITION MRS
AP FIFTY THREE YEARS OLD HAS TO
FLY BECAUSE COVERING 90% WITH
BUDGET. TWENTY SEVENTEEN SO
GREAT BECAUSE TRY TO SPREAD
DELIVERED AND HIGH LIVER ENZYME
THE BETA MEN DEFEAT. US TO THE
START BUTTON MIDDLE TEXAS FOR
THREE MONTHS TO START A
BIOLOGIC DOCTORS THAT
METICULOUSLY CONSTRUCTED LIVER.
AND IT. WOULD GIVE HER A GIVEN
SUBJECTS INCLUDE THOSE AT WORK
WILL THAT BE AT IT WHAT IT
MEANT AND THIS INCLUDES LIVER
ENZYME EVENTUALLY THEY HAVE TO
DECREASE THE DOORS AND STOP IT.
AND LATER ON WE CAN. FIELD
WHATEVER AND YOU MADE A FULL
TWO YEARS STILL SUFFERING FROM
SWOLLEN JOINTS AND PRETTY
PRETTY GETS RIGHT THE CRASH.
SHE NEED TO FIFTY THREE POINT
TWELVE THE CONDITION AND NOT
HAVE TO DELIVER ALSO AS USUAL
WAS SUBMITTED FOR CONSENT
DECREE. AND IT TAKES LONG TIME
TO GET THIS AUTHORIZATION
APPROVED INITIALLY INTO BOXES
AND IT DENIED FIRST AND
MULTIPLE PROCESS WAS DONE. THAT.
WE SHOULD HAVE SUFFERED IN THAT
BATHROOM AND- TRYING PUNK
SOMEBODY KEEPS. OTHERS DO WE
AND IF EFFECT ON HIM CARE OUR
HE DID. POSITION WEEK WEEKS A
MONTH SUFFERING WITHOUT GETTING
TWO MINUTES THIS IT'S BEEN
HOURS YES I BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE
AND INSURANCE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WHEN THE TIME THAT ANY.
THANK YOU NOW LET'S BRING
JENNIFER PELLEGRI- YOU KNOW
HAVE MINUTE AND NINE SO. GOOD
MORNING. A MEMBER OF THE SENATE
HELP COMMITTEE MANY IS JENNIFER
HOW AND I'M READY FOR NURSE
FROM CALIFORNIA I LIVE WITH THE
RIGHT RIGHT IN THE CHRONIC.
DISEASE THAT HAS NO CURE. SORRY
TO BE THE COMPANY TO TREAT AND
I HAVE TO WORK WITH BUT THE
GERMANS AND RHEUMATOLOGISTS.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN MY HOUSE HER
TEAM I DETERMINE BY LAW WOULD
WORK BEST FOR ME. HOWEVER I
WOULD DIE WHEN MY INSURANCE FOR
EACH OF OUT THREE DIFFERENT
MEDICATION FOR. I'D LIKE TO SEE
MY DOCTOR YOU START WITH YOUR-
MY INSURANCE COMPANY MAYBE TRY
AND PROPER CREAM FOR THREE
MONTHS. EVEN THOUGH I HAD
ALREADY USED THEM FOR YEARS
WITH NO RESULT. THAT MEANS
COMPANIES ATTEMPTED TO FORCE ME
INTO TRYING A MEDICATION THAT
WAS PARKED RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR MY LIVER. AFTER THREE
YEARS OF MEDICAL DOCUMENTATION
TO SHOW THE THREAT THEY FINALLY
ALLOWED ME TO BUY PROPERTIES
THAT. THE THIRD AND FINAL DAY
OF THE INSURANCE COMPANY MAYBE
JUMP THROUGH ME MIGHT THINK
THAT EVEN WORK. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THE RIGHT LIKE YOU
PEOPLE TRYING TO PRACTICE ON MY
BODY BUT THIS STEP THERAPY
TREATMENT FOR PRIMARY INSURANCE
COMPANY. EXACERBATED MY FRIES
SO THAT WOULD JUST BE ONE MONTH
IT COVERED 90% OF MY BODY. THE
THREE COMPANIES THAT. I DON'T
HAVE TO STAY ON THE STREET. FOR
TWO MORE MONTHS TO PROVE
FAILURE. AFTER FOUR YEARS
INSURANCE. FOR A BYLAW TARGETS
MAKES I GOT. HOW MANY MONTHS.
THE AND TRYING. BETTER BUT BY.
DO WOULD NOT WORK YES. SIR
REALLY. ON YOUR WAY. FROM
FRIDAY BY LARGE THE PACKING
SLIP ON. MY GREAT PAIN IS
MANAGEABLE AND FOR THE FIRST
TIME THOUGHT WE- THAT I CAN
HELP YOU FOR. I'M HERE TO AFTER
YOUR SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY THREE
FORTY SEVEN. I HEARD FROM MY
STORY CASES LIKE ME CAN'T WAIT.
HELP CALIFORNIA IF THE RIGHT
MEDICINE AT THE RIGHT TIME I
COPY. EIGHTY THREE FORTY SEVEN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANKS
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TEST. WILL
NOW MOVE TO THIS WITNESSES
SUPPORT OF THREE FORTY SEVEN
WE'LL BEGIN WITH THE- PUBLIC
GALLERY. PLEASE BEGIN NAME FOR
THIS POSITION. HOLD ON CAN WE
PLEASE BE SURE TO MICROPHONES
ON. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M FRED NO WE'RE
REPRESENTING THE PHARMACEUTICAL
RESEARCH AND MANUFACTURERS OF
AMERICA IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I SEE NO
OTHER WITNESSES AND GALLERY
LET'S MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
THING ON ROOM TWELVE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE FORTY
SEVEN NAME OR POSITION POSITION
ONLY. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN AND
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB THREE FOUR
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE.
WE'RE GONNA GO THE LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SURE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ONCOLOGY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT
RENEWAL LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU DR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ALEX
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT TO A
LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING KATIE LATER
ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN
SPECIALTY CARE COALITION AND
SUPPORT TO KILL THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. THANKS TO A LINE NUMBER
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR RYAN SPENCER
ON BEHALF OF THE CROHN'S AND
COLITIS FOUNDATION'S WE ARE CO
SPONSORS ON A MEASURE AND
PRODUCT SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THANKS TO
A LINE NUMBER FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
FORMER TOP ON BEHALF OF BY
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT TO
THE LINE NUMBER SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. UNDER A TARIFF
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. SIX OF THE
LINE NUMBER TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
AND SAID A MOTHER FROM LOANS
FOR LUPUS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NEXT TO A LINE
NUMBER NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CREST ROAD BY ON BEHALF OF
BIOGEN IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THANKS TO
THE LINE NUMBER NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DIMITRIUS THEY
WERE A NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU EXLINE. RECORD A LINE
NUMBER SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU JULIA BALLS ON BEHALF
OF THE NATIONAL TRANSFORMATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
HELLO LINE NUMBER FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS NEIL RUBENSTEIN ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL MULTIPLE
SCLEROSIS SOCIETY WE SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU EXLINE. FOR
YOUR LINE NUMBER EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I CAN- BORDER
ON BEHALF OF. THE EUROPEAN
ACCESS FOUNDATION AND NATIONAL
IMPLEMENTATION AND SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
SIX OF THE LINE NUMBER TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR STEVE HORN
ON BEHALF OF I CAN ONLY DO
NATIONAL CANCER ADVOCACY
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY THREE POINT SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. TO A
LIE NUMBER THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR- ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
RHEUMATOLOGY AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. A LITTLE LINE
NUMBER FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING REBECCA
BIRCH ON BEHALF OF SUSAN G.
KOMEN IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
EXLINE. WHAT A LINE NUMBER
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MICHELLE REPAIR BUT THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. THE LITTLE LINE
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS MARK YELL ON THE PATIENT YOU
CAN SMELL GREAT EMPLOYED AND I
REPRESENT THE INTERNATIONAL
PEMPHIGUS AND PEMPHIGOID
FOUNDATION I SUPPORT EIGHTY
THREE FORTY SEVEN AND ASK THAT
YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. NEXT LINE. UBER LINE
NUMBER NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT IN CALIFORNIA AND
FORT THANK YOU LINE. YOUR LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS STEPHANIE DOWNES
KERR WAS A BOARD MEMBER FOR THE
MUSLIM COUNCIL CALIFORNIA AND
YOUR- ADVOCACY COMMITTEE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. WE'LL GO
TO LINE NUMBER FIFTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING LINDA
WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY WE ARE CLEAR WITH
THE SUPPORT OF MEDICATION WE
APPRECIATE THE OFFICE WORK I
CANNOT SUPPORT THE PROVISION
WHICH PURPOSELY EXCLUDE
MEDICARE PLAN IF WE BELIEVE YOU
CAN ALWAYS HAPPEN. NAME ONE
THING OR THE SESSION ONLY
THANKS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
EXLINE. WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BRANDON MARCHING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
POLITE NUMBER NINETY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SURE
NUMBERS AUTOMOTIVE NETWORK THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK ALSO IMPORTANT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
OVER THE LINE NUMBER ONE A LOT
OF PEOPLE AHEAD. A TEACHER
NUMBERS TEN BAD REPRESENTED
CALIFORNIA RHEUMATOLOGY
ALLIANCE WE'RE PROUD CO SPONSOR
OF AB THREE FORTY SEVEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
BORDERLINE NUMBER FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M LESLIE
WATER AND GOLD RIVER AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. AND ONCE AGAIN MADE
GENERAL IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF A. B. THREE FOUR SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. A CHARITY THAT STEVEN
SCHULTZ OF THE REFERENCE I'M ON
THE- WITNESS LINE. ON BEHALF OF
OUR PRESENTATION- CO SPONSOR
THE BILL IS GOING TO REGISTER
OUR SUPPORT LIKE YOU MENTIONED
I'M HERE FOR. A TECHNICAL
SUPPORT NEEDS. OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU I HOPE WE GET TO
COMMITTEE MEMBER QUESTIONS SO
WE'LL SEE IF SOMEONE. IS
CALLING YOU THANK YOU. RIGHT
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I'LL BE ONE MOMENT PLEASE. I'M
SORRY YOUR LINE NUMBER ONE ALL
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT
ALL RIGHT. THE POLITICAL THANK
YOU. SIX NINE. MAYBE JUST ONE
MORE MOMENT PLEASE. THE BRIDGE
PROCEDURE PATIENTS BE JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT. I GOT A LINE
NUMBER SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FINALLY CALIFORNIA
ACCESS COALITION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIRPERSON WE HAVE
NOBODY ELSE IN Q. RIGHT THANKS
VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO- WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE
UNDERSTAND THE STANDARDS TO
LEAVE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
NECK LOUISA STUFF IN CALGARY SO
SEE TO HEALTH PLANS IS THAT THE
WALK INS FROM ATHLETICS SO- IF
THE MODERATING PLEASE BRING
THEM ON THE LINE. WILL BEGIN
WITH- NICOLAS LOUISE AS- HELLO
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
NICKEL RESULTS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS- WE ACTUALLY HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL AND- WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR. THE SPONSOR.
ON ANY COMMITTEE FOR THE OPEN
LINE OF DIALOGUE ON THIS BILL-
A NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS HAVE
BEEN TAKEN OR WILL BE TAKEN
SOME OF WHICH IMPROVED THE BILL
BUT WE STILL HAVE SOME WORK TO
DO. OUR PRIMARY CONCERNS WITH
EIGHTY THREE FORTY SEVEN WHEN
IT WAS INTRODUCED IS THAT IT.
ENCOURAGES THE UTILIZATION OF
MORE EXPENSIVE AND RISK YOUR
BRAND NAME DRUGS. AND IS
ADMINISTRATIVELY BURDENSOME ON
PLANS AND PROVIDERS WITH THOSE
BURDENS OUTWEIGHING. MEMBERS
HELP WHEN YOU STEP THERAPY FOR
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS TO CONTROL
HEALTHCARE COSTS. ENSURE
PATIENT SAFETY AND ENCOURAGES
PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS TO
UNDERTAKE A MORE EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACH TO TREATMENT. FOR
POTENTIALLY- MORE ADDICTIVE
THAN RISKIER DRUGS IT WAS A DAY
THAT ARE COMMONLY ABUSED. ON
HEALTH POINT AND IMPROVE
INFLUENCE THAT THERAPY
PROTOCOLS AS A WAY TO MAXIMIZE
TREATMENT AND DISEASE
MANAGEMENT WHILE REDUCING THE
RISK ASSOCIATED WITH OVER
MEDICATION. ABUSE AND ADDICTION
WE ARE ALWAYS CONCERNED THE
LEGISLATION ALLOWS PROVIDERS
AND PATIENTS SKIP PASSES
CAREFUL APPROACHING THE STREETS
THE USE OF RISK YOUR DRUGS.
HAVING SAID THIS OUR MEMBERS DO
NOT OPPOSE THE CONCEPT BEHIND
THIS MA'AM MEASURE. AS DRAFTED
HOWEVER IT IS STILL PLACES
OVERLY BROAD RESTRICTIONS ON
THE USE OF STEP THERAPY.
RESULTING IN HIGHER UTILIZATION
MORE COSTLY AND RISK YOUR BRAND
NAME DRUGS OVER SAFER AND LOWER
COST ALTERNATIVES- WE MUST ALSO
KNOW THAT EXISTING LAWS AND
REGULATIONS ALREADY PROTECT
CONSUMERS BY ALLOWING ENROLLEES
OR OTHER PROVIDERS. TO REQUEST
AN EXCEPTION TO HELP PLAN STEP
THERAPY PROTOCOLS FOR
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. I'M A
DESPITE PRIOR TESTIMONY TODAY
THERE ARE TIME LINE SAY IN LAW.
I'M IN A SPIRIT OF COMPROMISE
WE HAVE OFFERED AMENDMENTS SOME
OF WHICH HAVE BEEN TAKING
IMPROVE THE BILL- WE VERY
RECENTLY RECEIVED THEIR ORIGIN
THAT IS PROPOSED TO BE ADOPTED
BY THE COMMITTEE TODAY AND WE
WILL RESCUE ONE RESPONSE THE
AUTHORS SPONSORING COMMITTEE.
ONCE WE GET MORE FEEDBACK FROM
OUR MEMBERS. ONE OUTSTANDING
ISSUE IS THE INSISTENCE IN THE
BILL TO USE CLINICAL HERE. TO
REVIEW STEP THERAPY OVERRIDE
OPINION IF THEY ARE DENIED TO
MINIMIZE IT SOUNDS REASONABLE
ON PAPER. WHAT SHOULD THANK
YOU- THE WAY THAT THIS TERM IS
DEFINED AS A REASONABLE WOULD
BE IMPRACTICAL AND COSTLY TO
IMPLEMENT. WE'VE OFFERED
OFFERED AN ALTERNATIVE WITH THE
BASIS IN EXISTING PRACTICING
LAW. AND WE JUST HAVE TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSING THIS ISSUE
MOVING FORWARD FOR NOW WE
REMAIN OPPOSED THE LESS-
FURTHER AMENDMENTS ARE TAKEN
THANK YOU MR. THANKS VERY MUCH.
THE BRING ON STAFF- WHAT CAN.
FOR MAC WICK- V. SIX HAVE A
MINUTE AND. NINE AND STEP IF
YOU COULD YOU COULD YOU PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
APOLOGIZE THE STRIPPERS WERE
HAVING A LITTLE DIFFICULTY
GETTING HER ON THE LINE OKAY.
BUT SHE'S NOT COMING ON THE
LINE WILL JUST MOVE ON TO THIS
NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IF
HE COMES ON THE LINE LET ME
KNOW. SO ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO THIS NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY THREE
FORTY SEVEN PM PUBLIC GALLERY
SCENE ON THE PUBLIC OUT OF THIS
ROOM. MOVED TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
EIGHTEEN NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE BUT WE FEEL THAT THEY'RE
KNOWN ROOM WITH TWELVE.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY THREE
FORTY SEVEN. THANK YOU ONE TEN
LADIES GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE AN
OPPOSITION AB THREE FOUR SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN OPPOSITION TO
AB THREE FOUR SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND MISTER CHAIRPERSON SHOW
KNOWN IN Q. OKAY LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
YES CENTER ADMIN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- THANK YOU DOCTOR
REGULAR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I KNOW I HAVE NOTICED
AS BILL HAS BEEN MOVING THIS
WAY MY TWITTER ACCOUNT GETS
BLOWN UP A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE A
OT OF OPINIONS ON ON THE STEP
THERAPY CAN YOU CAN YOU TALK A
LITTLE BIT THROUGH ABOUT WHAT
ALL THE OPPOSITION. IT'S ABOUT-
SEEMS TO BE A LOT OF WHAT THE
QUITE A BIT OF OPPOSITION JUST
IF YOU COULD JUST TALK ME
THROUGH THE- THE- THANK. WHY SO
MUCH. I'M NOT SURE I CAN SPEAK
FOR THE OPPOSITION TO EXPLAIN
THEIR POINT MAYBE I CAN SPEAK
TOWARDS THE NEED FOR US TO MAKE
THE CHANGES TO STEP THERE WOULD
BE GREAT SO FOR TOO MANY
PATIENTS THEY HAVE DELAYS AND
MEDICATIONS THAT ARE
APPROPRIATE FOR THEM BECAUSE
THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT AND THE
STEP THERAPY. MEDICATION WHICH
IS BEST TAILORED FOR THEIR
NEEDS BASED ON THEIR HISTORY AS
A SEVEN MEMBER DO YOU MIND
SPEAKING CLASSES AND MICROPHONE
SO THAT WE CAN HEAR OKAY THANK
YOU APOLOGIES I WAS TRYING TO
SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THE SENATOR
INSIGHT INTO MY TOWN YES HAPPY.
FOR US TO- SO WHEN I'M- TALKING
ABOUT UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT
IT'S FOR ME TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING THE RIGHT
MEDICATION. TO THE RIGHT PERSON
AT THE RIGHT TIME. THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY
SEEN DONE- SEPTEMBER FIRST
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE- AND
YOU KNOW YOU'VE TAKEN SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE- THAT WE
FELT THAT WAS OFFERED BY THE
OPPOSITION THAT MADE SENSE-
ALSO- SO I APPRECIATE THE
OPPOSITION'S- PRESENTATION BUT
ALSO WANT TO BE SURE WE
PRESERVE. THE VERY IMPORTANT
ATTENTIVE YOU BUILD BE SURE
THAT PATIENTS ARE ABLE TO GET
THE MEDICATION THAT THEY NEED-
WITHOUT DELAY- AND NORDIC DELAY
IT CERTAINLY MEDICATIONS THAT
THEY'VE ALREADY TRIED BEFORE
THAT- IS THAT PROVEN NOT TO
WORK OR THAT- DID IT AND DID
YOU KNOW JUDGMENT OF PHYSICIAN
WOULD DIE NOT NECESSARILY BE
OF. SIGNIFICANT BENEFIT- WHILE
STILL ALLOWING THEM TO DO-
YOU'LL BE SURELY- HELLO QUALITY-
AND SO THAT'S ALL THE
GUIDELINES I ALSO JUST WANT TO
MAKE NOTES- IT TAKE THE WESTERN
LAMPARD HE DID MAKE MENTION OF.
WE'RE NOT COVERING MEDIC COW
AND THERE ARE TRANSFORMATIONS
GOING MEDICAL- PHARMACEUTICAL
PURCHASING- AND DISTRIBUTION
DATA OVER THE NEXT. YEAR OR TWO
THAT HOPEFULLY WILL ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT THE-
THAT- FEATURES BY THIS BILL
WHICH UNFORTUNATELY ARE BEING
LEFT OUT BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND
WHY AT THIS POINT TIME- YOU
YOU. WERE WHEN YOU KNOCK
LOOTING IT IN THE BILL- BUT
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL AS THE
MEDICAL PHARMACEUTICAL PROCESS.
INVOLVED SO WE CAN RESOLVE THAT
IN THE FUTURE AS WELL IT'S
CERTAINLY WE WANNA BE SURE
THOSE PATIENTS- ARE ALSO HAPPEN
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
SURE. TO GET THE BENEFITS OF
THIS KIND OF POLICY SO- WITH
THAT- WOULD YOU LIKE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. IT I WILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE
WHEN THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH. AGAIN WE ARE
WE ARE STILL. ONE SHORT OF A
CALL. SO THERE IS I KNOW THAT
MANY PEOPLE AND MANY OTHER
COMMITTEES AND SO THERE'S ONE
OTHER MEMBER CAN SHOW UP WE'LL
TAKE A QUORUM CALL- BUT- WILL
CONTINUE SUBCOMMITTEE WILL MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTY
THREE SIXTY NINE BY CENTCOM
LOGGER AGAIN AS I MAY NOTE AT
THE BEGINNING- WE ARE GOING TO
HEAR A PRESENTATION. OF THIS
BILL TODAY I UNDERSTAND TO SOME
OF THE WITNESSES- WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE AVAILABLE NEXT WEEK-
AND- WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON US AMENDMENTS WHICH I
GUESS I WILL COLLABORATE MORE
ON- AFTER THE PRESENTATIONS-
BUT THEN WE'LL BE VOTING ON.
THE BILL NEXT WEEK AND WILL OF
COURSE SOMEONE SURE THE
COMMITTEE HAS BEFORE THEM THE
FULL AMENDMENTS UP PRIOR TO
THAT BOAT- SO WITH THAT-
WELCOME CENTER COME LONGER-
PLEASE EGIN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR AND I FOR JUST WANNA-
THANK YOU PUBLICLY FOR ALL OF
THE HELP THAT YOU HAVE- OFFERED
IN MAKING THIS- STILL A
STRONGER- YOU AND YOUR STAFF.
IS A GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO ASK
HERE I MOVED ON AB THREE SIX
NINE THE STREET MEDICINE ACT.
WHICH EXPANDS ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CARE AND SOCIAL SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. YOU KNOW ONE
MOTHER'S DAY I HAD THE GOOD
FORTUNE OF. MEETING A HOMELESS
FAMILY THAT IS IN MY DISTRICT A
WOMAN KIANA HER HUSBAND AND
THEIR THREE CHILDREN AND- THEY
SAT IN THEIR HOUSE. WHICH WAS
ALSO THEIR BROKEN DOWN SCV. AND
TALK TO ME ABOUT ALL THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY FACE
TRYING TO FIND HOUSING AND ALSO
TRYING TO FIND HEALTH CARE. AND
HOW THEY ARE BUMPED FROM
ORGANIZATION TO ORGANIZATION
FILLING OUT APPLICATION AFTER
APPLICATION. AND GETTING NO
SERVICES. HE HANNAH AND HER
FAMILY- ARE ONE OF HE SIXTY
SIX THOUSAND PLUS. HOMELESS
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING ON THE
STREETS IN LA COUNTY A 13%
JUMP. FROM TWENTY NINETEEN.
THAT'S MORE THAN ANY OTHER CITY
IN THE COUNTRY. BUT LA IS NOT
THE ONLY COUNTY SUFFERING FROM
THIS CRISIS IT'S IN ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
IN CALIFORNIA CONTAINS HALF OF
ALL THE HOMELESS PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES. YOU KNOW KIANA
AND HER FAMILY BECAUSE THEY ARE
HOMELESS HAVE INCREDIBLY
COMPLEX AND FLUID NEEDS AND
THEY HAVE LESS ACCESS TO
PREVENTIVE PRIMARY AND
SPECIALTY HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
CAN I WAS TRYING TO GET
PREGNANT SHE AND CHALLENGES
WITH THAT SHE NEEDED POSTNATAL
CARE SHE HAS THREE YOUNG
CHILDREN OF VARYING AGES NONE
OF THEM. GET ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE BECAUSE OF OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM. MANY OF THE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS ARE INSURED THROUGH
MEDI CAL HELLO ALL HOWEVER EVEN
WHEN INSURED 73% HAVE NEVER
SEEN A HEALTH CARE PROVIDER OR
WHEN THEY DO SEE SOMEONE. THEY
ARE TURNED AWAY BECAUSE OF
BUREAUCRATIC BARRIERS. STARTING
WITH THE ENROLLMENT PROCESS
WHEN YOU ENROLL IN MEDICARE ALL
YOUR INSURANCE CARD WITH THE
NAME OF YOUR SIGN PROVIDER IS
MAILED TO YOUR HOME ADDRESS
HAHA IF YOU'RE HOMELESS WHAT IS
THAT ADDRESS. EVEN IF YOU'RE
LUCKY TO FIND OUT WHO YOUR
DOCTOR IS. MANY ARE RELUCTANT.
TO LEAVE ALL OF THEIR
BELONGINGS AND THEIR PRO. ON
FOR OR BEHIND. WITH NO WAY
TRANCE THEM TO THE- WHEN THEY
GO TO THE VESSEL. DEALING WITH
THE ANXIETY OR THIS. OF HAVING
TO WAIT AND SHOW WHAT I THAT
MAY NOT HAVE OR SHARE PERSONAL
MEDICAL HISTORY THAT YOU MAY
NOT REMEMBER. AND FINALLY IF AN
ID CARD IS STOLEN OR EVEN
TRADED. MANY LACK ANY FORM OF
OTHER IDENTIFICATION AND ARE
THUS THUS TONIGHT ALL HEALTH
AND SOCIAL SERVICES THAT WOULD
BE COULD BE COVERED BY MEDI CAL.
AND SO THEN WITHOUT ACCESS TO
MEDICAL CARE YOU ALL KNOW THE
STORY. THE IN HOUSE POPULATION
OVER UTILIZE EMERGENCY ROOMS
WHERE THEY OFTEN ARE PRESENTED
WITH MULTIPLE ADVANCED
CONDITIONS WHICH LEADS TO
INCREASED RATES OF
HOSPITALIZATION AND RE
ADMISSION AND THAT IS IF THEY
SHOW UP. SO THE MAINSTREAM
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY MODELS DO
NOT FIT THE REALITY OF THE
STREETS. AND IF WE ARE GOING TO
REALLY HELP THEN WE NEED TO RE
ENGINEER PORTIONS OF OUR
DELIVERY SYSTEM TO MEET PEOPLE
WHERE THEY ARE WHERE THEY ARE.
WHEREVER THEY ARE AND WHENEVER
THEY ARE IN THOSE PLACES AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT IT IS
HAPPENING THERE ARE TWENTY FIVE
STREET MEDICINE TEAMS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE DOING JUST
THAT. BUT THESE PROGRAMS THESE
TEAMS ARE CURRENTLY FUNDED
THROUGH PRIVATE GRANTS BUT THEY
PROVIDE MEDICAL AND BEHAVIORAL
CARE TREATMENT FOR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS IN ROME AND
SOCIAL SERVICES AND ASSISTANCE
WITH HOUSING TRANSITIONS IN
FACT IN LA COUNTY ALONE. WHEN
ON HOUSE POPULATIONS ARE
WORKING TO GET HOW PLACEMENT TO
HOUSING TO LHASA. IT'S AT A 6%
SUCCESS RATE WHEN THEY WERE TO
GET HOUSING THROUGH THE STREET
MEDICINE TEAMS AND SET A 42%
SUCCESS RATE. ALL OF THIS CARE
IS PROVIDED FREE OF CHARGE IT
IS DELIVERED ON SITE INCLUDING
DISPENSING MEDICATIONS DRAWING
BLOOD FOR TESTING THE PATIENTS
DON'T HAVE TO SCHEDULE
APPOINTMENTS FIND
TRANSPORTATION TO THE CLINIC
PICK UP PRESCRIPTIONS OR PAY
FOR THEIR TREATMENT. THEY ARE
REFERRED TO A SPECIALTY OF
SPECIALISTS THEY ARE TAKEN
RIGHT THERE IMMEDIATELY THE
BARRIERS THAT MAKE HOMELESS
PEOPLE MUCH STICKIER ARE
REMOVED SO THAT HEALTH CARE CAN
BE ADMINISTERED A CUTE AND ON
GOING. BY PROVIDING CONSISTENT
PRIMARY CARE TO THE HOMELESS
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE SHOWN TO
REDUCE AVOIDABLE EXPENSIVE
HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS AND
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS BY TWO
THIRDS RESULTING IN SIGNIFICANT
COST SAVINGS FOR THE STATE. BUT
DESPITE THESE BENEFITS MEDICARE
CURRENTLY DOES NOT ALLOW FOR
PROVIDERS TO TREAT PATIENTS ON
THE STREETS SO A. B. THREE SIX
NINE. GETTING TO THE JUICE OF
IT ALL RECOGNIZES THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF OUR HOME HOUSE
POPULATION BY EXTENDING MEDI
CAL PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY TO
THE HOMELESS FOR MOVING ID CARD
REQUIREMENTS FOR RECEIVING
CARE. ALLOWING ON HOUSE
PATIENTS TO RECEIVE
COMPREHENSIVE MEDICAL BENEFITS
OUTSIDE THE WALLS OF A
TRADITIONAL MEDICAL CLINIC. I'M
PROUD THAT WE'VE RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. IN
COMMITTEES AND ON THE FLOOR IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A SINGLE GROUP IN
OPPOSITION. YOU KNOW A LOT MORE
IMPORTANTLY I'M PROUD TO HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF SO MANY FOLKS
WERE AND HOUSED- WHO ARE LIVING
IN CAMPS IN ON THE STREETS
EVERY DAY. LAST MONTH WHEN THIS
WAS HEARD IN THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSING COMMITTEE WHEN IT
PASSED OFF THE FLOOR WE WERE
TOLD. THAT THERE WAS AN
ENCAMPMENT THAT WAS BEING
ADMINISTERED TO TREAT MEDICINE
AND THEY ALL STOPPED AND
CHEERED. AND THEY'RE LISTENING
TODAY. HERE WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IS BRETT FELDMAN WITH
THE STREET MEDICINE INSTITUTE
AND DR MATT MARY MURPHY C. WITH
THE UCLA DEPARTMENT OF FAMILY
MEDICINE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ERICA MARKERS MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING ON THE LINE BRETT FELDMAN
FROM THE USC DEPARTMENT FAMILY
MEDICINE AT ST MEDICINE
INSTITUTE AND DR MARY MARTHA C.
FROM THE CLI DEPARTMENT FAMILY
MEDICINE WILL BEGIN WITH BRETT
FELDMAN YOU HAVE. TWO MINUTES.
TO INTERVIEW FOUR MINUTES. UP
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU TO A
DOCTOR AND COMMUNITY ACCOUNT
SENATOR TOM LONGER INSTRUMENTAL
CAN WE GO TO THE PEOPLE FIRST
TO DELIVER A TENDER LOVE. AND
THEN THE SAME QUALITY
HEALTHCARE ON THE TREE THAT YOU
WOULD EXPECT IN A BRICK AND
MORTAR CLINIC. AFTER SPENDING
THE PAST. FOURTEEN YEARS UNDER
FREEWAYS AND RIVERS. PERFECT AT.
THEIR REALITY I'VE LEARNED THAT
PART OF THE REALITY IS THAT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN MEDICARE
ELIGIBILITY. AND MEDICAL ACTOR
A GAP THAT D. D. THREE SIX NINE
WILL CLOSE. THIS IS NECESSARY
BECAUSE THERE'S NO CLEAR
MECHANISM TO REIMBURSE FOR
THREE MINUTES AND- NOT BECAUSE
OF THE SERVICES THAT WE'RE
DELIVERING A BECAUSE OF.THE
LOCATION WHERE SHE DELIVERED.
EIGHT THREE SIX NINE RECOGNIZED
BY ALLOWING HER TO TAKE IT AS
WELL I MEAN SHE MET HIM AND HE
REIMBURSED FOR SERVICES. WHICH
ARE ALREADY REIMBURSABLE BY
RECOGNIZING THE NECESSITY TO
PRACTICE OUTSIDE FOUR WALLS SHE
OTHER IMPORTANT RESULT OF THE
P. THREE SIX NINE AND ALLOWING
PATIENTS DIRECT ACCESSSTREET
MEDICINE PROVIDERS. MEANING.
THAT EVEN WHEN THEY CAN'T
ACCESS. AND THEREFORE THERE. A
FEDERAL. WE CAN BUILD A THEM
WITH THE THEY NEED. MEDICATION
PLOWED HERE FOR ALL. CORRECTLY
ON THE STREET. YEAH OF COURSE
ALSO DIRET THE OF. TO CALAMP
LITTLE. CAROL AND HAND CARE
MANAGER A LITTLE AT BUT
GOALKEEPER EXCLUDE MEDICAL.
I'LL WE COULD NOT REACH. NINE
CARTER OVERWHELMING DR THANK
YOU BYE PROVIDED SHE- DIDN'T
ENCOUNTER PARK ACADEMIC MEDICAL
IN LAW WORKING BUT ARE
PROLONGED POVERTY MA. HE TOOK A
FEW AS WELL AS NPOS NO OPTION.
DIFFICULT ISSUES RECOGNIZING
MEDICAL MOBILITY ABOUT FOR
PUBLICATION LIVERY AND PRESERVE
THE FLEXIBILITY. BIDEN REALITY
HEALTHCARE THE POPULATION WITH
HER AND IN DOING SO ALSO
RECOGNIZES THE PEOPLE THAT WE
ALL COLLECTIVELY SEARCH AND
HUMAN. LIFE IS WORTHY OF OUR
LIVES. SH SH. THANKS THANK YOU
OKAY EXCELLENT RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW LET'S BRING ON DR
MERION MERCY. HELLO AND I'D
LIKE TO THINK THAT YOUR PAN AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK HERE TODAY ABOUT A
TOPIC THAT IS VERY DEAR TO ME
MEDICAL CARE OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. MY
NAME'S MERRY MARKEY DOCTOR
MARQUIS FROM A PHYSICIAN IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAMILY MEDICINE
AT UCLA. FIFTEEN YEARS MY
MEDICAL PRACTICE HAS BEEN
EXCLUSIVELY DEDICATED. TO
PROVIDING MEDICAL CARE FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS. I
PRACTICE IN STREETS IN
CAMERON'S EMERGENCY SHELTERS
TRANSITIONAL HOME OF THE
NINETEEN KRAJ THROUGH KEY HOTEL
REALLY ANYWHERE WHERE PEOPLE
ARE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
UCLA DEPARTMENT OF FAMILY
MEDICINE HAS BEEN DOING THIS
FOR ABOUT THIRTY TWO YEARS BUT
IT'S ESPECIALLY DURING THESE
LAST FOUR FIVE YEARS WE'VE SEEN
A MARKET INCREASE. IN PEOPLE
LIVING ON THE STREETS. TOGETHER
WITH PHYSICIANS RESIDENTS AND
STUDENTS WE'VE TREATED OVER
EIGHTY SIXTEEN EIGHTY THOUSAND
PATIENTS RANGING IN AGE FROM
NINETY TWO TO A NEW BORN JUST
TWO DAYS OLD. EIGHTY THREE
SIXTY NINE IS ALL ABOUT ACCESS
THE OVER ARCHING COMPLAINT
AMONG THE THOUSANDS OF PATIENTS
WE CAN IN OUR COLLECTIVE STORY
IF. THEY'RE PERSISTENT BARRIERS
TO CARE. THAT DRESS SO WELL BY
EIGHTY THREE SIXTY NINE
ALTHOUGH SOME OF THE TIME THE
PRIMARY HAVE AN ASSIGNED
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER IN THE
SYSTEM. HOMELESS PATIENTS
EXPERIENCED PROHIBITIVE ACCESS
AND OFTEN GET DROPPED BY THE P.
C. P. WITHOUT EVEN KNOWING IT.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE COME IN. BY
THE SAME STANDARD OF CARE THAT
WE WANT IN OUR REGULAR HEALTH
CARE SETTINGS. I WISH I HAD
TIME TO TELL YOU ABOUT SOME OF
THE STORIES OF THE TERRIBLE
HEALTH PROBLEMS THAT WE SEE IN
OUR HOMELESS POPULATION. AND
THE UNFORTUNATE CONSEQUENCES
GIVEN THE RUNAROUND LACK OF
ACCESS TO CARE SUCH AS THINGS
LIKE. DENTAL ABSCESSES TOO LONG
CAUSING MENINGITIS LEADING TO A
COAL MINE A LONG TERM
HOSPITALIZATION- THERE HAVE
BEEN SOME PROPOSED LAST MINUTE.
AMENDMENTS THAT WE THINK WOULD
LIMIT OF TREATMENT ESSENTIAL TO
PROVIDERS. FROM PERFORMING EVEN
THE SIMPLE DIAGNOSTIC TESTS.
FOR REFERRING TO SPECIALISTS
WHEN NEEDED. THAT WOULD NEGATE
THE WHOLE IMPETUS FOR THE BELL
N. AS A LICENSED ADDICTION. I'M
CONCERNED THAT IF WE KEEP US
FROM PROVIDING THE KIND OF
COMPASSIONATE BASIC STANDARD OF
CARE. TO HELP. PEOPLE OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS- SO I ASK YOU-
WHEN YOU GET A CHANCE TO VOTE.
TO VOTE FOR THE BILL ENTERED
WITHOUT THE HANDMAID'S WRAP UP
THEN DON'T WORRY DOCTOR PAIN
YOU CAN COUNT ON US TO. GIVE
OUR EXPERIENCE AND DEDICATION
THESE ROBOTS WORK TIME'S UP
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW LET'S. MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND- SO.
OF EIGHTY THREE SIXTY NINE WILL
BEGIN WITH PUBLIC. EIGHT THREE
EIGHT. I'M SORRY I'LL START
WITH THE MICROPHONE ON EVERAL
THINGS BEGIN YEAH OKAY RANDY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PARTICULARLY
TIMELY BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THE MORNING MOLLY ROBSON
WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES IN CALIFORNIA WERE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. OKAY SEE
NO ONE ELSE AT THE GALLERY WAS
MOVED TO ROOM ONE TWELVE C.
KNOWN ROOM TWELVE- MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY THREE
SIXTY NINE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE SUPPORT OF AB
THREE SIX NINE PLEASE PRESS ON
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BY YOUR LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ERIC HARRISON WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT OF A. B. TWO SIX NINE
THANK YOU THANKS LINE. MEXICO
LINE NUMBER SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS CINDY HILLARY
I'M HAPPY THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION WEREN'T
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL OUT
TO BRITAIN NOT WITH A YOUNG MAN
THANKS- I CHICKEN NINETEEN NOW.
THANK YOU NEXT NEXT LINE. NEXT
TO THE LINE NUMBER EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS IN THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT LITTLE LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
KERN COUNTY THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA AND LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI ON SUPPORT
THIS MORNING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT WOULD ALIGN
NUMBER ONE OH SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING DONNA
THANKS REPRESENTING A LOCK INTO
THE COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE
SIXTY NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. THANKS TO A LINE
NUMBER FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR ASKING ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS SEE IF HE
IS SUPPORT AT EIGHTY THREE
SIXTY NINE AND PRINT THEM AT
ALL WELCOMELANGUAGE ON
PROVIDER THING THAT YOU CAN
LOOK FORWARD TO LOOKING AT THE
CHEROKEE OFFICE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. SIX ZERO
LINE NUMBER ONE OH ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU YOUR
NUMBERS TO MADDEN REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NEXT CALL LINE
NUMBER FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING LINDA AWAY
WITH WESTERNS AND- ON POVERTY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
THANKS TO A LINE NUMBER ONE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU KELLY BEAM ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH NET AND CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND WELLNESS COVERING
ABOUT TWO MILLION MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. IN SUPPORT.
EIGHTY THREE SIX NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THANKS TO
A LINE NUMBER SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
UNDER TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
SIX ZERO LINE NUMBER FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
CONNIE CHAN ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE TREASURER UNIMOG CALLING
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
FAX LINE. SIX WHAT LINE NUMBER
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CALL THE RECORDS
WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION THE
COURT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
MEXICO LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS SERRA HELPFUL FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXT WILL ALIGN NUMBER THIRTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS SHELBY DO VERY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACCESS COALITION IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANKS THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. NEXT THE LINE NUMBER
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORE
IN THIS IS ACTUALLY ON BEHALF
OF PAST PEOPLE PUT IN THE
HOMEWORK AND SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
THREE SIXTY NINE THANK YOU I
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THE
NATIONAL LINE NUMBER SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A LITTLE BIT
ON THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY HEARING HEALTH AGENCY
THE COURT. THANK YOU NEXT TIME.
SIX OF THE LINE NUMBERS THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
HEADLINE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT
CALL ONE NUMBER ONE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS. I THINK YOU FEEL
LIKE YOU AND ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF ALLIED FOR
ESSENTIAL MEDICINES I'M TRYING
TO SUPPORT THE SCHOOL. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. SIX WERE LIABLE
ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEPTENTRIONAL ON BEHALF OF THE
KECK MEDICINE AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND PART
OF THE BILL IN PRINT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THANKS TO
A LINE NUMBER THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
CHARLY JIANG AND I'M I'M NOT
I'M A UCLA MEDICAL CENTER SANTA
ANA CALIFORNIA TRANSPORT EIGHTY
THREE SIX NINE AND A CURRENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER ONE
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONCE
AGAIN WE'RE GOING TO ONE ONE
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MOVING
ON WE'RE GOING TO WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER NINETY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING THIS
IS JASMINE DIEGO WITH UCLA
HEALTH AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LIKE HER TO GO LINE NUMBER
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANY
CHANCE HE WOULD NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER SUPPORTING
THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM
THANK YOU THAT'S FINE. AND ONCE
AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
THREE SIX NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE CAN
SUPPORT FOR A. B. THREE SIX
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR PERSON
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. OKAY THANKS VERY
MUCH I WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY THREE
SIXTY NINE THERE'S NO
REGISTERED- WITNESS THAT
OPPOSITION FOR TESTIMONY WILL
GO TO PUBLIC GALLERY. YOU KNOW
THE PUBLIC ALAN SMITH ROOM
TWELVE SEEN ON ROOM TWELVE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHICH TESTIFIED
IN OPPOSITION TO AB THREE SIXTY
NINE. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU ARE AN OPPOSITION AB THREE
SIX NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE DUE
AT THE TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO AB THREE
SIX NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. BRING YOUR LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KENNEDY
OLYMPIAN AND STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. AND ONE
MORE TIME LADY GENERATED
THROUGH AN OPPOSITION AB THREE
SIX NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE TO RE
ELECT ACCOUNT. MISTER
CHAIRPERSON AT THIS TIME I HAVE
KNOWN IN Q. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU- BEFORE WE BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE I JUST WANT TO-
MENTION TO THE COMMITTEE- FOR.
IN TERMS OF FIRST OF ALL I
THINK A CENTCOM LOGGER FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE- WE
ARE WORKING ON TRYING TO
ADDRESS SOME ISSUES THERE
POINTED OUT I THINK IN THE NOW
ASSISTS- UNDER THE POLICY
COMMENTS BUT PARTICULARLY- BE.
WORKING OUT- MECHANISMS TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE- FOLLOW UP
CARE AND COORDINATION OF CARE
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE PROVIDING
MORE THAN IF YOU CARE FOR
EXAMPLE HAVE INVOLVED FOR ALL
THE SPECIALISTS ARE EXTENSIVE
STUFF YOU KNOW. MORE EXPENSIVE
FORMS OF TESTING OR IMAGING ARE
THOSE TYPES OF THINGS. AND ALSO
TRYING TO ENSURE THAT- KNOWING
THAT THE POINT OF THE BILL IS
TO. ACTUALLY GET PAYMENT FOR
THESE PROGRAMS I THINK IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IS THAT WE
ALSO ASSURE THAT THERE'S-
APPROPRIATE MECHANISM OF
PAYMENT THROUGH THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM AS WELL SO I DO
APPRECIATE- THE CENTRE WORKING.
WITH OUR COMMITTEE AND ALSO
MANY OF THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL AS WELL AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE AT. FOURTEEN WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO GET IT ALL IN
ALL THE LANGUAGE AND SO FORTH-
RESOLVED BY TODAY BUT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR TO BE ABLE TO BRING
THIS BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
NEXT WEEK- WITH WITH THOSE
WORKED OUT. BUT AGAIN REALLY
APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO- BE ABLE TO
GET THAT TOO TWO PEOPLE SENT-
SO WITH THAT- I ENDO DATA
CENTER ADMINS. I THINK YOU. AND
THANK YOU CENTER COMMANDER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- YOU KNOW
AS- YOU KNOW I'M A I'M A SOCIAL
WORKER AND I HAVE AN OFFICE
FULL OF SOCIAL WORKER SO MY
STAFF HAS BEEN VERY INTERESTED
IN THIS BILL- AND TRACKING IT
AS IT'S GONE ALONG WITH A LOT
OF CONVERSATION ABOUT IT- I
APPRECIATE A HEART THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING TO IT THE ACTUAL NEED.
THAT IS HERE. AND I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR IN TRYING
TO REALLY WORK OUT THE DETAILS
BECAUSE I KNOW OFTENTIMES. OUR
IDEAS ARE FANTASTIC BUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF IT. WE JUST
DON'T WANT TO TURN THAT PART
INTO SOMETHING THAT WAS THAT WE
DIDN'T INTEND. I AM ALSO SORRY
THAT WE'RE NOT HERE FOR REAL
ROBUST CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS
TOO. I MEAN AS YOU KNOW THIS.
TIME OF COMMITTEE. BUT I THINK
THIS THAT THIS ISSUE IS ONE OF
HUGE VALUE. AND I WOULD LOVE
WHEN YOU CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THE AMENDMENTS. IF I COULD BE
ADDED ON AS A CO AUTHOR AND
WORK WITH YOU ON THIS- AND ALSO
OFFER UP HOWEVER I CAN HELP
WITH THAT ITH THE CHAIR AND
THE COMMITTEE. ON MAKING SURE
THAT WE LAND THIS IN A- IN A-
IN A WAY THAT I THINK. AGAIN WE
TAKE CARE OF THE DETAILS OF IT.
BUT WE ALSO. MAINTAIN THE HEART
OF IT AS AS WE GO FORWARD.
THANK YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS YESTERDAY AS I WAS
THANK YOU MR CHECK TO WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD- THIS IS. VERY
VERY IMPORTANT I WOULD LOVE. TO
ALSO SEE IF WE CAN GET LONG
BEACH ON BOARD- BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE OUR OWN HEALTH DEPARTMENT
AS I OFTEN TALK ABOUT IN. THIS
IS THIS IS DIRE FOR LA COUNTY-
SO I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AS WELL
AND I JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORTS IN BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I KNOW WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS- WITH
DOCTOR PAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ALL
RIGHT AND THEN OUT OF IT SO I
JUST FINALLY SAY BEFORE IT DIED
YEAH YOU MAKE YOUR CLOSES AGAIN
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD WE WANT TO
SUPPORT ST MADISON- WE KNOW
THAT PEOPLE AS YOU OR EIGHT
POINT OUT SO ELOQUENTLY OR
OKAY. YOUR PRESENTATION- PEOPLE
AREN'T GETTING CARE- THEY'RE
SUFFERING OUT THERE- THEY DON'T
SIT IN THE EXISTING MODELS SO
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE-
MAKE THESE AS THE MODELS-
ESSENTIALLY UP WHILE. THEY
CERTIFICATE ACCESS GIVEN THE
SITUATION AND SO I APPRECIATE-
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
TOGETHER TO MAKE. THAT HAPPEN
AND WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE- AND WANNA SAY THANK YOU
TO THE MEMBERS WHO SPOKE AND
WHO. ARE INTERESTED IN JOINING
ON AS CO AUTHORS I WANT TO ONCE
AGAIN THANK. THE CHAIR AND HIS
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US. ON
THIS BILL I THINK YOU CAN TELL
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS IF YOU HAVE
SOMEONE FROM USC AND UCLA
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF IT. AND
WITH THAT I WILL RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR THE I BELIEVE NEXT
WEEK. RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
S. R. CAMARGO LOOKING FOR TO
OUR CONTINUED- THE- DIALOGUE
AND LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
PRESENTATION TO. THE FOUR OF US
THE COMMITTEE NEXT WEEK THANKS
VERY MUCH. OKAY I AM GOING TO
NEED TO STEP OUT TO MY OTHER
COMMITTEE- SO. SIR EDMUND DO
YOU- DO YOU MIND TAKING OVER
THE CHAIR AND I KNOW WE CAN-
WE'RE GONNA HAVE. SOME MEMBER
MAY'S PERCENT- ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR OKAY DOVE- EDUCATION SO.
THIS IS- SO RECREATIONAL
WEAPONS- SO LEADS TO POOR AND
THERE'S- I'M NOT NOT NOT IT'S
ONLY NO OPPOSITION ON THIS ONE
HOPEFULLY NOW IF YOU GET IN
THAT AREA YEAH. SO OKAY ALL
RIGHT SO ANYWAY THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW. OKAY
PLEASE. DO YOUR PHONE- BUT OKAY
OKAY. ALL RIGHT MOST WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OKAY I THINK
TODAY YOU'RE PRESENTING A B.
FOUR FOUR ONE FOR US. AND THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND- MEMBERS- I
APPRECIATE UP TO TESTIFY BEFORE
YOU TODAY ON ABC FOUR FOUR ONE.
SIMPLY MY THIS LEGISLATION
PICKS UP WHERE A. B. ELEVEN
SIXTY ONE LEFT OFF LAST SESSION
AFTER IT WAS VETOED THIS EFFORT
SEEKS TO CREATE HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS APPLICABLE TO
DEDICATED SURFING WAVE BASINS.
WHICH ARE NEW TO CALIFORNIA AND
GENERATE REAL SEARCHABLE WAVES
AND A HUNDRED THOUSAND SQUARE
FOOT FIFTY MILLION GALLON
GALLON BODY OF WATER. THESE
WAIT BASINS ARE SEPARATE AND
DISTINCT FROM WAVE POOLS AND
SWIMMING POOLS. THE UNIQUE
CHARACTERISTICS OF A MAN MADE
WAVE BASIN INCLUDE THE VOLUME
OF WATER CHEMICAL DISPERSION
CAUSED BY WAVE ACTION WATER
CLARITY OCCUPANCY RATE THE SIZE
OF THE WAVE BASIN MEANS THEY
CAN'T PROPERLY BE REGULATED. BY
EXISTING GUIDELINES FOR
pWATER PARKWAY POOLS. IT'S
INTRODUCTION WE TOOK A MOMENT
TO ADDRESS THE VETO LETTERS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND US RELATIONS AS WELL
AS FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH IMAGE
TAKEN IN ASSEMBLY HEALTH. SINCE
IT HAS ARIVED IN THIS HOUSE A
CD PH REMAINS OPPOSED THE
MEASURE THE DEPARTMENT DOES
RELATIONS SENT AN OPPOSITION
LETTER JUST LAST WEEK
ADDRESSING MORE MINUTES FELL
SHORT. OF ADDRESSING THEIR
CONCERNS I AS WELL AS MY
SPONSOR ME COMMITTED TO FINDING
A RESOLUTION FOR THE PROPER NEW
REGULATORY STRUCTURE MUST
CREATE FOR CALIFORNIA WAY
BASINS. SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO
BUILD THEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA
INSTEAD OF OTHER STATES LIKE
FLORIDA TEXAS THAT HAVE ALREADY
PASSED SIMILAR REGULATORY
FRAMEWORKS. WITH THAT I'D LIKE
TO INTRODUCE MY WITNESSES-
ADDRESS ON BEHALF OF THE WORLD
SURF LEAGUE. THE YOU VERY MUCH.
I HAVE MODERATOR FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE I THINK WE HAVE THAT
CHOICE WITH US FROM KEEPING
PUBLIC AFFAIRS WORLD SURF
LEAGUE. GOOD MORNING SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ACTUALLY SOME
HALF THE WORLD SURF LEAGUE
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
FOUR FORTY ONE TODAY. WSL THE
GLOBAL ORGANIZATION BASED IN
SANTA MONICA CALIFORNIA. NINE
ITS OWN PROFESSIONAL SURFING. I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR PUTTING THIS MATTER FORWARD.
WITNESSES INVEST TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. AND GENERATE
LONG TERM ECONOMIC BENEFITS.
EIGHTEEN NEW TOURISM
DESTINATION OLYMPIC ORGANIZERS
ARE ACTIVELY LOOKING AT USING
WAY BASED ON TECHNOLOGY TO
SUPPORT CERTAIN EVENTS IN
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. ALL STATES
LIKE TEXAS AND FLORIDA HAVE
ADOPTED UNIQUE RULES AND
REGULATIONS TAILORED
SPECIFICALLY FOR WAVE BASINS.
CALIFORNIA STILL TREATS WAY
BASED ON THE SAME AS PUBLIC
SWIMMING POOLS OR AWAY FOR YOU
MIGHT FIND AT THE LOCAL WATER
PARK. THIS CREATES A
DISINCENTIVE. FOR DEVELOPERS TO
BRING THESE PROJECTS THE
CALIFORNIA. AB FOUR FORTY ONE
ADDRESSES THIS PROBLEM BY
CREATING NEW HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS AROUND WATER QUALITY
SANITATION PROCEDURES. IN THE
UNDERLYING EQUIPMENT THAT
GENERATES THE WAVE. THE SCALE
THESE MENUS WHICH IS ROUGHLY
OVER. SIX FOOTBALL FIELDS LONG
AND CONTAINS OVER. FIFTEEN
MILLION GALLONS OF WATER
WARRANT THEIR OWN SET OF RULES
AND REGULATIONS. OTHER KEY
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN SOME
IMPORTANTLY BASINS INCLUDE. THE
CONSTANT WATER CIRCULATION
CREATED BY BREAKING SIX FOOT
WAVE. PERSON STATIC WATER
TURNED OVER BY PUMPS. LOW USER
CAPACITY VERSUS HIGH USER
CAPACITY. AND FINALLY THE
PRINCIPAL RECREATIONAL USE. IS
FOR SURFING NOT SWIMMING.
LARGELY THE SAME BILL THIS
COMMITTEE PASSED LAST SUMMER
BUT CONTAINS SEVERAL NOTABLE
CHANGES TO ADDRESS THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE. THESE
CHANGES INCLUDE STRENGTHENING
CAL OSHA'S ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY. IN EXPANDING THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REFERRAL. THERE ARE SEVERAL
OUTSTANDING ISSUES REMAINING
AND WE'RE ENGAGED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH IN
CALIFORNIA. LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA ESTABLISHES. A
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK THAT IS
PROTECTIVE OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
AND I ASSURE I BUILT THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW WILL GO WILD. FOR OTHER
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT WE GO TO THE
GALLERY I DON'T SEE ANYBODY UP
THERE WE LOOK AT ROOM ONE
TWELVE I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
THERE- UP OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN
THE LINE TO SAVE OTHER PEOPLE
IN SUPPORT. FOR A B. FOUR FOUR
ONE. OKAY ONCE AGAIN IT'S ONE
OF THEM ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR A B. FOUR FOUR
ONE. ONE ZERO. WHEN WE DO A ONE
LINE THAT'S QUEUED UP COMES
FROM THE LINE OF EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO OUT.
HI I AM AN ATTORNEY AND I AM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
CALLERS MODERATOR. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY
LISTED AS LEAD OPPOSITION. I DO
NOT SEE ANYBODY- HERE OR IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE- MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
FOUR GB. FOUR FOUR ONE. ONCE
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
THAT SHOW OPPOSITION FOR A B.
FOUR FOUR ONE. ONE ZERO. AND WE
DO NOT EVER ANYONE IN Q. OKAY
THANK YOU LET'S BRING IT BACK
THEN TO THE COMMITTEE- IS THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING NONE-
SUMMER MAY THANK YOU- I KNOW
THIS IS APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I KNOW THAT-
WE'RE- STILL IN CONVERSATIONS
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH- I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT THEY HAVE
THE REGULATORY POWER TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT THEY-
MENTIONED. THAT THEY WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT- SO MY MIND
THEY CAN STILL ADDRESS THEY CAN
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE THROUGH
REGULATION- BUT WITH THAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. SURE THE
GAME THANK YOU MISTER FOR ALL
OF YOUR WORK ON THIS- IT
DOESN'T NEED TO BE SAID BUT
SURFING IS A REALLY BIG DEAL IN
CALIFORNIA- AND THE WITH THIS
THESE NEW WAVE BASIN SO WE CAN
CONTINUE TO LEAD THE WORLD. IN
SURFING IT IS MY HOPE THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE WORK WITH THESE-
WITH THESE AGENCIES TO COME UP
WITH A REGULATORY STRUCTURE
THAT WILL WORK- I UNDERSTAND IT
THEY'VE- THEY'VE THEY'VE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL OF COURSE
HAS BEEN VETOED IN THE PAST.
WE'RE HOPING THAT THAT WILL
WORK WITH US TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE REGULATORY STRUCTURE IS
WHAT IT NEEDS TO BE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN MAKE THIS
HAPPEN IN CALIFORNIA. WITH THAT
AS FOR THE REQUEST OF MY VOTE.
RIGHT THANKS FOR MUCH SUMMER
MEZA WE'RE STOPPING THE
SUBCOMMITTEE SENT US OUT TO
SCORN YET BUT WHEN IT
APPROPRIATE TIME WE WILL- WE
CHECK ON THE STATUS WILL TAKE
UP THE VOTES OF THANKS VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
OKAY I DON'T SEE ANY. AUTHORS
HERE AT THE MOMENT. OKAY SO
JUST WANNA LET YOU KNOW IF YOU
HAVE A COMMITTEE HAVE A
BILLBOARD COMMITTEE ON HEALTH-
WE ARE AVAILABLE SO WE HAVE
BILLS FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBERS IN
THIS AREA AND GIVE SEND ROBERT
REAVIS XU X. MAHER CG GABRIEL
AND MCCARTY.
HUH I SEE A SEVEN
MEMBER IN THIS AREA AND WELCOME
SO LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY FIVE
BY SEVERN IS ERIN- WELCOME.
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR. AND SENATORS- THIS YOU
SHOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
BILL IN THIS COMMITTEE TODAY A.
B. EIGHT THIRTY FIVE WOULD
REQUIRE A HOSPITAL EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT TO OFFER AN HIV TEST
AT ANY PATIENT FOR WHOM A BLOOD
DRAW IS ALREADY BEING DONE. WE
HAVE TAKEN SEVERAL AMENDMENTS
IN ORDER TO MINIMIZE ANY BURDEN
ON THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT AND
I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO THANK THE
CHAIR. AND HIS STAFF FOR THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT WE
WILL BE TAKING TODAY. WITHIN
OUR AMENDMENTS WE HAVE ADDED
SEVERAL EXEMPTIONS. FROM THE
MANDATE WHICH INCLUDE IF THE
PERSON IS IN A LIFE THREATENING
SITUATION. OR IF THE PERSON HAS
A PATIENT WITH THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT WITHIN THE PREVIOUS
TWELVE MONTHS. WAS OFFERED AN
HIV TEST AND CONSENTED TO IT.
OR IF THE PERSON IS PREGNANT
AND WAS TESTED PURSUANT TO
EXISTING LAW. AND FINALLY IF
THE PERSON IF THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT KNOWS THAT THE
PATIENT HAS HIV OR HAS BEEN
TESTED FOR IT. WITHIN THE
PREVIOUS TWELVE MONTHS. WE HAVE
ADDED A MINIMUM AGE OF TWELVE
WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
MOST RECENT GUIDELINES ISSUED
BY THE UNITED STATES PREVENTIVE
SERVICES TASK FORCE.
FURTHERMORE THE BILL ALLOWS THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT TO USE
RAPID HIV TESTING FOR SOME TEST
KITS. THE BILL ALSO ALLOWS FOR
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT TO
REFER ITS PATIENTS WITH A
POSITIVE TEST RESULTS THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT OR THIRD
PARTY. THAT IS QUALIFIED TO
PROVIDE POST HIV TESTING
COUNSELING. AND AS FOR PATIENTS
WHO LEAVE THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT PRIOR TO RECEIVING A
TEST THEY WILL BE REFERRED TO A
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT OR A
QUALIFIED THIRD PARTY. PROVIDED
IT HAS A BUSINESS ASSOCIATE
AGREEMENT WITH THE HOSPITAL-
THESE ARE ALL THE AMENDMENTS
WE'VE TAKEN SINCE THE BILL HAS
BEEN IN THE SENATE NOT TO
MENTION THE SEVERAL OTHERS WE
TOOK IN THE ASSEMBLY WE'VE DONE
OUR BEST TO WORK WITH EXISTING
OPPOSITION TO FIND A COMPROMISE
THAT DOES NOT SACRIFICE THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR BILL BUT
DESPITE OUR EFFORTS OPPOSITION
REMAINS IN THEIR SAME POSITION
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS
ARE THE LAST MAJOR COMPONENT OF
THE HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM
FOR HIV TESTING DOES NOT
ROUTINELY OCCUR. THE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION CALLED ON ROUTINE
HIV TESTING IN A T. D.'S MORE
THAN THREE DECADES AGO
ACCORDING TO A REPORT RELEASED
BY THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR
BIOTECHNOLOGY INFORMATION THEIR
FINDINGS SUGGEST THAT EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT VISIT RATES IN
CALIFORNIA INCREASED FROM
200-052-2000 FIFTEEN ACROSS ALL
AGE GROUPS AND PARTICULARLY
AMONG THE UNINSURED AND
MEDICAID IN SHORT BLACK AND
HISPANIC POPULATIONS. THEY
FOUND THAT THE INCREASED
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISIT
RATES BY THESE POPULATIONS MAY
REFLECT LIMITATIONS IN ACCESS
OF CARE IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THE FINDINGS
EVEN STATE THAT RATHER THAN
FOCUSING ON WAYS TO REDUCE
EERGENCY DEPARTMENT USE
POLICYMAKERS SHOULD RECOGNIZE
THAT EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS PLAY
A VITAL ROLE IN THE PROVISION
OF CARE AND CONSIDER WAYS TO
INCORPORATE THAT REALITY INTO
THE DELIVERY OF HEALTH
SERVICES. OTHER STATE AND
NATIONAL REPORTS HAVE CONCLUDED
THAT POSITIVITY RATES ARE
HIGHER IN AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT THEN AND OTHER
HEALTH CARE OR TESTING SITES
ONE POINT 723% COMPARED TWO
POINT 9% OR LESS THESE REPORTS
ARE ONLY A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES%
OF LIGHT AP THIRTY FIVE IS
FOCUSED ON EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS. I NEED TO KNOW
THAT THIS BILL IS NOT INTENDED
TO INCREASE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT USE INSTEAD IT IS AN
OPPORTUNE. FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
AN HIV TEST SINCE MANY OF THEM
USE THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT AS
PRIMARY CARE. BECAUSE THEY DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO PROPER
HEALTH CARE. CALIFORNIA IS
KNOWN AS THE STATE THAT LEADS
THE NATION IN INNOVATIVE
THINKING AND LEGISLATION. BUT I
WANT TO ALSO NOTE THAT
ACCORDING TO THE CDC ALSO LEADS
THE NATION IN THE MOST NEW. HIV
CASES PER YEAR. THE STATE STILL
HAS MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE LIVING
WITH HIV AND IS EXPERIENCING.
FORTY FOUR HUNDRED NEW
DIAGNOSIS EVERY YEAR.
OPPOSITION WILL TELL YOU THAT
DESPITE THE TWELVE OR MORE
AMENDMENTS I HAVE TAKEN TO
ADDRESS EVERY SINGLE CONCERN
THEY HAVE HAD THEY REMAINED
OPPOSED BECAUSE ULTIMATELY.
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS ARE NOT
THE RIGHT PLACE FOR THIS
TESTING. THIS IS WHERE. I SEE
THAT THEY ARE WRONG. FOR ALL
THE REASONS I'VE JUST STATED.
SO IN CLOSING WELL I CAN. AND
AS A CLOSING THOUGHT FOR NOW.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO ASK ALL OF YOU
IS IDENTIFYING NEW PEOPLE WITH
HIV AND GETTING THEM INTO CARE
AND TREATMENT JUSTIFY JUST A
LITTLE MORE RESPONSIBILITY ON
THE STAFF. WITH THAT I. AM
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AND
ALSO INTRODUCE RAN MARTIN WHO
REPRESENTS OUR- BILL SPONSOR
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH A
CEMETERY AND- AND- IT'S NOT
CONFIRM YOU ARE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS CORRECT YES THANK
YOU SO MUCH WORKING COMMITTEE
ON THOSE SO WE'RE NOW GOING TO
TAKE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT WILL
BEGIN WITH THAT RAIN MARTIN WHO
I SEE IS UP IN THE GALLERY I'LL
MAKE NOTE THAT SINCE THE
OPPOSITION DOES HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I WILL
GIVE YOU UP TO FOUR MINUTES OF
OUT THE CLOSING TIME FOR BOTH
SIDES SO- REMARKS PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
HOPEFULLY WON'T TAKE THE FOUR
MINUTES BECAUSE OF DESERT
MISSOURI DID A GREAT JOB OF
SUMMARIZING THE BILL. FIRST OFF
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
HIS STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US.
ON IMPROVING THE BILL OVER THE
LAST WEEK OR SO AND MR MISSOURI
FOR STICKING WITH US FOR THE
LAST FEW YEARS TO. GET THIS
POLICY ADOPTED. MMHM THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT WE ARE REALLY GOOD
AT TESTING PEOPLE IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT MEDICAL FACILITIES.
WHERE WE'RE NOT GOOD ABOUT
DOING THAT IS IN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS- SOME HOSPITALS ARE
BETTER THAN OTHERS BUT MANY ARE
NOT DOING ROUTINE HIV TESTING.
AND WHAT THIS BILL SEEKS TO DO
IS TO REQUIRE THAT AT LEAST A
MANDATE TO OFFER- IS- IS
IMPOSED ON HOSPITAL EMERGENCY
ROOMS ON A GOING FORWARD BASIS.
MR NEWBERRY POINTED OUT WE
STILL GET FORTY FOUR HUNDRED
NEW CASES OF HIV EVERY YEAR.
THAT IS CAUSED IN GREAT PART BY
THE 15% OF THE PEOPLE WITH HIV
WHO DO NOT KNOW THAT THEY ARE
HIV POSITIVE- FORTY FIVE
PERCENT- OF THE THIRTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR. AGE RANGE DO NOT
KNOW THAT THEY'RE HIV POSITIVE.
AND THEY'RE CAUSING FORTY
PERCENT. OF THE NEW INFECTIONS.
WE NEED TO GET TO THOSE PEOPLE
EDUCATE THEM- MAKE SURE THEY'RE
AWARE OF THEIR HIV STATUS. SO
THEY'RE NOT UNINTENTIONALLY-
EXPOSING OTHER PEOPLE. AS A
MEDICAL CARE PROVIDER HF IS
VERY SYMPATHETIC. TO THE
ARGUMENTS HAVE BEEN RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION RELATIVE TO THE
BURDEN. ON THEIR OPERATIONS.
AND WE'VE DONE EVERYTHING WE
POSSIBLY CAN TO REDUCE THAT
BURDEN. OF PLAYED BY MANY MANY
MINUTES PER PATIENT- WITHOUT
GIVING UP ON THE FACT THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE. A MORE HIV
TESTING OCCURRING WITH THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE HARDEST TO GET
TWO. OF THEM FOR THOSE FOR
THOSE REASONS AND FOR THE
REASONS THAT MR NAJARIAN HAS
OUTLINED- WE URGE THE.
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY THANK YOU. THANKS VERY
MUCH L. L. MOVE ON TO. IT AS A-
OF EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY- SEE NO
ONE ELSE IN THE GALLEY LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEN ON
ROOM TWELVE MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES. FOR WITNESSES
WHO WAS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY FIVE.
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
OKAY ONCE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE OF THE ZERO. FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT THIRTY FIVE. ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THERE TO THE WITNESSES
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY FIVE SO
MODERATE CAN PLEASE BRING ON
THE LINE DEMAND FROM AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS
AND MARIA SPERBER FROM
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES A
TOTAL FOUR MINUTES BETWEEN THE
TWO OF YOU WILL BEGIN WITH-
TEMEN. THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS
TO MADDEN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS THAT WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY FIVE. MY
FIRST OF ALL WE'D LIKE TO THANK
MR NEWS ARIAN IN THE SPONSOR
FOR THEIR TIME AND EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS OUR ON GOING CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL. WHILE THE AMENDS
TO EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY FIVE
IMPROVE THE CONSENT PROCESS
THERE IS STILL A CONVERSATION
REQUIRED BETWEEN THE PHYSICIAN
AND PATIENT THAT IS BOTH TIME
CONSUMING. AND POTENTIALLY
INAPPROPRIATE. PATIENTS ARE IN
THE MERCY DEPARTMENT WITH
SERIOUS CONCERNS ARE LIKELY
AFRAID AND ARE NOT MISSING THE
MIND TO BE DISCUSSING AN HIV
TEST. THEY MAY HAVE TO BE UPSET
WITH THE TREATING PHYSICIAN
CRISSCROSSING PERFORMING AN HIV
TEST. WHEN I HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH THEIR SYMPTOMS LEADING.
LEADING TO LONGER CONVERSATIONS.
THESE CONVERSATIONS AT A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TOTAL
TIME OF CARE. PROVIDED IN BUSY
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS.
ACCORDING TO THE CDC BLOOD
DRAWS ARE PERFORMED ON 42% OF
ALL ET PATIENTS. CALIFORNIA'S
EAST. MERSEA DEPARTMENTS TREAT
FOURTEEN MILLION PATIENTS PER
YEAR AND EVEN IF ADDING. AN HIV
TEST TO EACH OF THOSE
ENCOUNTERS ONLY TOOK AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE MINUTES. THAT
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL UPWARDS OF
TWENTY NINE MILLION ADDITIONAL
MINISTER CARE EACH YEAR THAT
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS WOULD ASK.
BEATS PER RIDE. THERE'S NO WAY
TO ABSORB THIS WITHOUT
IMPACTING THE TIMELINES AND
QUALITY OF CARE PROVIDED TO ALL
PATIENTS IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. WE ALSO HAVE
CONCERNS THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
AS BARRIERS IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH REPORT WHICH
EXAMINED HOSPITALS THAT
VOLUNTARY VOLUNTARILY
IMPLEMENTED A PROGRAM TO
OPERATE CHEVY TESTING. THE
REPORT. STATES QUOTE PROGRAM
SUSTAINABILITY MAY HINGE UPON
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS ABILITY
TO IDENTIFY HOW TO ACTUALLY
COVER THE. COST OF SCREENING
PATIENTS FOR HIV. MAYBE A
THIRTY FIVE NOT ADDRESS THOSE
CAN. AND WOULD INITIALLY RESULT
IN UNEXPECTED COSTS UNINSURED
PATIENTS. GENERALLY INSURED
PATIENTS MAY HAVE A SHARE OF
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH TESTING
WHICH WILL LIKELY BE UNKNOWN TO
THEM AT THE TIME THE OFFERS
MADE. HIM CALL IT DOES NOT
ALLOW FOR THE DISCUSSION OF THE
COSTS OF. THE HOSPITAL DURING
THE PILOT PROGRAM RECEIVED SOME
LEVEL EXTERNAL FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE PILOT. WE
BELIEVE EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY
FIVE SHOULD BE CLARIFIED TO
ENSURE PHYSICIANS AND HOSPITALS
ARE REIMBURSED FOR PROVIDING
HIV TEST AS WELL AS ENSURING
PATIENTS ARE NOT SUBJECT TO ANY
COSTS RELATED TO TESTING. FOR
THESE REASONS REMAIN AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- WHEN I BRING ON
MARIA SPERBER FROM CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION I THINK
YOU LEFT YOU ONE MINUTE FORTY
SECONDS. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MARIA FOREVER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
WASHINGTON FAMILY MEMBER THE
VARIANCE CALLED AND WE THANK
THE AUTHOR BLOCKAGE TO THE
DIALOGUE HOWEVER HUGELY
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREES WITH
WHERE HIV TESTING FOR NON
CLINICAL INDICATIONS SHOULD
OCCUR. TIMELY TRIAGE TREATMENT
AND CARE FOR CRITICAL PATIENTS
MUST BE AN EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
PRIORITY TO SAVE LIVES AND
PROTECT AGAINST. UNTOWARD
EMERGENT CONSEQUENCE OF.
ADDITIONAL HIGH REQUIRED FOR
NON AMONG CARE WILL INCREASE
THE ALREADY OVERCROWDED
CONDITIONS INCREASE THE TIME IT
TAKES TO CARE FOR PATIENTS WHO
PRESENT AN EASY. COMPROMISE
WHEN NEEDED ABILITY TO PERFORM
CENTRAL EMERGENCY CARE
FUNCTIONS. TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT THE
HIV SCREENING WORK WELL MUST BE
ADJUSTED TO AN EMERGENT YOUR
WORKFLOW I TIME AND RESOURCE
INTENSIVE ENDEAVOR THAT
ULTIMATELY PREVENT ALL PATIENTS
FROM GETTING THE MOST
APPROPRIATE CARE SHE HAD
INDICATED IN THE CDPH RECORD.
NUMEROUS BARRIERS MUST BE
ADDRESSED BEFORE HOSPITAL
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT HIV
TESTING WOULD BE SENSIBLE FOR
BOTH THE PATIENT IN THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT. STAGES OF
SCOTT SEVERAL ALTERNATIVES BUT
THE OTHER TOPICS INCLUDING HIV
TESTING WITHIN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT ONE ALTERNATIVE TO
CONSIDER IN SHORT EACH PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT OR LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS TO
FORMALLY COME BACK WITH A
BIRDIE THREE DEPARTMENTS THAT
DO NOT VOLUNTARILY PERFORM HIV
SCREENING EACH WITH A COMMUNITY
KERR CRACKED. CLINIC PARTNER
THAT WILL PROVIDE HIV SCREENING
AND FOLLOW UP CARE TO PATIENTS.
ANOTHER OPTION IS TO ASK
PATIENTS IF THEY WANT AN HIV
TEST DURING THE TRIAGE PROCESS
AND IT'S SO DIRECT THEM TO A
LOCAL FACILITY FOR TESTING. IN
THIS WAY HOSPITAL EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT COULD CONTRIBUTE TO
THIS IMPORTANT EFFORT ARE
REFERRING PATIENTS AFTER THE
FACT QUITE SPECIALTY CLINICS
WHERE THE PATIENT CAN RECEIVE
TESTING COUNSELING TO THE
STAGING AND TREATMENT MOST
APPROPRIATE FOR THEIR NEEDS.
AND EXCITING BETTER SUITED TO
THEIR CONCLUSION ABOUT THESE
RETURNS THE EXCHANGE REMAINS A
POLITICAL MESSAGE THANK YOU
THANK YOU THAT'S LET'S NOW MOVE
ONTO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY EIGHT
THIRTY FIVE OF YOUR PUBLIC
GALLERIES YOU KNOW THE PUBLIC
ALEX. MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY
TWELVE SEEN ON ROOM TWELVE.
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO ATTESTED OUT.
TO EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY FIVE.
OKAY AND ONCE AGAIN YOU'D LIKE
TO UP WITH PRESS ONE THE ZERO.
TOP FOR A. B. EIGHT THIRTY FIVE
ONE NINE ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME IT'S NINE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN- GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBER DATA INVOLVEMENT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU EXLINE.
WE DO HAVE ONE MORE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THE NEXT ONE WILL COME
FROM NINE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
AND I'M IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU EXLINE. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT THANKS FOR MUCH
THAT'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. K.
STATE YES CENTER GONZALEZ YEP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I AND I
TOO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I
HAVE- IN LONG BEACH
UNFORTUNATELY VERY VERY HIGH
RATES OF HIV AND STDS YOU SEE
THAT SORT OF STATEWIDE BUT-
LONG BEACH HAS DOUBLE- THE
NUMBERS AND SO WE'VE BEEN
TACKLING ON HOW EXACTLY. TO
IDENTIFY MORE INDIVIDUALS IF
THEY HAPPEN TO BE LIVING WITH
HIV- AND THEN ALSO PROVIDE THEM
WITH CARE AND RESOURCES SO. I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL- BUT IF YOU'D LIKE TO ADD
THAT I WOULD JUST LIKE TO HEAR
YOUR CLOTHES JUST ON THE
LOGISTICS BECAUSE THEY DO. IN
AN EMERGENCY ROOM SO WE JUST
LIKE TO KIND OF ENVISION WHAT
THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE- IN THE
EMERGENCY ROOMS ARE. YOU KNOW-
IN RESPONSE TO WHAT THE
OPPOSITION WILL BE PRESENTING
SO WITH THAT THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THINKING THE OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
RIGHT SO AGAIN A SUMMONS AND I
WANNA THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE ON THE BILL-
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT- WE WANT
TO BE SURE WE ADDRESS. THAT THE
OPPOSITION RACE WAS ABOUT-
PAYMENT ACTUALLY AND- AND
SUPPORTING THIS AND I WILL MAKE
NOTE THAT- NOT ONLY OF COURSE
HE TOOK THE AMENDMENT ON US
PREVENTIVE SERVICES TASK FORCE
WE ALSO LOOKED UP AND- FOUND
OUT THAT. IT IS ACTUALLY RATED.
AS A PREVENTIVE SERVICE IT WAS
RAISING EIGHT WHICH MEANS THAT
IT ACTUALLY IS COVERED WITHOUT
CO PAY FIVE. HUNDRED AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT. AND WE EVEN CHECKED
TO BE SURE THAT MERGES TWO
ROOMS WOULD STILL COULD AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF THAT PROVISION
SO. THEREFORE IF YOU ARE HAVE
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE- YOU ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THAT
WITHOUT COST SHARING- IT'S ALSO
COVERED BY MEDI CAL AS WELL- SO
I CERTAINLY DO MAKE NOTE THAT
IF SOMEONE'S. TOTALLY UNINSURED
THAT COULD BE A GAP BUT-
FRANKLY BETWEEN THE INSURED IT
WHETHER YOU HAVE MEDIC HOW ARE
INSURED THAT WILL BE COVERED
WITHOUT COST SHARE- I DO FIND
OUT WHAT WE DID HAVE JUST A
PRESENTATION ALSO ON STREET
MEDICINE AND WE TALKED ABOUT
HOW WE HAVE TO. REACH PEOPLE
WHERE THEY ARE AND SO I DO FIND
A LITTLE CHALLENGING TO SAY
THAT THE ANSWER WOULD ACTUALLY
BE IS THAT ONCE YOU HIT SOMEONE
SHOWS UP EMERGENCY ROOM THAT WE
THEN. SAY IF YOU WANT TO TEST
WE HAVE SEND YOU SOMEWHERE ELSE
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO TRY TO
CLOSE THAT GAP BUT ALSO
APPRECIATE THAT YOU. TOOK AN
AMENDMENT THAT SAID IF THE E.
OURS AWARE AND IN THEIR OWN
RECORD AND BY LIKE THE WHOLE
ENTIRE HOSPITAL RECORD YOU KNOW
WHATEVER THE R. HAS ACCESS TO.
THAT PERSON'S EITHER GOTTEN THE
TESTER READY IN THE LAST TWELVE
MONTHS OR ACTUALLY THE
REPOSITORY KNOW. THEN ACTUALLY
THEY DON'T NEED TO DO THAT IT'S
UP TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM
OTHERWISE TAKE TIME TO CHECK
THAT OUT BUT- AGAIN THAT WOULD
REDUCE THAT TIME BURDEN AS WELL
AS WE ARE HOPEFULLY.
IDENTIFYING PEOPLE. WHO HAVE
HIV GETTING THEM TO CARE I
THINK THAT'S THE PART WE NEED
TO BE SURE WE CONTINUE TO WORK
ON GETTING THE CARE SO
HOPEFULLY WE CAN AGAIN. I HAVE
THIS. REDUCE THE SPREAD OF THIS
CONTAGIOUS DISEASE AND THAT'S I
THINK THE ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO
ACTUALLY IDENTIFY SO WE CAN
LIMIT THE SPREAD. AND
EVENTUALLY HOPEFULLY EVEN
ELIMINATE- IT H. IDEAS WELL. SO
I AM. APPRECIATE THE- THEY WERE
BROUGHT UP BY A PHONE. OF PEACE.
THE FACT THAT YOU KNOW- BUT
WORKING WITH THEM THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND OUT THE PATH
FORWARD TO- SHOULD RETIRE AND
THEN A FIGHT. AND THEN GET.
PEOPLE ACCESS TO THE CARE THEY
NEED- IF THEY ARE HIV POSITIVE-
AND ALSO TRYING NOT TO
OVERBURDEN EMERGENCY ROOM SO I
APPRECIATE THAT WORK. I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU DR PAN
I. JUST BRIEFLY WANT TO MENTION
A COUPLE OF THINGS FIRST OF ALL
I. HE WAS A- I WAS A STAFFER
WITH A LOT MORE HERE AT THAT
TIME HERE WHERE I WORKED ON A.
B. E. THIRTY FIVE FOR MY FORMER
FOR MY FORMER BOSS- SOME LIMIT
AND THEN SOME REMEMBER PAUL
KRIKORIAN- AND WE DO AGREE THAT
INSURERS NEED TO FULFILL THEIR
PAYMENT OBLIGATION AND WILL
WORK WITH CAL A STEP. TO
RESOLVE THAT ISSUE BUT WOULD HE
BE WITH EIGHT THIRTY FIVE DATE
WAS OBLIGATED INSURERS TO PAY
FOR HIV TEST SO THERE'S ALSO
THAT PIECE AS WELL BUT I JUST
WANTED TO MENTION- SECOND-
AGAIN IT HAVING WORKED ON THIS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN RUN
A BUILD THAT CAME UP WITH THE
STUDY WHICH DISCOVERED THAT ONE
POINT 7% OF UNSUSPECTING
INDIVIDUALS BETWEEN THE AGES OF
FIFTEEN FOURTEEN TO THIRTY
FIVE. WHO WENT TO THE ER ROOMS
WERE CAPTURED AS INDIVIDUALS
WHO DID NOT KNOW THAT THEY WERE
HIV POSITIVE I MEAN THAT'S A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT NUMBER AND
THAT'S WHY WE FELT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO MOVE FORWARD NOW
WITH WITH REQUIRING THIS ON AN
ONGOING BASIS IT'S REQUIRED.
BUT IT GIVES THE OPTION FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL TO OPT OUT THAT'S
REQUIRED FOR THE HOSPITAL TO
PASS THE E. OUR ROOM TO ASK-
AND LOGISTICALLY WE TRY TO DO
EVERYTHING WE COULD WORK HAVING
WORKED WITH THE ER DOCTORS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
WHEN I WORKED ON THIS BILL THE
FIRST BILL- EVERY IT AT EVERY
ITERATION WE'VE TRIED TO MAKE
IT EASIER FOR THEM. BECAUSE WE
DO UNDERSTAND THE STRENUOUS
CONDITIONS OF IN YOUR ROOM SO
THE JUST SPEAKING TO THE
LOGISTICS IF I'M UNDERSTANDING
IT CORRECTLY WE WANTED THAT'S
WHY E INSERTED LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD ALLOW- FOR THE POSITIVE
RESULT TO BE TRANSFERRED TO A
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND FOR
THIRD PARTY THAT IS QUALIFIED
TO PROVIDE THE POST HIV TESTING
COUNSELING SO WE'VE TRIED TO
TAKE EVERY. DIFFERENT APPROACH
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT. THE
E. R. THE STRESS ON THE E. R.
ROOM IS REALLY BUT THAT'S THE
LAST. THATWE CAN ACTUALLY
CAPTURE. ANY OUTLINE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD OTHERWISE
NOT BE TESTED THAT THAT WOULD
BE THE BEST PLACE. SO- PROBABLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE ON THIS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTERS THERE
AND WE DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM
SOURCE OFFERING INTERCEPTED E.
BUSINESS WE- TABLE SAT SCORE-
HOPEFULLY WE CAN THEN TAKE
MOTIONS AND- THE ENVELOPES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. RIGHT
LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX AT TEN THIRTY EIGHT
BY SUMMER GIBSON I SEE HIM HERE
WELCOME- JUST GIVE US A MOMENT
TO. TIDY UP THE PODIUM HERE.
RIGHT WELCOME PLEASE BEGIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT- ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
THIRTY EIGHT WHICH SEEKS TO
CREATE A CALIFORNIA HEALTH
EQUITY FUND TO REDUCE THE
UNJUST IMPACT OF KOTAK
NINETEEN- NOW AND INTO THE
FUTURE. FIRST OFF I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN- GIVE HIM
SPECIAL THANKS. FOR HIS GREAT
LEADERSHIP AND TREMENDOUS
SUPPORT IN DISCUSSING- AND
DISCUSSING- THE SUPPORT FOR
THIS HEALTH EQUITY ALSO I WOULD
LIKE TO THE TICKET
OPPORTUNITIES TO SERVE. TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
ASSEMBLY DR AROUND ENOUGH FOR
HIS HEAVY SUPPORT- IN THESE
EFFORTS- THAT I SPEAK TO
TODAY'S SO THANK YOU BOTH. FOR
YOUR DILIGENCE AND YOUR FOCUS
IN THIS PARTICULAR AREA. AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW- THAT THAT WE
HAVE TO CALIFORNIANS- ONE THAT
IS ADEQUATELY SUPPORTED WITH
THE RESOURCES- TO. TO SUPPORT
THOSE WHO. HAVE HEALTH
DISPARITIES AND ALSO THE OTHER
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAS EXTORT
PLEA- BEEN OVER LOOKED. THOSE
WHO ARE BEEN OVERLOOKED ARE
HELD BACK BY SYSTEMS. THAT
ASSIGN VALUE. DETERMINES HOW
OPPORTUNITIES BASED ON
DEMOGRAPHICS INCOME LEVELS AND
EVEN SKIN COLOR TODAY'S
LATINOS. BLACKS NATIVE
AMERICANS A. P. I. L. G. B. T.
Q. AND LOW INCOME RESIDENTS ARE
TRULY BEARING THE BLOCKS OF
THIS PANDEMIC. WHAT WE NEED OUR
COLLECTIVE STRATEGIES INVEST
INVESTMENTS TO GET IN FRONT OF
WHAT IS CAUSING THIS HEALTH
DISPARITY IN THE FIRST PLACE
THIS BILL WILL SUPPORT-
PARTNERSHIPS AMONG COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS COMMUNITY
CLINICS TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS.
AND LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
THAT SERVE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THESE ENTITLES WILL
CREATE A STRATEGY TAILORED TO
LOCAL NEEDS AND ADDRESS THE
ROOT CAUSE OF IT EQUITIES- THAT
EXIST THAT EXISTS BEFORE THIS
PANDEMIC AND HAVE ONLY
WORSENED. THESE ISSUES INCLUDES
HOUSING. FOOD IN SECURITY
EMPLOYEE INSTABILITIES UNDER
RESOURCE- SCHOOLS- CHILDCARE
COMMUNITY VIOLENCE AND HATE
CRIMES AND ENVIRONMENTAL
INJUSTICE FOR ANYONE WHO WHO
WONDERS WHY THIS IS THIS
APPROACH IS NECESSARY- PLEASE
NOTE THAT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
IS EXPERIENCED THE HIGHEST RATE
OF ILLNESS AND PREMATURE DEATH.
IN LIFE EXPECTANCIES OF NON
HISPANICS BLACK AMERICANS- IT
IS FOUR YEARS LOWER THAN OTHER
POPULATIONS BEYOND POLITICS
BEYOND THE TWEETS BEYOND THE
FOLLOWERS AND LIKES THE EFFORTS
THIS EFFORT IS TRULY- THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE LIVES AND
COMPLETELY SHIFT OUTCOMES FOR
OUR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN
A COMPREHENSIVE WAY TO FIX THIS
BROKEN PIECES. IN OUR HEALTH
SYSTEMS NOW MAKES OUR COMMUNITY
AND MAKE OUR COMMUNITY WHOLE
MANY OF THEM. ARE HERE FOR THE
FIRST TIME AND IT'S OUR
OBLIGATION AND RESPONSIBILITIES
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO HELP THESE
COMMUNITIES WHILE I AM
DISAPPOINTED. THAT FUNDING FOR
HEALTH EQUITY A. B. TEN THIRTY
EIGHT WAS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
LAST SKATER THE BUDGET RATIONS
I WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
FOR PRIORITIZING HISTORIC THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY COMMITTED FOR FINDING
IN 200-022-2000 TWENTY THREE TO
IMPART SUPPORT HEALTH EQUITIES.
WE ARE FAR BEYOND JUST PLANTING
SEEDS OF OPPORTUNITIES AT THIS
POINT OUR COMMUNITIES NEED LONG
LASTING INVESTMENTS INC TO
INCLUDE IMPROVEMENTS OF OUR
CHILDREN AND ALSO OUR
GRANDCHILDREN'S. THANK GOD FOR
BID FOR ANOTHER PANDEMIC TO
OCCUR BUT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
BUILDING COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
NOW TO WHETHER ANY FORESEEN
OUTCOME WITH ANY OTHER PANDEMIC
THEY MAY HIT US IN THE NEAR
FUTURE THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT A.
B. TEN THIRTY EIGHT INTENDS TO
DO. I HAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL
BE HERE TO TESTIFY WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE WHO IS SELF
INTRODUCED- THE FROM THE LATINO
COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA ASWELL AS A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
WHO SELL PRODUCE WHO SHOULD BE
WITH US ON THE LINE. THANKS
VERY MUCH SUMMER GIVE SEND WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AT TEN THIRTY EIGHT
SO LET'S BRING ON TO THE LINE-
MEGAN TO CLEAR FROM THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THE PART OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND MARVELOUS.
FROM THE LATINO KELLER
COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA- ACTUALLY SUMMER
GIBSON YOU AT MOUNTS THEM IN
THE RIVER AND THE OTHER ORDER
DID YOU IT'S OUR PREFERENCE FOR
WHICH BUTTONS YOU GO FIRST- I
WOULD THE LATINO COALITION FOR
HELP GETTING HELP YES. RIGHT SO
MODERATOR COMPLETES FIRST BRING
ON MARV ELLIS FROM THE LATINO
COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AT TEN THIRTY EIGHT.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES FOUR
MINUTES COLLECTIVELY. YOU
RECKON THE MEMBER DEFENDING
GOOD MORNING CHIP PAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. OVER THE PAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS BUT YOU KNOW
COALITION FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA OR LPG HAVE
PROTECTED IN ADVANCE HEALTH
EQUITY FOR LATINOS AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS. HOWEVER HELP THE
THEORIES ARE STILL RAMPANT IN
OUR STATE AND THE LONG TERM
IMPACT OF THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. ON HEALTH EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING. THE ONLY MAKE THEM
WORK. HI TO TRANSFORM HOW WE
IMPACT AND HELP. FOR TO LONG WE
HAVE LAMENTED PREDICTED HELPING
EQUITIES BUT FAILED TWENTY FIVE
BEEN CHANGING THE CONDITIONS.
THAT DRIVE THE EQUITY. MANY OF
WHICH ARE THE RESULT OF
SYSTEMIC RACISM. COVERAGE
SHOWED US. JUST HOW DEADLY
DOMESTIC CAN BE. THAT IS WHY
THE COMPARE THAT WE TAKE A LOOK.
WHERE LEARNING COMPANY. I MAKE
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS HEALTH
EQUITY TO ADDRESS AND PREVENT
HEALTH OUTCOMES FROM WORKING.
AND WE CAN DO THIS BY
SUPPORTING BOTH TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM. AS WELL
AS INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS AND
STRATEGIES OFFERED BY CHECK THE
MESSENGERS MY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. DEEPLY NOW AN
APPETITE TO COMMUNITIES AT THE
GROUND LEVEL. EIGHTY POINT
THIRTY EIGHT WOULD DO JUST THAT
BY PUBLISHING THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH EQUITY FUND. TO TWENTY
B. O.'S TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS
AND CLINICS TO WORK WITH
COMMUNITIES AND DEVELOP
COMMUNITY DETERMINE STRATEGIES
TO IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES. AND
THEREBY ROOTING OUT RACISM AND
HEALTH INEQUITIES. AN EXAMPLE
OF THIS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
WORK IS ABOUT POLITICAL
CAMPAIGNS LED BY LCC IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT O SOCIAL SERVICES.
COULDN'T PROVE VACCINATION
RATES IN THE LATIN COMMUNITY.
WE NOW KNOW THAT HE KNOWS IN
PARTICULAR WERE HARD HIT BY
KOBE. REPRESENTING. 56% OF ALL
HE SAID. I'M PAYING OUT THE-
WOULD BE DIDN'T. WITH RELY A TO
DATE AND- ON THE CALL NINETEEN
SIXTY. LED BY CAN YOU HEALTH
WORKERS BUT THE MOST THAT. WE
REACH OF COMING MEMBERS AND
DROVE UP VACCINATION RATES OR
EVEN GOOD GOVERNMENT ALONE
COULD NOT. BE KIND OF COMMUNITY
DETERMINE STRATEGIES ARE
CRITICAL TO SOLVING THE
CHALLENGES FOR COMMUNITIES TO
NOT TO ACT UP BACK IN BUT HOW
THE ABILITY EDUCATION GROUP TO
THIRTY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. THE UNDERLYING DRIVERS
ABOUT HELPING EQUITIES BUT
LET'S NOT THE NOT THE DENMARK
AND COOK IT IN THE FIRST PLACE.
FOR THESE REASONS THE LATINO
COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA THE POWER CO FOUNDER
AND THE CORK AT TEN THIRTY
EIGHT WE THINK I CAN'T REMEMBER
GIBSON ENERGY INC A LEADING ON
THE ISSUE AND RESPECTFULLY. ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU OUR SPRING
ON MEGAN A CLEARER FROM THE
ANGELES PARK PUBLIC. YOU HAVE A
MAY AND FORTY SECONDS. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU COMMITTEE
CHAIR AND ANIMAL CLINIC MEMBERS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY ON BEHALF OF LA
COUNTY AND THE PORT OF AB TEN
THIRTY EIGHT. I'M IN A PUBLIC
HEALTH IS PROUD TO JOIN A LONG
LIST OF ADVOCATES AND
ORGANIZATIONS URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
AND ENABLE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. THE ORGANIZATION'S
CLINICS AND TRIBAL
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE DANCE
PROGRAMS AND INITIATIVES THAT
FOCUS ON RACIAL AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE. THEY WERE THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING ACROSS. ALL
CALIFORNIA. SENDS OUT THE
SEVENTEEN ONLY COUNTY HAS
EFFORTS TO REDUCE HEALTH
INEQUITIES AMONG COUNTY
RESIDENTS. ARE CENTER FOR ALL
THAT BUT HE WORKS DURING THE
PARTNERSHIP AUGMENTS MANY
EFFORTS TO REALIGN RESOURCES
ADVANCED CONDITIONS. THAT
SUPPORT OPTIMAL HEALTH. THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT OF CODE IN
NINETEEN A FURTHERING THAT
EXACERBATED DEEPLY ROOTED
INEQUITIES OUR MOST
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES. BLACK
LET NEXT DATE WHY AND THE THICK
ISLANDER AMERICAN INDIAN AND
ALASKA NATIVE POPULATIONS.
CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE A
DISPROPORTIONATE. BURDEN FROM
THE PANDEMIC. LONGSTANDING
SYSTEMIC AND- IN ON IN.
OVERCROWDED HOW. HIGH RATE THE
ONE. HEALTH AND A LACK OF
STRONG WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS.
CRITICAL DELHI'S RESPONSE TO
THE INVESTMENT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT THEY CAN DO
WHAT THEY DO BEST. CONNECT WITH
RESIDENTS GATED POLITY PRACTICE
CHANGES AND SHARE IMPORTANT
INFORMATION TO IMPROVE
OUTCOMES. THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
EQUITY PROGRAM COULD PROVIDE
VITAL RESOURCES FOR INITIATIVES
TO ADVANCE HEALTH EQUITY IN LA
COUNTY. BUILDING ON SUCCESSFUL
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERS IT'LL ALLOW
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO ADDRESS
THE HEALTH DISPARITIES AND
DISEASES IMPACTING OUR
COMMUNITIES. THE DRIVER THAN
THE THAN EQUITIES SUCH AS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE INCLUDE
SECURITY WE URGE YOU TO ACT
NOW. CREATE A MUCH NEEDED IN
COORDINATED STATEWIDE HEALTH
EQUITY PROGRAM AS WE WORK
COLLECTIVELY TO CLOSE THE
UNACCEPTABLE GAPS IN HEALTH.
AND WELLBEING ACROSS RACE
ETHNICITY AND SOCIO ECONOMIC.
STATUS THANK YOU. THE YOU VERY
MUCH- WE'RE GONNA TAKE A QUICK
PAUSE HERE BECAUSE I KNOW WE
HAVE THE PRESENCE OF A QUORUM
SO CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FOR A PRESENT FOR
A QUORUM. PAN'S HAND HERE
MELINDA'S EGGMAN. EGGMAN HERE
GONZALEZ HERE CONSOL IS HERE
GROVE. FURTADO HERE FOR TOTO
HERE LEYVA. LEAVE HERE EARLY
MON HERE WE MOAN HERE ROTH.
RUBIO HERE RUBIO HERE WINNER.
THANK THE CAR HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF AB TEN THIRTY EIGHT SO BE IN
THE PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ON THE
PUBLIC OUT ITS MOVE ROUTE TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE C. KNOWN ROOM
TWELVE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT AT TEN THIRTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
TEN THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WELL
LINE NUMBERS SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS ERIC CHURCH
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN CONCORD THANK YOU
EXLINE. NEXT IN THE LINE NUMBER
ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RANDY REYNOLDS FROM CALIFORNIA
ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT JULY
NUMBER FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING LINDA WAY
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY APOLOGIES FOR NOT
GETTING A LETTER IN TIME BUT
IN. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. TECH
SUPPORT LINE NUMBER ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANDREA
RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THANKS TO
A LINE NUMBER ONE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS OSCAR SAID WALL WOULD BE
WHAT PEOPLE COALITION FOR
HEALTH OF KOREA AND I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF A BEACON THIRTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
YOUR NUMBER ONE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
SURE NUMBERS NOT ON GOOGLE AND
YELP AND WORKED MORE ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. FOR LINE NUMBER ONE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING EUGENE CAMPAIGN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK- PROUD CO
SPONSOR AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. FOUR LINE
NUMBER SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THAT'S OKAY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD AND FARMING
NETWORK SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANKS LINE. FOUR ONE NUMBER
ONE ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHECK YOUR TRADE BEGAN ON
BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE WE ARE COSPONSORED
MAYBE TEN THIRTY EIGHT AM AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. THE ONE NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS LUCY SALCEDO
CARTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFITS AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. THE LINE NUMBER ONE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ARGHA STEINBERG- WOULD
HELP ACCESSING STRONG SUPPORT
THANKS THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
POLITE NUMBER ONE OH NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
AMANDA HER ON BEHALF OF
MEMORIALCARE HEALTH SYSTEMS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT TIME.
BUT LINE NUMBER SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN REALLY
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
AGENCIES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. FOUR LINE NUMBER
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BARTLET OFFICE ON BEHALF OF THE
BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU EXLINE. FOUR
LINE NUMBER ONE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS SERENA WONG ASIAN. AND
STRONG SUPPORT AT EIGHTY TWO
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. FOR A LINE
NUMBER ONE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IT'S OVER CLINICAL
PROFESSOR AT UCSF IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
AND ONCE MORE TO OUR SUPPORT OF
AB ONE ZERO THREE EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
SUPPORT OF AB ONE ZERO THREE
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AT THE
MOMENT. WE JUST ANOTHER MOMENT
OKAY. I'M IN YOUR LINE OF
NUMBER ONE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I WE ARE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
PARTNER FOR EMPOWERMENT
ADVOCACY AND LEADERSHIP OFTEN
AS THE P. O. OUR ORGANIZATION
IS A CO SPONSOR IN RECALLING
THE STRONG SUPPORT. OF THAT AND-
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. MISTER
CHAIRPERSON AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NOBODY ELSE TO YOU THANKS
VERY MUCH MODERATED OUT LET'S
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AT TEN THIRTY
EIGHT THERE'S NO LEAD WITNESS
OPPOSITION REGISTERED FOR
TESTIMONY WILL GO TO A PUBLIC
GALLERY SCENE ON PUBLIC ALEX
MOVED TO ROOM TWELVE SEEN ON
ROOM TWELVE MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
WHO TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION TO
AT TEN THIRTY EIGHT NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU AND THEY GENERALLY
ARE IN OPPOSITION AB ONE ZERO
THREE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHEN I GO TO
LINE NUMBER EIGHTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI. ONE MOMENT. BUT
IF YOU JUST A MOMENT. ONE MORE
MOMENT PLEASE. ONE CAN WE'RE
GONNA GO TO LINE EIGHTY TWO
POLICY DELAY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS KENNEDY ON THE
ON THE PART OF MANY COMMUNITY
IS THAT YOU GUYS NAME THAT YOU
SAY THAT YOU REPRESENT NINE
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE AN OPPOSITION
AT ONE ZERO THREE EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR
SHEPHERDS WE HAVE NOBODY ELSE
THINK YOU ARE THANKS FOR MUCH
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
I REALLY DO WANT TO THANK OUR-
OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS- MEASURE FORWARD
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT-
IN PARTICULAR- I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE BILL AND THAT
TACKLES ARE AREAS THAT HAVE
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY COAL BED. NINETEEN
AND WITH INVESTMENT IN THIS
AREA IS SO CRITICAL I THINK
THAT IT IS IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE DISPARITIES AND I
JUST WANTED TO SHARE SOME DATA
THAT I GATHERED BASED ON A
REPORT THAT I READ ON THE CDC-
IN THE LAST WEEK THAT IT TALKS
ABOUT. HOW COLD IT NINETEEN I
REALLY LOWERED THE LIFE
EXPECTANCY FOR EVERYONE IN
GENERAL BY ONE YEAR WILD
HISPANICS LOST ONE POINT NINE
YEARS IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY
TWO POINT SEVEN YEARS BASED ON
COVE AND- AND SO I THINK IT'S
SO IMPORTANT WE INVEST THAT WE
BE PROACTIVE AND PARTICULARLY.
I BELIEVE THIS BILL TACKLES
THOSE AREAS THAT WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED- AS
IT PERTAINS TO COVER IT SO I
WOULD LOVE TO NOT ONLY HAVE
MOVED IF A BILL FORWARD WHEN
APPROPRIATE BUT ALSO BE A CO
AUTHOR. AND JOHN AND WITH THAT
I'D- I WANTED TO SEE ONCE AGAIN
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS TORY THANK YOU RIGHT THANK
YOU IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
RUBIO CENTER TADO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I. ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD. AS
A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND OF COURSE RURAL
CALIFORNIA I KNOW.
UNFORTUNATELY ALL TOO WELL WHAT
IT MEANS TO HAVE A DISPARITIES
AND WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
INEQUITIES. AND I THINK THIS
PUT THIS BILL WILL. HELP
SIGNIFICANTLY COMMUNITIES LIKE
THE ONES THAT I REPRESENT BUT
REALLY ALL ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO REALLY SAVE
LIVES SAVE THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS AND ALSO HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY AND
WOULD BE LIKE TO ADDED AS A- AS
A CO AUTHOR OF POSSIBLE. THANK
YOU RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS C. SAYING NONE-
EVER GETS IN FIRST I MIGHT JUST
THANK YOU SO MUCH RINGS BEFORE
AND FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
ADDRESSING EQUITY- I LIKE YOU
WERE A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED
THAT- WE WERE ABLE TO FUNNY
THIS YEAR BUT REALLY APPRECIATE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT
AND- OUR LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP
AND- COMING TO- PROVIDING FUNDS
STARTING WITH THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR TO ADDRESS PUBLIC HEALTH
AND EQUITY- AS YOU POINTED OUT
AND SO CERTAINLY THIS BILL'S
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT AND
HELPING. SHAPE THAT- MOVING
FORWARD WITH THOSE FUNDS- AND
SO CERTAINLY VERY STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT AND REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. SUCH
AS CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
KIND WORDS I WANT TO ALSO
THANK- BOTH SENATORS HI TODD-
AND ALSO- RUBIO FOR YOUR KIND-
REMARKS AS WELL AS BECOMING A
CO AUTHORS OF THIS BILL. I
HUMBLY RECEIVED THAT SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE WANT TO MAKE
MENTION TO- MEMBERS ARE
PRESENT. THIS BILL RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I'M ON THE
FLOOR OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY I'M
HAPPY TO REPORT- COMMUNITIES
THIS PANDEMIC HAVE CERTAINLY
SHOWN BECAUSE DISPARITIES AS
WAYS COMMUNITIES. AND SPECIALLY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE BEEN
HIT THE HARDEST AND CONTINUE TO
BE HIT THE HARDEST WE MUST LOOK
AT THIS FROM A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE LANDS. AND PUT A
STRATEGY IN PLACE AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO WE
NEVER TRIED BEFORE. AND SO I
THINK IT IS BECOMING UP ON US
TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN. TO TO-
NOW ONLY- CREATIVE
COLLABORATION BUT ALSO REAL
PLANNED WE BELIEVE ASSEMBLY
BILL. AT TEN THIRTY EIGHT WILL
KNOWING THAT SHE COULD CLOSE
THE DISPARITY IN TERMS OF GAPS
IN TERMS OF HEALTH ACCESS. BUT
ALSO BRING THE COMMUNITY
TOGETHER LET THEM KNOW WE CARE
ABOUT THEM- IN A CONFLICT IN A
VERY COMPREHENSIVE WAY SO RISK
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
I BUILT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RIGHT THANK YOU SO- THE END
BINS BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR RUBIO THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS
CONSULTANT. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON AT TEN THIRTY EIGHT.
CAN HI CAN FINALLY IS A- BY
ADMIN I CAN SOLICIT.THEMSELVES
ON A GROVE HER TADO. FURTADO I
LLEVA. LABOR I A. LEE MOON. THE
MOON I. ROSS. RUBIO HI RUBIO I
WINNER. SEVEN SO THEY'LL
CURRENTLY SEVEN ZERO WILL PUT
THE PHONE CALL THANKS VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT I THINK WHEN I SEE
SOME MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS HERE
OKAY WELCOME SO WE'LL MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR BY SAM ROBERT
REAVIS- JUST GIVE US A MOMENT
TO TIDY UP THE PODIUM HERE-
WELCOME. PLEASE BEGIN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MORNING SANDERS
WE HAVE TO SEE EVERYBODY- IN
THIS LEGISLATION- FOR SOMEONE I
THINK GOT A COMMITTEE STAFFER
DURING GAUGE MINT ON ON THIS
BILL WORKING WITH THE STAFF
AND- YOU KNOW THIS LEGISLATION
IS ON THE BILL. ON ONE ONE FOUR
FOUR IT PROPOSES TO MAKE A
NUMBER OF UPDATES TO
CALIFORNIA'S COTTAGE FOOD LAWS-
COTTAGE FOOD OPERATIONS OR
CFO'S ARE SMALL BUSINESSES AND
IN WHICH- PEOPLE MAKE AND SELL
HOMEMADE FOODS. TO HELP
SUPPLEMENT THEIR INCOME OR IN
SOME CASES IS THEIR PRIMARY
SOURCE OF INCOME. UNDER CURRENT
STATE LAW CFO'S ARE LIMITED TO
MAKING FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
OR LESS IN ANNUAL SALES FROM
THEIR FOOD PRODUCTS. THIS FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR FIGURE HAS NOT
BEEN UPDATED IN SIX YEARS TO.
ACCOUNT FOR INFLATION AND THE
RISING COST OF LIVING HERE IN
OUR STATE. IN ADDITION CFO'S
ARE NOT CURRENTLY ALLOWED TO
SHIP HOMEMADE FOOD THROUGH THE
MAIL OR- OTHER THIRD PARTY-
SOME. DELIVERY SERVICES ACROSS
OUR STATE- AND- THIS IS DESPITE
THE RISING IMPORTANCE OF THESE
SERVICES. AND SO THIS BILL IT
PROPOSES TO ADDRESS ISSUES BY
FIRST ALLOWING IN STATE THE
DELIVERY PRODUCTS VIA MAIL
ORDER AND OTHER- DELIVERY
SERVICE. SECOND INCREASING THE
SALES LIMIT OF TWO SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND FOUR CLASS AT CFO. AND
A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND FOR A
CLASS B. CFO. AND LASTLY- IN
PREVENTING THE CLASS B. CFO'S
FROM NEEDING A COLLEGE WOULD
PERMIT IN MULTIPLE COUNTIES.
THAT WOULD BE STRAIGHTFORWARD
BUT IMPORTANT CHANGES TO. TO
OUR STATE'S EXISTING COTTAGE
FOOD LAWS- THIS LEGISLATION
WILL. WILL CREATE SUBSTANTIAL
NEW OPPORTUNITY FOR SMALL
ENTREPRENEURS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. FINE WITH ME HERE
TO TESTIFY- THIS MORNING OR TWO
CFO'S REPRESENTED BY- SEE LAURA.
BUT PALOUSE- AND SOME CHANGE
AND WITH THE- THAT'S WHAT I AND
THANK YOU MR CHAIR RIGHT SO
MUCH SENATOR- MODERATE PLEASE
BRING ONTO A LINE OR TWO.
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
LAURA PALAU SKI FROM THE LIKE
THE BULLS AND SONIA CHANG FROM
CALLIE GRANOLA. ARE YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES MAX
PERFORMANCE BETWEEN THE TWO OF
YOU. LET'S BEGIN WITH A LOWER
PALAU SKI. HI GOOD MORNING CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE BEGIN.
GREAT THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS AND SENATE FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY MY
NAME IS LAURA PALAU SKI MY
HUSBAND AND I STARTED
COLLECTIBLES WHICH IS A COTTAGE
FOOD OPERATION WHERE WE CREATE
EXCEL HEALTHY HOMEMADE SNACKS
AND SWEETS. WE DECIDED TO START
OUR BUSINESS BECAUSE OF OUR
DAUGHTER WHO SUFFERS FROM
ANYTHING SENSITIVITY SHE COULD
NOT EAT ANYTHING PROCESS
WITHOUT BECOMING ILL AND
EXPERIENCING A TOOTH PAIN OR
ISSUES THAT MADE US AWARE OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF EATING CLEAN
UNPROCESSED AND FACES WE WANTED
TO OFFER A GREAT TASTING
HEALTHY THREE TO OTHERS WHO
SUFFER FROM PAIN ISSUES. MANY
PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
COME THE DOCUMENT AREA FARMERS
MARKETS AND THEY TELL ME OFTEN
THEY DO NOT HAVE OPTIONS LIKE
OUR PRODUCT IN THEIR AREAS AND
ARE VERY DISAPPOINTED WHEN THEY
FIND OUT WE CANNOT SHIP OUR
PRODUCTS ARE COMPLETELY SHELF
STABLE THEIR SAFETY SHIP AND
THEY ARE MUCH HEALTHIER. THAN
MOST THINGS YOU CAN FIND ON THE
SHELF. THIS YEAR WE WILL LIKE
LIKELY REACH THAT FIFTY DOLLAR
ANNUAL. AND IT DOES LIKE A LOT
AMOUNT OF MONEY. BUT IT REALLY
ISN'T AND LET ME EXPLAIN IF YOU
RUN YOUR BUSINESS VERY WELL YOU
MAY MAKE A NET PROFIT OF THIRTY
PERCENT. THIS TRANSLATES TO AN
ANNUAL NET PROFIT OF FIFTEEN
THOUSAND. THIS AMOUNT IS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO MAKE THE
TRANSITION FROM A COTTAGE. TO A
COMMERCIAL KITCHEN OR BRICK AND
MORTAR LET ALONE CONTRIBUTE
FAMILY FINANCE. ALSO WANTS THAT
FIFTY THOUSAND CAP IS REACHED
WE MUST INFORM OUR CUSTOMERS
THAT WE HAVE HAD TO HALT
PRODUCTION TEMPORARILY. AND NOT
ONLY DOES THIS HINDER OUR
BUSINESS AND TRUSTED OUR
CUSTOMERS. BUT IT DOES NOTHING
TO IMPROVE THE- SAFETY. CLEARLY
IF WE CAN SAFELY PRODUCE AND
SELL FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS THE
PRODUCT FROM OUR HOME KITCHEN.
IN THE FIRST TEN MONTHS OF THE
YEAR. THEN WE CAN ALSO PRODUCE
AND SELL ANOTHER TEN THOUSAND
FOR THE LAST TWO MONTHS THIS
YEAR. WITHOUT COMPROMISING THE
SAFETY. BY RAISING ITS TAIL CAP
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO KEEP
CURRENT CUSTOMERS YEAR ROUND
WHILE MAINTAINING THE SAFETY.
AND LASTLY AN INCREASE IN THE
ANNUAL CAP YOU KNOW THE WHITE
FINANCIAL GAP THAT EXISTS
BETWEEN MOVING FROM A COTTAGE
FOOD. TO A COMMERCIAL KITCHEN
OR BRICK AND MORTAR. I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO PASS AB ONE ONE
FOUR FOUR THE POSITIVE IMPACT
THAT WOULD PROVIDE FOR THE
THOUSANDS OF. COTTAGE FOOD
OPERATORS IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. HOW'S THAT BRING US ON
YOUR CHECK FROM CO. KELLY
GRANOLA. YOU HAVE. TO HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE BEGIN.
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF FELLOW
ARTISTS IN COTTAGE FOOD
OPERATORS MY NAME IS SONYA
CHANG I AM CALIBER NO DOUBT
MORE IMPORTANTLY SINCE TWENTY
TEN I AM A SINGLE MOTHER OF TWO
CHILDREN AS I HAVE MY CHILDREN
SIX DAYS A WEEK BOTH TIMES I
NEEDED AN INCOME STREAM THAT
WOULD ALLOW ME THE FLEXIBILITY
OF PUTTING MY FAMILY FIRST. IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN I APPLIED FOR
LA COUNTY COTTAGE FOOD
OPERATION CLASS BE PERMANENT
THE BANK TELLING AN INTERESTING
DENTAL HEALTH OKAY THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT MY DAUGHTER THAT
IT'S HEALTHY AND PAID BACK
NOBODY WORRIED IT MINOR
PROGRAMS IS THAT I GREW TO
TWENTY FOUR WHOLESALE ACCOUNT.
DIRECT SALES I DON'T STARTED TO
BRING ALL OF THE MONTH CLASS AT
THE CLUB GROUP I STRUGGLED WITH
COORDINATING DELIVERY EACH
MEMBER COME ON TOP OF MY OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES THE MEMBER
SAID IT WAS LIKE CHRISTMAS EACH
TIME THEY'RE GOING ALL AWRY. I
WAS DISAPPOINTED WHEN I HAD TO
INFORM THEM DUE TO SHIPPING
RESTRICTIONS I COULD NO LONGER
CONTINUE THE CLUB AFFECT
RECRUITMENT GRILL IT'S EASY AND
SAFE HE SAID IN FACT DURING THE
PANDEMIC SHIPPING IS EVEN SAFER
THAN DELIVERING IN PERSON I
WOULD LOVE TO GET THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY GRANOLA TO TRY THE
FATTENING I'M NOT ALLOWED TO. I
NEEDED MORE CAPACITY IN WHAT
MIGHT BREAK MY HOME KITCHEN
COULD HANDLE SO I PURCHASED A
BRICK AND MORTAR COMMERCIAL
BAKERY NOW THAT I HAVE OWNED
BOTH TYPES OF BUSINESSES I HAVE
A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE ON THE
ADVANTAGES AND LIMITATIONS OF
THEM UNDER THE CARPET GOOD LUCK
GIVE SOMEONE AN AMAZING CHANCE
TO START A BUSINESS FROM THEIR
HOME CALIFORNIA'S HIGH
POSSIBILITY AND THE CURRENT.
FIFTY THOUSAND CAP WOULD LIMIT.
EIGHTY FOR COTTAGE. TO GO INTO
COMMERCIAL COULD BEFORE REALLY
TO TAKE. BACK I'VE BEEN IN THAT.
IN I ABOUT. THREE OF WORKING TO
MAKE A CALLS EVERY. IT PART OF
THE AMERICAN. AND AT THE FO I'M
NOT. TO PAY A SMALL BUSINESS
MANY RISK. WITH THIS BILL WE
ARE NOT ASKING TO CHANGE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS
MERELY ADJUSTING AND EXPANDING
THE GUIDELINES. AND BOUNDARIES
TO ALLOW BUSINESSES TO GROW. I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THOUSANDS OF COTTAGE FOOD
OPERATORS BY PASSING AB ELEVEN
FORTY FOUR. WHICH SHOULD BRING
HOPE TO SO MANY PEOPLE HAVE A
GREAT NEED FOR INCOME
GENERATING OPTION. ESPECIALLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANKS VERY MUCH. WELL MOVE ON
TO ADDITIONAL. AND SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY ELEVEN FORTY FOUR BEGAN
PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE OF PUBLIC
OURS WITH THE ROOM ONE TWELVE
SEEING NO ONE ROOM TWELVE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WOULD TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF EIGHTY ELEVEN
FORTY FOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU PLAYS
IN GERMAN IF YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
ONE ONE FOUR FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH
TONE PHONE. ONCE AGAIN SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN FORTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. I SHOULD BE
JUST A MOMENT. ONE ONE ONE FOUR
AND SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. TO BE JUST ANOTHER
MOMENT. WE SHOULD YOUR PATIENCE
BE JUST ANOTHER MOMENT. YOUR
LINE NUMBER FIFTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DAVE FRENCH CENTRIC
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF A. B. ELEVEN FORTY FOUR.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. WOULD BE
JUST ONE MOMENT. THE MOMENT. I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE ME
JUST ONE MORE. YOUR LINE NUMBER
ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JORDAN THE NAME YES FOR CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE INSTITUTE FOR
JUSTICE IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
FORTY FOUR. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
MISTER CHAIRPERSON AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NOBODY ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU MODERATOR WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
AT ELEVEN FORTY FOUR- THERE'S
NO FORMALLY REGISTERED-
OPPOSITION TO TESTIFY I WILL
MOVE THE PUBLIC GALLERY SAY
NORTH PUBLIC ALEX MOVED TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE SEEN ON ROOM TWELVE.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO SHOULD
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR. THANK YOU IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION AB ELEVEN
FORTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE CAN
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
BE JUST ANOTHER MOMENT. AND
AGAIN IN OPPOSITION AB ELEVEN
FORTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT.
I APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE THE
ONE MOBILE. YOUR AVAILABLE ONE
FORTY EIGHTH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS BACK YEAH. THE
CLOSEST. THANK YOU THANKS LINE.
A MATURE PERSON AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH
MODERATOR WILL NOW BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR- I JUST WANT TO
ALSO COMMENT THAT THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
THINK IT'S JUST A GOOD BELL AND
TIGHT LIKE TO MOVE FORWARD WHEN
APPROPRIATE THANK YOU ALL
RIGHTS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
RUBIO ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. RIGHT I THANK YOU A
SIMILAR REAVIS FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I THINK
ADDRESSES- MANY ISSUES I ALSO
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH DIRECTORS-
SO THAT THERE'S NOW A- IT'S
INSPECTION REQUIREMENT A
CERTAIN THRESHOLD TO ENSURE
FOOD SAFETY AT THOSE VERY
IMPORTANT TO REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK THOSE COMPONENTS
TOGETHER SO WE CAN HELP SUPPORT
COLLEGE STUDENTS STREET WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I JUST
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO- TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING AND RESPECT THAT'S WHAT
I LOVE. ALL RIGHT THANKS VERY
MUCH TO SOME REMEMBER. THOSE
MOVED BY SENATOR RUBIO THE
MOTIONS TO PASS THE FIRST. BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS CONSULT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PAN HI CAN I AM
MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S I AIKMAN.
EGGMAN EIGEN SOLACE. GROVE HER
TADO FOR TOTAL LIZA I LIVE I
LIVE ALONE LIMONEIRA. RUBIO HI
RUBIO I WINNER. THE BILL
CURRENTLY HAS SET US AT SEVEN
ZERO WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL.
ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER ASC CENTER QUEUE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT EIGHTY ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR HI SUMMER SHOE
WELCOME- PLEASE BEGIN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR WHICH
WOULD STRENGTHEN. PATIENT
CONFIDENTIALITY PROTECTIONS FOR
THOSE WHO ARE NOT THE PRIMARY
POLICY HOLDER FOR THEIR
INSURANCE. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE MANY PEOPLE WERE NOT THE
PRIMARY POLICY HOLDER FOR THEIR
INSURANCE. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY NOT WHO ARE
ON THEIR PARTNER'S HEALTH PLAN
WAR IN MANY INSTANCES DUE TO
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT YOUNG
ADULTS WHO ARE STAYING ON THEIR
PARENTS HEALTH PLANS UNTIL THE
AGE OF TWENTY SIX. IN SOME
INSTANCES PRIMARY POLICY
HOLDERS MAY RECEIVE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE TYPE OF CARE
PROVIDED. THAT A PATIENT MAY
NOT WANT REVEALED. IN SOME
INSTANCES IT COULD ACTUALLY
EVEN BE DANGEROUS FOR A PRIMARY
POLICY HOLDER TO RECEIVE
INFORMATION. ABOUT THE SERVICES
THAT A PATIENT ON THEIR PLAN
HAS RECEIVED. FOR EXAMPLE A
WOMAN WHO'S ACCESSING
REPRODUCTIVE CARE OR CARE
RELATED TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
MAY NOT WANT HER PARTNER TO
KNOW SHE'S ACCESSING THAT CARE.
FOR TRANSGENDER YOUTH MAY NOT
WANT THEIR PARENTS TO KNOW THAT
THEY'RE ACCESSING HEALTHCARE
SERVICES. THIS BILL WOULD
UPDATE EXISTING PATIENT PRIVACY
LAWS TO DO A NUMBER OF THINGS
FIRST. IT AUTOMATICALLY ENSURES
THE COMMUNICATIONS FROM THE
INSURANCE COMPANY REGARDING
SENSITIVE SERVICES AS THE FINER
CONFIDENTIAL. AND NOT SENT TO
THE PRIMARY POLICY HOLDER.
SECOND IT EXPANDS EXISTING
DEFINITION OF SENSITIVE
SERVICES TO INCLUDE. BEHAVIOR
HEALTH CARE AND GENDER FOR ME
CARE. EXTENDING AUTOMATIC
CONFIDENTIALITY FOR THOSE
SERVICES AND THIRD. THAT
ENSURES THAT PATIENTS WHO ARE
RECEIVING SENSITIVE SERVICES
HAVE A PATHWAY TO REQUEST
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS
FROM THEIR HEALTH PLAN. OR TO
TAKE A MOMENT AND THANK THE
CHAIR OF HIS COMMITTEE STAFF.
FOR THEIR DEEP ENGAGEMENT ON
THIS BILL. I'M COMMITTED TO
TAKING AMENDMENTS AND SENATE
JUDICIARY TO DO A NUMBER OF
THINGS TO CLARIFY. THAT
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATION
REQUEST SUPPLY TO ALL SERVICES
NOT JUST ONE OR A FEW. AND
SECONDLY TO REMOVE THE
EXPLANATION OF BENEFITS FROM
THE LIST OF DOCUMENTS IN WHICH
HEALTH PLANS MUST NOTIFY.
PATIENTS ABOUT THE CCR PROCESS.
AND WE JUST ALSO MENTION THAT
IN RECENT DAYS WE'VE HEARD SOME
OPPOSITION SUGGEST. THAT THIS
BILL MIGHT BE CHANGING EXISTING
MEDICAL CONSENT LAW OR CHANGING
THE AGE OF CONSENT FOR
SERVICES. I WANNA BE VERY CLEAR
THAT THAT IS NOT WHAT THIS BILL
DOES ALL WE ARE DOING IS
ENSURING THAT FOLKS WHO NEED
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS CAN
RECEIVE THEM. AND WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO RETURN IT OVER TO OUR
MAIN WITNESSES WE HAVE MOLLY
ROBSON. WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD. AND TOMMY MARTIN
WITH A QUALITY CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH DECEMBER TWO
AND APPRECIATE AGAIN ARE YOU
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS WHICH
WILL BE TAKEN UP ACTUALLY AND
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THAT'S
WEATHERED UP FOR YOU- I THINK
YOU PEOPLE HAVE A COPY SHOULD.
RECEIVE COPY BUT THEY WILL BE
TAKEN UP TO A JUDICIARY. SO
WITH THAT- WE'RE GOING TO FIRST
BEGAN WITH US HI WATSON FROM
PLANNED PARENTHOOD IS UP IN THE
GALLERY YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES-
TOTAL FOUR MINUTES FOR BOTH
WITNESSES HAVE YOU GO OVER. TO
KEEP IN MIND THAT SHORTENS THE
TIME FOR YOUR- COMPATRIOT- SO
WE'LL BEGIN WITH- MY ROBISON
WELCOME. THANK YOU SHARE. A
GOOD MORNING MOLLY ROPES AND
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA. WE REPRESENT THE
SEVEN PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES WHO SERVE OVER ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION PATIENTS.
ANNUALLY ACROSS THE STATE.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD IS
SPONSORING A B. ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR TO CONTINUE THE IMPORTANT
WORK ADVOCATES AND LAWMAKERS
UNDERTOOK. WHEN THEY PASSED SB
ONE THIRTY EIGHT YEARS AGO.
THANKS AT THE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PATIENTS HAVE CONTINUED TO FIND
IT DIFFICULT TO EXERCISE THEIR
RIGHTS UNDER THE LAW. TO GET
CONFIDENTIALITY FOR THEIR
HEALTH CARE. FOR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD CONFIDENTIALITY IS
AT THE CORE OF ITS ROLE AS A
TRUSTED HEALTH CARE PROVIDER.
ASIAN SHOULD BE ABLE TO ACCESS
SENSITIVE SERVICES LIKE
REPRODUCTIVE CARE GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE. MENTAL HEALTH
CARE OR STI CARE WITHOUT FEAR
OF THEIR PRIVATE INFORMATION
BEING EXPOSED. WHEN A PATIENT
SEEKS CARE THEY MAY NOT REALIZE
THAT THEIR INFORMATION ABOUT
THE CARE THEY RECEIVE. COULD BE
DISCLOSED BY ROUTINE. NOTICES
FROM THEIR HEALTH INSURER. THIS
IS ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR MINORS
AND YOUNG ADULTS ARE ON THEIR
PARENTS INSURANCE. ANYONE WHO
HAS SET WHO HAS HAD AN ADVOCATE
COVERAGE ISSUES WITH THEIR
HEALTH INSURANCE KNOWS. IT'S
NOT A SIMPLE OR EASY PROCESS.
AND PATIENTS RELY ON OTHER
PEOPLE FOR THEIR HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. SHOULD NOT HAVE THE
BURDEN OF ENLISTING AND HELP.
IT LISTING THE HELP. OF
CONSUMER RIGHTS ATTORNEYS AND
ADVOCATES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THEY GET THE MEDICAL CARE
THEY NEED CONFIDENTIALLY.
HEALTHCARE IS PERSONAL AND THIS
BILL SIMPLY EXPANDS WHO CAN
RECEIVE CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS FROM THEIR
INSURANCE. AND INSURE THAT
PATIENTS AND THEIR INFORMATION
ARE KEPT SAFE. FOR THESE
REASONS WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT.
OR SPONSOR EIGHTY ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR AND WOULD URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING ON THE LINE- TOMMY MARTIN
FROM EQUALITY CALIFORNIA. ALSO
PROVIDE CUSTOMER SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS TOMMY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE VERY PROUD
TO SUPPORT EIGHTY ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR WHICH WILL CONTINUE
CALIFORNIA'S LEGACY OF
PROTECTING VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING LGBTQ
PLUS PEOPLE AND TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE IN PARTICULAR WHILE
OTHER LEGISLATURES OUTSIDE
CALIFORNIA ARE LAUNCHING
ASSAULT AGAINST THEM. AND IF SO
WILL IMPROVE THE WAY INSURANCE
COMMUNICATIONS WORK SO
CURRENTLY PATIENTS WERE UNDER
SOMEONE ELSE'S PLAN THE OPTION
OF SUBMITTING WHAT'S CALLED THE
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS
REQUIRED OR IF WE ARE TO THEIR
PLANS. THE AUTHOR DESCRIBED IT
TO NPR IS SUPPOSED TO ENSURE
THAT ONLY THE PATIENT RECEIVED
DOCUMENTS RELATING TO THAT
PATIENT CARE WHICH IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE SEEKING LGBTQ CLASS BUT
THAT THERE. COULD YOU NOT HAVE
RECORDED FAMILY. EVEN BACK THE
R. ALL THE TRANSLATE INTO FULL
CONFIDENCE. IS THAT HOW CAN SHE
IS COMPLEX AND NOT MANY
PATIENTS AREN'T EQUIPPED TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TO NAVIGATE IT
HERE'S ONE EXAMPLE. IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN AN LGBTQ CLASS
PATIENT FILED A CPR HE CONFIRMS
THAT THE DVR WAS INCREASED AND
THEREFORE WAS CONFIDENT THAT
HIS INFORMATION WOULD BE
PROTECTED. HE PROCEEDED TO
OBTAIN CRAP WHICH IS A HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE HIV PREVENTION
MEDICATION. WHICH GIVES PEOPLE
MORE AGENCY OVER THEIR HOUSE.
AND THEIR WELL BEING AND THEIR
FUTURE. STATIONS ARE ON ALL
UNDERGO ROUTINE TESTS THE
CONDITION OF BEING ON
MEDICATION. AND INFORMATION
RELATED TO THESE SERVICES WHAT
IS CLOSE TO THE POLICY OWNER
WHICH IN THIS CASE WITH THE
PATIENT'S MOTHER. AND IT'S LED
TO HIM BEING POURED OUT HIS
VIAL CANLEY. SO THE PATIENT
MADE A RESPONSIBLE DECISION TO
SAFEGUARD THE ACCOUNT AND IN
DOING SO IT WAS STRIPPED OF THE
ABILITY TO COME OUT ON HIS
TERMS. IN HIS MIND AND IN A WAY
THAT WOULD BE SAFE THERE FOR
HAND. FOR THIS BILL WILL HELP
TO GET PATIENTS TO THE PRIVACY
DIGNITY AND SAFETY EVERYONE
DOES THEIR WHEN SEEKING HEALTH
CARE AND WE RESPECTFULLY. URGE
THE CANADIAN COURT TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK VERY MUCH- WITHOUT
WANT TO DO KNOW WHAT THIS IS
AND SOME OF A DEAL EIGHTY FOUR
BEGIN WITH PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE
ON ELSE THE PUBLIC GALLERY WILL
MOVE OUT TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
TINO ELSE ROOM TWELVE.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
TO WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU. BEIJING JAN IF YOUR
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MORNING GO
TO LINE NUMBER ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT TO
A LINE NUMBER ONE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIND ONE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY BESSEMER LINE NUMBER FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARTIN
RADAKOVICH ON BEHALF OF MAYOR
OUT PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANKS TO A LINE
NUMBER ONE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE LAWSUIT ON BEHALF
OF THE CENTRAL AXIS TELL HIM
SUPPORT. BUT NOW THE LINE
NUMBER SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING TRIBUTARY TWENTY
MEMBER THIS IS THE LAWNS YOUR
CALL ON THE HOCKEY FIELD YOU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
ONE FOUR ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. INTERESTED IN THE
SHIPPERS WITH WOMEN ORGANIZED
RESPONSE LECTURING DISEASES AND
THAT THAT IN THE CALIFORNIA
INSTRUCTED THE ELEVENTH BEFORE.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THROUGH A
ONE NUMBER ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT JOHN
BEHALF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBGYN STITCHES NINE GET SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOUR SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH
TONE PHONE. MISTER CHAIRPERSON
WE HAVE NOBODY ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU MODERATOR WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
US EIGHTY ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR WE
HAVE TO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES TO PLEASE BRING ON TO
THE LINE STEPHANIE WATKINS FROM
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND SUSAN ARE NOW.
FROM- THE RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE-
SO- CAN YOU PLEASE FIRST BRING
ON STEPHANIE WATKINS- EACH OF
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES TOTAL FOR
MINUTES BETWEEN THE BOTH OF YOU.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANY. I'M LIKE THE
BIRTH EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION
TO THE CHAIRS WHILE AT THE
AKURE SPONSORING COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS TO
HEAR OUR CONCERNS IN THE
LENGTHY DISCUSSIONS WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO HAVE. REGRETTABLY AS
ADULTS YOUNG THEY REMAIN
OPPOSED. AS PREVIOUSLY
REFERENCES MEASURES EXPAND THE
MANNER IN WHICH IS GROWING YOUR
INSURANCE CAN SUBMIT A REQUEST
TO HAVE THEIR MEDICAL
INFORMATION FOR YOU DIRECTED TO
ALTERNATE ADDRESS. OFTEN-REFERRED TO AS THE CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATION REQUEST. AS WELL
AS THE OBLIGATION PLANS
INSURERS HONOR THOSE REQUESTS.
UNFORTUNATELY AS WE STARTED THE
PROCESS WE CANNOT FULLY
APPRECIATE HOW BROAD THE
INCIDENTS THEY'LL LET THEM HAVE
MOSTLY FOCUSED ON THE PRIVACY
ISSUES RELATED TO SENSITIVE
SERVICES. AND THE NEEDED
INSPIRED UPDATE THE REGIONAL
LEGISLATION SIGNATURE ON MOST
VULNERABLE PATIENTS AND
SERVICES RECEIVED THE PHONE
PROTECTIONS INTENDED BY THE
ORIGINATING LEGISLATION SB ONE
THIRTY EIGHT. AS SOME OF YOU
MAY REMEMBER AT THE ONE THIRTY
EIGHT WAS ORIGINALLY DRAFTED
UNDERSTANDING THAT CRITICAL
BALANCE OF INSURING PATIENTS
ACTIVE IMPORTANT PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS. ALSO PREACHING
THAT MR DEPARTMENT WOULD BE
PLACED ON PLANS AND ENSURE.
IMPLEMENTING THIS TYPE. ONLY
REQUIRES AN INITIAL WORKAROUND
BY THE PLAN BUT IT ALSO
REQUIRES THE PLAN TO CONTRIBUTE
TRACK EACH REQUEST. AND GINGER
THE COMBINATION OF BEING
APPROPRIATELY KNOWLEDGE IS
HONORED BY ALL PRINTERS. AND
NETWORK THE BILL CURRENTLY
STANDS THE OBLIGATION PLANS ON
A CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNIQUE.
COMMUNICATION REQUESTS WILL NO
LONGER BE LIMITED TO SENSITIVE
SERVICES. BUT INSTEAD WILL BE
BROADLY APPLIED ALL. CERTAINLY
ANYONE HAS THE RIGHT TO REQUEST
THAT THE THING IN OUR
HEADPHONES LOUD FOR SOME
FLEXIBILITY- FOR A REASONABLE
STANDARD TO BE APPLIED WHICH
ALLOWS THE PLANT SOME
FLEXIBILITY ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
REMOVES ACCESSIBILITY REQUIRED
PLANS INSURANCE ON OCT EIGHTEEN
ARE. UNKNOWN VOLUME OF REQUESTS
AS WELL AS THE POTENTIAL
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN AND COSTS
THAT COULD PLAY SOME PLANS AND
INSURE THAT CERTAINLY
CONCERNING. ADDITIONALLY THE
MOST RECENTLY PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS INCLUDE AN EXTENSIVE
LIST OF NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS. WE APPRECIATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF ENSURING ON
RELATED INSURANCE- WHERE THEIR
RATES THE NOTICE PROVISIONS
SEEM TO GO BEYOND. AND ABOVE
WHAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED
TYPICAL WITH THAT IN MIND WE
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THE
SECTION TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
INADVERTENTLY APPLYING THE
NOTIFICATION PROVISIONS AND
APPROPRIATELY COMMUNICATION
SUCH AS APPOINTMENT TEXT
MESSAGES EXCEPT FOR. WITH THAT
IN MIND WE CONTINUE TO BE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE BUT
LOOK FORWARD TO FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS AT THE SUMMIT.
SUPPORT ACT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NOW LET'S BRING
TO THE ARE NOW. YOU KNOW HOW A
MINUTE AND- FOR SECONDS- TO
PRESENT. IT IS AN ARNOLD
TRAINING WAS THE RIGHT LIFE
WEEK AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR FOR
IN COMPANY TO KEEP SECRET FROM
PARENTS KEEPING SECRETS HURTS
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
CALIFORNIA ONLY ALLOWS CHILDREN
THE ABILITY TO CONSENT TO A
VARIETY OF MEDICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL SERVICES WHILE
KEEPING IN THE DARK. EIGHTY
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR FOR YOUR
INSURANCE COMPANY TO KEEP
ABORTION SEXUAL ASSAULT
TREATMENT DRUG ABUSE AND MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT CROSS SEX
HORMONES PUBERTY BLOCKERS ON
SEX CHANGE OPERATION SECRET
FROM PARENTS. CHILD PREDATORS
AND SEX TRAFFICKERS RELIANCE
SECRET SPEECH TO MANIPULATE
THEIR VICTIMS SO WHAT CANHE
TAKE A GIRL AS YOUNG AS TWELVE
YEARS OLD TO GET TREATMENT FOR
STDS OR AN ABORTION. SOMEONE
ELSE CAN MANIPULATE A THIRTEEN
YEAR OLD AUTISTIC BOY TO SPEAK
SPEAK THEIR ALLIES IN PUBERTY
BLOCKERS AND CROSS SEX HORMONES
FOR RAPID ONSET GENDER
DYSPHORIA MINORS TWELVE AND WE
DO NOT NEED PARENTAL CONSENT.
FOR THE MEDICAL SERVICES UNDER
OUR CURRENT STATE LAW SPEECH TO
TEACHERS ARE COVERED BY
INSURANCE AND EIGHTY ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR SURE THAT PARENTS
NEVER FIND OUT THAT HELPS THOSE
WHO ABUSED TRAFFICKED AND
MANIPULATE CHILDREN BY KEEPING
TREATMENT SEEKERS. SECRET
DOMESTIC ABUSERS RELY ON
SECRECY TO CONTINUE THERE
APPEARS TO BE A YOUNG WOMAN ONE
FRIENDLY CHURCH AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOR FUTURE TREATMENT FOR
READY FOR IT HE DEFLECTED FROM
HER PARENTS WERE PAYING FOR IT.
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC ABUSE NEED
FAMILY SUPPORT TO ENCOURAGE
THEM TO REPORT AND CYCLES OF
VIOLENCE AND IF SHE COULD BE
USING DRUGS OR IS SUICIDAL
EIGHTY ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR MAKES
THAT COMPANY KEEP THAT SECRET
FROM HER PARENTS TOO. AND
EIGHTY ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR IS
WRAPPED UP WITH THE INSURANCE
FRAUD WHAT IS THE INSURANCE
MISTAKENLY KILLED THE POLICY
HOLDER FOR ONE OF THE- SERVICES
FOR SOMEONE NOT COVERED UNDER.
INSURANCE PLEASE REMEMBER.
THANK YOU CAN'T BE WE GET
PREVENT. HE DON'T MAKE IT COME
KEEP YOU FOR PARENTS. NO ON
ELEVEN FOUR THANK. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WE'RE NOW WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO WITH ENOUGH. TO IT
LET EIGHTY FOUR WITH PUBLIC
GALA. NAME OR DATE POSITION-
ONLY PLEASE. HELLO MY NAME IS
GREG BIRD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
RIGHT SO NO ONE ELSE IN THE
PUBLIC ALICE MOVED TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. SEEN ON ROOM ONE
TWELVE- MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU BEIJING JAN IF YOU
ARE AN OPPOSITION AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ON
JAN OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. YES ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. YOUR LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS KENNEDY ISLAND WE
I'D BE AN AMBASSADOR FOR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND I AM IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANKS LINE. THANKS
TO A LINE NUMBER ONE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANY HERRINGTON FROM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. THANKS TO A LINE
NUMBER ONE FIFTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TONY ROSALYN CAPITAL
RESEARCH INSTITUTE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXT ONE NUMBER ONE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FINE ONE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SCHERING NAKED JOB. MOTHER
RANDOM OTHER ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHER STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. I NUMBER ONE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME
IS ERIN FRIDAY I'M AN ATTORNEY%
A LOVING PARENTS AND A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA PARENTS OF
RAPID ONSET GENDER GENDER
DYSPHORIC CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU FOR NEXT LINE. THANKS TO A
LINE NUMBER ONE FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
TED WHO THAT GO I'M WITH THE
SAMPLES I'M A PARENT I'M WITH
THE SAN FRANCISCO PARENTS OF
RAPID ONSET GENDER DYSPHORIC
CHILDREN I LOST CUSTODY OF MY
CHILD JUST NAME ORGANIZATIONAL
SHELL BEACH ARE YOU OPPOSED. I
AM ABSOLUTELY OPPOSED TO THIS
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS VERY
MUCH NEXT LINE. THANKS TO A
LINE NUMBER ONE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A LINE ONE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS ELLEN WAY I'M
A CONCERNED MOTHER FROM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. THANKS TO THE LINE NUMBER
ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS YASSER ARAFAT- I
HAVE A TEENAGE TEACHER
TRANSITION- AND ALSO AN
ASSISTANT CONTROLLER AND PART.
OF THE MODEL WITH GENDER
DYSPHORIA. A THANK YOU NEXT
SLIDE. THANKS TO A LINE NUMBER
ONE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME'S PRISCILLA NICHOLS
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA MOTHER
GRANDMOTHER IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
THEN ONCE MORE IF YOU ARE AN
OPPOSITION AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. YOUR LINE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO PARENTS GRANDPARENTS
STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. THE NATIONAL LINE NUMBER
ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I THINK I ALREADY SPOKE. THANK
YOU BOB A POST THANK YOU THANKS
LINE THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRPERSON AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANKS
THANKS VERY MUCH MODERATOR WILL
BRING IT BACK THE COMMITTEE OR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CENTER
MELINDA'S. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN- ASSEMBLYMAN
CHEWED GOOD TO SEE YOU- I. HAVE
A GREAT NUMBER OF CONCERNS WITH
THIS BILL FROM A PARENT'S
PERSPECTIVE- I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH FOR ADULTS-AND I
DO RECOGNIZE THAT SP THIRTY
EIGHT PUT MUCH OF THIS ALREADY
INTO STATUTE. BUT AS A PARENT-
EIGHT I AM I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW IT'S A GOOD
THING THAT A CHILD WHO'S GOING
THROUGH SOMETHING THAT COULD BE
LIFE CHANGING OR SOMETHING
THAT'S- REALLY AND- AN
EMOTIONAL DIFFICULTY THAT THIRD
STRUGGLING WITH HOW. IT'S OKAY
TO KEEP THE PARENTS FROM
KNOWING THAT IN AN EFFORT TO
YOU KNOW FOR THOSE PARENTS OR
OTHER CAREGIVERS- TO HELP THEM
THROUGH THAT AND- YOUR CHILDREN
YOUR YOUR YOUR SON HE'S LITTLE-
SO YOU HAVEN'T EXPERIENCED YET
THE- THE EMOTIONAL ROLLER
COASTER KNOWN AS- TEENAGERS.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU IT'S- IT
CAN BE A STRUGGLE IN TEENAGERS
AND EVEN YOU KNOW PRETEENS
TYPICALLY. YOU KNOW THEY DON'T
LIKE TO TALK TO YOUR PARENTS
ABOUT A LOT OF THINGS. WE
DIDN'T I'M SURE THEIR RATINGS
WOULD PREFER TO TALK TO OUR
FRIENDS ABOUT OR SOMEONE ELSE
BUT NOT CERTAINLY NOT HER
PARENTS. THE SAME GOES HOLDS
TRUE FOR TODAY HOWEVER THAT
DOESN'T NEGATE THE FACT THAT
CHILDREN REALLY DO NEED THEIR
PARENTS INPUT AND GUIDANCE AND
COUNSEL ON SOME OF THESE
ISSUES. AND BY PASSING
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS THIS
MEANS THAT THE PARENT HAS NO
HOPE OF EVEN BEING ABLE TO
ADDRESS IT- AND- I THINK ABOUT.
BUT CHECK MY CHILD A MINOR WHO
IS ACCESSING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES NOW. IF A PARENT
DOESN'T KNOW THAT THIS IS
TAKING PLACE AND A PARENT
DOESN'T KNOW THAT THIS. MINOR
IS. SEEKING THESE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES PERHAPS BEING GIVEN
MEDICATION TO TREAT IT HOW IN
THE WORLD IS APPARENT ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE THE SIGNS THAT
SOMETHING MAY BE GOING TERRIBLY
WRONG CAN BE ABLE TO REACH OUT
AND HELP THEM. IMAGINE THE-
LIKE THE GUILT THAT WOULD
OVERWHELM THE PARENT IF. YOU
KNOW SOMETHING WERE TO HAPPEN
TO THEIR CHILD AND- THEY WERE
IGNORANT OF WHAT WAS TAKING
PLACE THAT SAID THAT'S TERRIBLE
BURDEN. TO PLACE ON A PARENT
WHO- LIKELY LOVES THEIR CHILD
MAYBE THEY'RE HAVING SOME
DIFFICULTY IN SOME DIFFERENCES
BUT STILL LOVES THEIR CHILD- SO
FOR THAT REASON I AM NOT ABLE
TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY BUT
I WONDER IF. PERHAPS YOU COULD
COMMENT ON SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
THANK YOU ABSOLUTELY I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO LET ME JUST START BY
SAYING. AS APPARENTLY Q. ALL OF
US CARE VERY DEEPLY FOR OUR
CHILDREN WANT TO WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE GETTING THE BEST
CARE POSSIBLE- WHAT I. WILL SAY
A FEW THINGS- I UNDERSTAND THAT
FOR. MANY OPPONENTS OF THIS
BILL WE ALL MAY HAVE A BIT OF A
PHILOSOPHICAL DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION ON A PATIENT'S RIGHT TO
PRIVACY AND THE RIGHT TO
CHOOSE. BUT I DO WANT TO MAKE
IT VERY CLEAR WHAT THIS BILL
DOES AND WHAT IT DOES NOT
BECAUSE I THINK- THE
OPPOSITION'S. ARGUMENTS ARE BIT
MISPLACED. WITH REGARD TO WHAT
IS CURRENT LAWSUIT THE
OPPOSITION HAS BEEN ASSERTING
THAT SOMEHOW THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW CHILDREN TO ACCESS
MEDICAL CARE IN SECRET. FROM
THEIR PARENTS AND THAT
STATEMENT IS JUST FRANKLY NOT
TRUE- THIS BILL DOESN'T CHANGE
ANYTHING ABOUT EXISTING
MEDICAL. CONSENT LAW IT DOESN'T
CHANGE WHAT SERVICES A MINOR
CAN CONSENT TO WITHOUT PARENTAL
SIGN OFF- SO THERE ARE MANY
LAWS STATE AND FEDERAL. ON
MINOR CONSENT TO GIVE MINERS
THE RIGHT TO ACCESS SERVICES
LIKE PREGNANCY AND ABORTION
CARE. MENTAL HEALTH CARE STD
SERVICES WITHOUT PARENTAL
CONSENT AND SO I APPRECIATE
THAT- I THINK A LOT OF
OPPOSITION. MAY WISH THAT THOSE
LAWS WERE DIFFERENT. BUT THIS
BILL DOESN'T IMPACT THAT SO
JUST WANNA MAKE THAT CLEAR WHAT
THIS BILL DOES SAY THOUGH IS IF
A PARENT CAN CAN IF IT IF THE
PATIENT WAS A YOUNG PERSON. BUT
CAN CONSENT TO A SENSE OF
SERVICE WITHOUT THEIR PARENTS.
THEN THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE COMMUNICATIONS ON THE
CARE THAT IS CONFIDENTIAL SO
THAT'S WHAT THIS WHAT THIS BILL
DOES SPIKE AGAIN I APPRECIATE
THAT WE MAY HAVE A DIFFERENCE
OF OPINION ON. THE AGE OF
MEDICAL CONSENT AND WHEN THAT
COULD HAPPEN BUT THAT'S A
DIFFERENT BILL FOR DIFFERENT.
CONVERSATIONS AND I APPRECIATE
THAT IN YOUR RATE I THINK MANY
OF US WOULD PREFERRED THAT
THOSE LAWS WERE IN PLACE THAT
WE COULD YOU KNOW BE THERE FOR
KIDS WHEN THEY MAY NEED US EVEN
THOUGH THEY MAY NOT. BE OPEN TO
DISCUSSING THE ISSUE BUT I
THINK. ALSO THE HEART OF THE
BILL IS THAT IT REALLY IS
CEILING. THIS WHOLE EVOLUTION
INVOLVED SO THAT A PARENT HAS
ABSOLUTELY NO WAY OF KNOWING
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH THEIR
CHILD WHILE IT'S TRUE. THAT YOU
YOU KNOW EXIST LINE WILL ALLOW
THEM TO. THIS CARE WITHOUT
THEIR PARENTS KNOWLEDGE THIS
BILL. GOES FURTHER TO MAKE SURE
THAT ANY- BILLING INFORMATION
IS ALSO KEPT CONFIDENTIAL AND
IS NOT SENT TO THE PARENT. WHO
IS THE POLICY HOLDER WHO IS YOU
KNOW PAYING FOR THAT INSURANCE
POLICY SO IT REALLY DOES. LOCK
IT AWAY SO THAT A PARENT. JUST
HAS NO KNOWLEDGE OF IT AND
THAT'S THAT'S- THAT'S THE CORE
ISSUE BUT I APPRECIATE YOU.
MAKING THE CLARIFICATION THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. XCERRA LABOR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND I ALSO THANK
HIM FOR HIS CLARIFICATION I DO
ALSO THINK THAT THE OPPOSITION
IS CONFUSED ON WHAT THIS BILL
DOES AND I BELIEVE THAT THEY
MAY WANT TO CHANGE CURRENT AND
EXISTING LAW BUT I WOULD ALSO
SAY THAT MANY OF THE PEOPLE WHO
CALLED IT IN OPPOSITION ARE
PROBABLY THE ONES WHO NEED THIS
BILL THE MOST BECAUSE MOST OF
THESE PARENTS ARE NOT PARENTS
WHO'D BE ACCEPTING. OF THEIR
CHILDREN IF THEY ARE DIFFERENT
FROM SOCIETAL NORMS YOU'VE ALL
HEARD HEARD ME TALK ABOUT MY
DAUGHTER WHO IS GAY AND WHEN
SHE CAME OUT TO US SHE SAID I
ALWAYS KNEW I COULD COME OUT TO
YOU BUT YOU'VE PROBABLY ALSO
HEARD ME TALK ABOUT HER FRIENDS
FRIENDS THAT WE KNEW WHOSE
PARENTS KICK THEM OUT OF THE
HOUSE WHEN THEY SAID THAT THEY
WERE GAY SO ALL FAMILIES AREN'T
LOVING ALL FAMILIES AREN'T
ACCEPTING AND THIS IS ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT CHILDREN HAVE
ACCESS TO THE HEALTH CARE THAT
THEY NEED I WISH WE LIVED IN A
WORLD WHERE EVERY FAMILY
ACCEPTED THEIR CHILD THE WAY
THEY WORK. BUT THE FACT IS WE
JUST DON'T SO THANK YOU SOME
REMEMBER FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
RUBIO THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR-
FROM SAN FRANCISCO FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND I'M- GLAD THAT
HE CLARIFIED. THE ISSUE AT HAND
AND THAT EXISTING MEDICAL
CONSENT. DOESN'T CHANGE. BUT I
ALSO WANTED JUST TO SHARE IT
YOU KNOW. THIS BUT JUST SIMPLY.
GIVES PATIENTS THE ABILITY TO
MAKE BETTER HEALTH. CHOICES AND
BETTER HEALTH CHOICES CLEARLY
MAKE FOR YOU KNOW HEALTHIER
LIVE. LONGER LIVES- I ALSO VERY
PLEASED THAT THE AUTHOR
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL. I IT X.
BANSTEAD TO INCLUDE INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE WHICH IS I
BELIEVE IS ALSO VERY CRITICAL.
AS A SURVIVOR MYSELF. AN
ADVOCATE FOR VICTIMS I DO
UNDERSTAND JUST HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS TO KEEP SOME OF THE
SERVICES. CONFIDENTIAL SADLY
AND TOO OFTEN. TOP VIOLENT
PARTNERS WILL RESORT TO
REPRODUCTIVE COURSE OF CONTROL
WHICH MEANS LITERALLY. MAKING
EVERY DECISION FOR THE VICTIM
THEIR PARTNER. AND DIE
FOLLOWING. THESE VICTIMS TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE DECISIONS FOR
THEMSELVES AND GET THE CARE
THEY NEED WITHOUT FEAR OF.
RETALIATION I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO OUR IN MY- OPINION
THIS MAY MEAN THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN LIFE. OR DEATH FOR SO
MANY OF THESE VICTIMS- AND I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT- YOU KNOW I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CONCERNS. OF
THE OPPOSITION. YOU KNOW SOME.
I'M NOT A PARENT SO I WOULDN'T
UNDERSTAND BUT I DON'T WANT TO
VALIDATE SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS
BUT I JUST THINK THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT AND- AND IT'LL HELP
SO MANY PEOPLE AND I JUST WOULD
LIKE TO SAY- THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR AND THE TEAR FOR WORKING
OUT SOME AT THE- ABBEY THERE'S
SOME DIFFERENCES AND- CAME TO A
CONCLUSION TO RECENT AMENDMENTS
AND WITH THAT. I'D LIKE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTION OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
YES- CENTER ADMIN. THANK YOU
BUT JUST ALSO THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I
HAVE A I HAVE A TWELVE YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER. AND CERTAINLY CAN
UNDERSTAND- HOW PEOPLE START
GETTING NERVOUS AS THEIR AS
THEIR KIDS DEVELOPING GROW. BUT
I ALSO UNDERSTAND. THAT KIDS
NEED TO HAVE SAFE PLACES TO GO.
AND PEOPLE THEY TRUST THAT MY
DAUGHTER HAD A DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION WITH MY WIFE THE
OTHER DAY- AND- OUR BIG
TAKEAWAY WAS IT. WAS WASN'T
THAT WASN'T A GREAT DISH YOU
CAN HAVE THAT CONVERSATION. AND
I THINK THAT'S WHERE WE ALL
NEED TO CONTINUE TO WORK IS TO
HAVE. RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR
KIDS WHERE THEY FEEL
COMFORTABLE COMING TO US- AND
UNDERSTANDING SOMETIMES AND
TRUSTING IN THEM AND IN OUR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEM. THAT
THAT THAT THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
COME THEY'RE GONNA COME BACK
AROUND AND- AND POWER. ARE IN
A- RESPONSIBLE WAY GETTING THE
HELP THAT THEY NEED. THIS IS
ABOUT ACCESS TO MEDICAL CARE.
WHICH I THINK IS IMPORTANT AND
NOBODY WOULD ARGUE WITH THAT
FAX I WOULD THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR THIS BILL- MY SELF ON
BEHALF LGBT CAUCUS AS WELL. AND
ASKED TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR. A THE CENTRE MELINDA'S
YES THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN JUST
WITH RESPECT AND DEFERENCE TO
THE AUTHOR WHO IS- HERE I JUST
WANT TO OFFER AN APOLOGY TO THE
CALLERS. WHO CALLED IN IN
OPPOSITION I KNOW THERE ARE
SOME DEROGATORY COMMENTS MADE
ABOUT. HOW THEY FEEL WHAT'S IN
THEIR HEART WHAT KIND OF PARENT
THEY ARE AND I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY IN THIS COMMITTEE
CERTAINLY. WOULD KNOW WHAT TYPE
OF PARENT THEY ARE OR WHAT'S IN
THEIR HEARTS I JUST WANTED TO
OFFER THAT APOLOGY THANK YOU. I
THANK THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT- ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY
SAYING NONE- NO FURTHER
COMMENTS AT A CENTER TO OFFER
SO I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH- OUR COMMITTEE
AND- ALSO I THINK SPONSORS
STUFF THAT. AND TAKING THOSE
AMENDMENTS- WE DID TRY TO
ADDRESS IT BY MAY NOTE THAT
WHEN THE OPPOSITION IS THAT WAS
THE HEALTH PLANS IS TO TRY TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS
ABOUT BIRDS BUT ALSO MAKE NOTE
THAT TO. THAT UNDER FEDERAL LAW
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE AN
OBLIGATION FOR NON SENSITIVE
SERVICES AS WELL IF THOSE
SERVICES- A POTENTIALLY LIFE
THREATENING FOR THAT PATIENT SO
NO THEORY HAVE TO HAVE SOME
KIND OF MECHANISM. TO TRY TO
ADDRESS EVEN ON SENSITIVE
SERVICES AS WELL IN PLACE
BECAUSE OF FEDERAL LAW SO WE
DID WANT TO SIMPLIFY THINGS FOR
THEM WITH THE AMENDMENTS- IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY HAD TO DO-
BUT- ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT BY
FEDERAL LAW THEY ALSO HVE TO
HAVE THAT A SIMILAR MECHANISM
IN PLACE AND SO WE COULD LINE
THOSE TOGETHER- SO HOPEFULLY
THAT. DAY SO- HOPEFULLY THAT
DID HELP ADDRESS SOME OF THAT
IS CERTAINLY- I KNOW I KNOW
THAT- YOU SOMEONE THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE- THE
HEALTH PLANS IF THERE'S OTHER
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE DONE TO
HELP- STILL IMPLEMENT WHAT YOUR
GOALS ARE WHILE. ADDRESSING IT
THERE'S NO OTHER TECHNICAL
ISSUES BUT I THINK WE TRIED TO
ADDRESS THAT IN THOSE
AMENDMENTS I WOULD ALSO MAKE
NOTE THAT- YOU KNOW I'M A
PEDIATRICIAN AND A PARENT OF A
TEEN AND PRETEEN- SO. AND SO AS
PETERSON OF COURSE TAKE CARE
OF- MANY TEENAGERS- I I'VE
HEARD THAT BUT BEFORE I TALK
ABOUT THAT I WANNA KNOWLEDGE
WHAT RUBIO SAID THIS ISN'T JUST
ABOUT THE KIDS THAT WE SIR TALK
ABOUT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND HOW
UNFORTUNATELY THIS INFORMATION
COULD BE USED- TO ACTUALLY-
FOR. THE INCREASE CAN- IN
MESSED VIOLENCE SO WE TO REGRET.
THE WE NEED TO GIVE THOSE
TOOLS- TO PATIENTS SO THEY HAVE
THOSE TOOLS. BUT ALSO IN TERMS
OF- CHILDREN YOU KNOW- WHEN I
SEE A CHILD NAME WANTS TO
DISCLOSE SOMETHING TO ME- AS IN
A VISIT. IN PRIVACY I DO ALWAYS
ENCOURAGE THEM TO DISCUSS IT
WITH THEIR PARENTS. ALL RIGHT.
I MEAN THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO
HAVE HAPPEN THAT'S IDEAL. BUT
THE SAME TIME- WE ALSO KNOW
THAT IF THEY KNEW THERE WASN'T
THE PRIVACY AND THAT AND NOT
SAY ONLY DID IT WITH THEIR
PERMISSION THEY WOULD DISCLOSE
IN THE FIRST PLACE. AND WHAT DO
KNOW IS THAT. CHILDREN IF THEY
CAN GET ADULT GUIDANCE ARE
GONNA MAKE BETTER DECISIONS. SO
THE ISSUE THEN BECOMES. WELL IF
THEY DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
ENOUGH AND I KNOW IT'S
SOMETHING THAT CAN YOU KNOW THE
PARENTS YOU ALWAYS WANT YOUR
CHILD TO COME TO TELL YOU
EVERYTHING BUT LET'S FACE IT
THAT'S NOT REALITY ALL THE TIME
RIGHT FOR WHATEVER. REASONS
DYNAMICS MARISSA NET DOESN'T
HAVE TO DO WITH. A JUDGMENT ON
TERMS OF. WHAT THE OTHER
PARENTS CARE FOR THAT CHILD.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TEENAGERS
RATE AND- AND ADOLESCENTS ARE
GOING UP TRYING TO BECOME
INDEPENDENT AND SOMETIMES THEY
JUST DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
TELLING US AS PARENTS. BUT WE
BASICALLY CLOSE OFF ALL AVENUES
FOR THEM TODAY AND TALK TO
ANOTHER ADULT WHERE DATA
PRIVACY CAN BE MAINTAINED.
INCLUDING PHYSICIANS OR HEALTH
OTHER HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS.
THAT ACTUALLY CAN LEAD TO POOR
DECISIONS BEING MADE AND ALSO-
ENDANGERED THEIR HEALTH AND
SAFETY AS WELL. AND SO I THINK
pLAWS. THAT BY THE WAY IS AS
MENTIONED BY THE AUTHOR THAT
ALREADY PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF
THOSE POLICIES WERE ESTABLISHED
FOR GOOD REASON. TO GET TO HELP
SUPPORT- TO. USE BUT ALSO THAT
WE DON'T HAVE THE SITUATION
THEN FOREIGN MINISTRY TO FLEE
THROUGH THE HEALTH PLAN THAT
BASICALLY UNDERMINES THOSE
PARTICULAR PRIVACY LAWS. AND
THAT'S WHY TO ME THIS BILL SO
VERY IMPORTANT. AND REALLY
APPRECIATE- YOU SIMPLY MEMBER
FOR BEING AFFORDED YOUR
SPONSORS RAY FORD AND WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU WELL. I THINK MANY OF YOU
HAVE STATED. WHAT I WAS GOING
TO SAY MY CLOTHES THAT I FIRST
WELL AGAIN JUST FOR MUCH WANT
TO. THE AND YOUR ENGAGE. IN AND
THE PLANS- AS THEY KNOW WE'VE
WORKED FOR MANY MONTHS TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED- WE THOUGHT WE HAD
GOTTEN THERE AND THEN IN THE
LAST- IN RECENT DAYS WE REALIZE
THERE'S THIS ONE LAST ISSUE
PARTICULARLY TO. ENSURE THAT-
AS REPORTING THIS IN PLACE FOR
DOING THIS WITH. AS MUCH
ADMINISTRATIVE EFFICIENCY AND
SIMPLICITY AS WE CANCEL PREVIEW
THE TEACHERS ENGAGEMENT WITH-
WITH OUR COALITION TO. TO
ENSURE THAT AND- ARE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS ON THAT
FRONT- AS IT WAS POINTED OUT BY
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY- THIS BILL IS
NOT JUST ABOUT- ENSURING.
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE BY BY
YOUNG PEOPLE WE WANT TO ASSURE
THAT ADULTS WHO ARE IN. OR HAVE
EXPERIENCED VIOLENCE IN
INTIMATE PARTNER. VIOLENCE
SITUATIONS FAMILY VIOLENCE
DOMESTIC VIOENCE. ALL THAT
THEIR HEALTH SERVICES ARE
CONFIDENTIAL. IF THEY HAPPEN TO
BE ON THE HEALTH PLAN OF THEIR-
IF THEIR PARTNER- BUT TO ALL
THE PARENTS. WHO HAVE TAKEN
PART IN THIS DISCUSSION- FOR ME
AGAIN AS A PARENT AND I KNOW
THIS IS TRUE FOR. OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM STOCKTON AND FROM THE
INLAND EMPIRE. WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THAT ALL YOUNG
PEOPLE IF HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE. HI AND MANY MAY BE IN.
CHALLENGING SITUATIONS AT HOME-
IF THEY ARE. L. G. B. T. Q. USE
IF THEY ARE- STRUGGLING WITH-
WITH WITH DIFFERENT ELEMENTS-
RELATED TO HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
THAT IS FIRST AND FOREMOST WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE HERE-
AND IT'S BIG AND IMPORTANT NOTE
THAT THIS DOESN'T PREVENT- FOR
EXAMPLE PROVIDER FROM HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH THE PARENTS-
BUT WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT. IF
A MINOR- CAN CONSENT TO A SENSE
OF SERVICE WITHOUT THEIR
PARENTS AND COMMUNICATIONS THE
BILLS. SHOULD ALSO BE
CONFIDENTIAL SO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION-
HOPE THAT- FOLKS CAN SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. OKAY THANK
YOU- ACTUALLY I DO THE I'VE
RECEIVED THEM. YOU A TO MOVED
BY CENTER LATER THE MOTIONS TO
PASS THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CAN HI CAN I MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S NO ADMIN ADMIN I CAN
SOLACE. GROVE HER TADO. LLEVA
HI LLEVA EILEEN MON HI THE
MOMENT I ROTH RUBIO HI RUBIO I
WINNER. FIVE ONE RIGHT RIGHT
CURRENT LOTUS FIVE ONE WOULD
PUT THE BILL ON CALL. YEAH ALL
RIGHT AND LET'S SEE. WE HAV
OUR NEXT AUTHOR HERE THE
COMPLEX AND LESS. OKAY SEE THAT
WE HVE ANOTHER AUTHOR DO WE
HAVE RIGHT. NOW WE DON'T HAVE.
THAT'S WHAT'S OKAY THERE YOU GO
OKAY THAT IS UNDER FLEXION OKAY
SORRY I WAS LIKE. SO SEVERAL
WEEKS I'M COLLEGE I SAID I DID
SO TO SEE YOU BUT ASN'T SURE
IT WAS. ON THE ANGLES AND STUFF
SO THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE-
THIS IS THE ITEM NUMBER NINE
EIGHTY TWELVE OH FOUR BY
SEVERAL WEEKS THANK YOU AND
PLEASE PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL OF THEIR TIME AND
WORK ON THIS BILL AND I DO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
TO KEY MOMENTS ARE AS FOLLOWS.
BETTER DEFINE WHAT DISPARITY
REDUCTION MEANS FURTHER CLARIFY
AND PRIORITIZE WHICH
DISPARITIES REDUCTIONS ARE
REPORTED IN THE EQUITY REPORTS.
ENSURE THAT SEXUAL ORIENTATION
AND GENDER IDENTITY DATA
REPORTED TO AN EXTENT AVAILABLE
WITH STRONG PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS. ESTABLISHED HEALTH
CARE EQUITY ADVISORY COMMITTEE
TO CONVENE STAKEHOLDERS
IDENTIFY WHICH APPROPRIATE
MEASURES INCLUDING ANY. H. R.
Q. QUALITY INDICATE THAT
INDICATING MEASURES ARE
APPROPRIATE FOR EQUITY
ANALYSIS. DELAY THE REPORTING
AND INCLUSION OF SPECIFIED
MEASURES IN THE ANNUAL EQUITY
REPORT AS RECOMMENDED BY THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. UNTIL
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AND LASTLY WE'RE-
THE REPORTING OF WORKFORCE PAY
DATA WE DID TAKE A LOT OF
AMENDMENTS- IN THE HOPES OF
GETTING OPPOSITION OFF I DON'T
BELIEVE THEY ARE BUT WE DIDN'T.
MOVE THE NEEDLE PRETTY I THINK-
YOU KNOW CONSISTENTLY AND
FAIRLY ADD TO TOWARDS THAT END-
BEFORE COMING NINETEEN PANDEMIC
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
AN EQUAL ACCESS TO QUALITY
HEALTHCARE. THE CDC IS FOUND
THATRACISM AND OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
FUNDAMENTAL HEALTH INEQUITIES.
AND DISPARITIES IN LIFE
EXPECTANCY. THIS FANDOM BECAUSE
FURTHER EXPOSED AND EXACERBATED
THESE INEQUITIES IN OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. IN PARTICULAR
pTHAT BLACK CLOUD NECKS AND
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE ARE AT AN
INCREASED RISK OF EXPOSURE
ILLNESS HOSPITALIZATION. AND
SADLY DEATH RELATIVE TO THEIR
SHARE OF THE POPULATION.
CURRENTLY OUR STATE IS LIMITED
ON HEALTH QUALITY DATA AND
THESE METRICS ARE NEEDED TO
BEGIN ADDRESSING HEALTH
DISPARITIES. TO COLLECT MORE
DATA ON PATIENT HEALTH OUTCOMES
BY RACE ETHNICITY AND OTHER
IMPORTANT INFOGRAPHICS AB
TROUBLE FOR. FOR CAR HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS TO SUBMIT AN
ANNUAL EQUITY REPORT. AND YOU
HAVE HEARD I'D ACCEPTED
COMMITMENTS NOT ONLY TO RESPOND
TO THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS
BUT ULTIMATELY TO APPROVE THE
BILL INSURE THAT WE ARE HOLDING
ALL HOSPITALS REGARDLESS. OF
WHETHER THEY'RE NONPROFIT FOR
PROFIT OR PUBLIC HOSPITALS
ACCOUNTABLE TO IMPROVE ACCESS
AND DELIVERY OF QUALITY HEALTH
CARE. THIS IS THE ULTIMATE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL. THIS BILL
SPONSORED BY SEIU AND SUPPORTED
BY HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK AND MANY OTHERS.
TESTIFYING HERE- IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL TODAY- IS MARRIED
JUNE. D. AS REPRESENTING SEIU.
AND CHAMAN ODD SALAAM- HEALTH
CARE JUST AS PATIENT ADVOCATE
REPRESENTING US YEAH YOU YOU H.
W. THANKS VERY MUCH SUMMER
ROLEX. MODERATOR PLEASE BRING
ON THE LINE- MARRIAGE INDIA'S
FROM SEIU CALIFORNIA AND- IS
SHAMMA A SLUM FROM THIS YEAR
YOU YOU H. W. WILL BEGIN WITH
MARRIAGE IN DS- YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES THE TOTAL FOUR MINUTES
BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU. PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU DR CANNON
CENTER AND GAVE THE S. P. ON
BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA AND
R. SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS. BOTH OF WHOM ARE
FRONTLINE ESSENTIAL HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND WHO HAD SPEAKING
HOW LACK OF ACCESS TO QUALITY
CARE HAS IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. BEFORE AND DURING
THIS CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
WE ARE DEFINED AS A B. TWELVE
OH FOUR WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
HOSPITALS TO DEVELOP. AND
SUBMIT ANNUAL EQUITY RECORDS
THAT INCLUDE ANALYSIS AND HELP
STATIC QUALITY OF CARE AND
HEALTH DISPARITIES HE- ONGOING
HOSPITAL LEVEL DISPARITIES IN
THE DELIVERY AND QUALITY OF
HEALTHCARE SERVICES. FURTHER
CONTRIBUTE TO RACIAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES AND INEQUITIES AND
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
HAD. PHONES AND FURTHER
EXACERBATED THE LONGSTANDING
HEALTH INEQUITIES. UNEQUAL
HEALTHCARE TREATMENT HAS BEEN
CAUSED BY A NUMBER OF FACTORS
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
FACTORS AFFECT APPROPRIATE AND
TIMELY PROVIDER HERE-
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS OR THEIR
PROTECTIONS THAT PROVIDERS MAY
HAVE WHEN TREATING PATIENTS OF
COLOR. PROVIDED PROVIDED NOT
DANCING FOR OFFERING CULTURALLY
AND LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
INTERPRETATION SKILLS OR
LANGUAGE ACCESS TO PATIENTS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY AMONG
OTHERS- I. REMEMBER WAS
MENTIONED WE HAVE TAKEN A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF AND THEN
THEN AND WE'RE DISAPPOINTED
THAT THERE'S THE OPPOSITION'S
AT KABUL FORMER. ESPECIALLY
AFTER TAKING MUCH OF THE
OPPOSITION ORIGINAL AND THEN
END. UP OPPONENTS WOULD FURTHER
LIKE TO THANK ME WHAT AID BE
PROBABLE OR CONFIRMED BRIDGE
CLICK HERE TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
WHAT HAPPENS WITHIN THE FOUR
WALLS OF THE HOSPITAL. AND HOW
THAT SPECIFIC HOSPITAL DELIVERS
ON QUALITY OF CARE AND
OUTCOMES. EIGHTY PROVOKE WAR
PROVIDES THE NEXT STEP IN
IMPROVING THE COLLECTION
REPORTING AND ANALYSIS OF
IMPORTS QUALITY AND OUTCOME
DATA. FOR THIS REASON WE-
REQUEST FOR YOUR SUPPORT I
DON'T AND I'D LIKE TO TURN.
OVER TO SHAMA OFFLINE WITH ONE
OF OUR YEAH. HOW CAN GET IT TO
THE MEMBERS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LISTEN SO MUCH ON THESE ARE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME MISSION
RPM. THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO
ME I AM I'M OF THE END UNIQUE
IF YOU DON'T HELL IN THE
TECHNICIAN I THINK THERE IS FOR
WHAT YOU'D LIKE TOWARDS THE- I
THINK WILL HEALTH HER AS A
WOMAN OF COLOR WHEN I WENT INTO
THE HOSPITAL WITH THE URINARY
HUMANS THE YEARS AGO. AND THIS
IS A COMMON ISSUE THAN ANYONE
AFTER CHILDBIRTH BUT MY DOCTOR
TOLD ME I COULDN'T DO
OUTPATIENT SURGERY AND THAT IT
WOULD BE A SIMPLE ONE BUT IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE SURGERY IN
INTERMOUNTAIN DOCTOR HE COULD
WATCH IN. THE DOCTOR NEVER
INTRODUCED HER TO MEI'M NOT
GONNA THEN YOU PAY THEM LIKE
THEY INVADING MY PRIVACY
AFTERWARDS THAT DIDN'T GIVE ME
ANY INSTRUCTIONS ON THE WOMEN
OR HOW TO REMOVE MY CATHETER SO
I WENT HOME WITH THE CAMERA I
WAS ONLY SUPPOSED TO HAVE A
CHANCE TO GET IN FOR ABOUT
THREE DAYS. BUT I HAD IT IN FOR
ABOUT TWO WEEKS BEFORE-
SOMEBODY TOLD ME UP ON ME
CALLING THAT TO GO IN AND
REMOVE IT AND THEN I SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO HAVE THAT CAP ROCK
ABOUT LONG- I WOULD LOOK LIKE
AND THEN GET INSPECTION THANK
GOD. AND THE SURGERY DIDN'T
RESOLVE THIS MINOR ISSUE AND I
HAVE THREE MORE SURGERIES AFTER
THE COURSE OF THE YEAR I NEVER
GOT A REASON WHY THE TURN IN
WORK TO MAKE MATTERS WORSE
SHORTLY AFTER THIS EXPERIENCE.
MY INTERCROPPING AND I NEEDED
TO GET ANOTHER SURGERY I DON'T
REMEMBER IT WAS COMING OUT OF
THE ORDINARY AND HAVING SO MUCH
PAIN YEAH TO A POINT WHERE I
WAS I'M JUST NOT NOT WALKING
THEIR PAIN BUT THEY DON'T SEND
ME HOME AND TELL ME IT WAS
NORMAL AND THEN THEY WOULD HEAL
GLOBAL. IT WAS NOT NORMAL MY
HUSBAND HAD TO CARRY ME INTO MY
HOUSE AND I COULDN'T MOVE AN-
AND IF I WAS IN PAIN- OVERNIGHT
I DIDN'T MOVE. OUR FORMER NIGHT
FINALLY MY FRIEND WHO IS WHITE
CAME OVER IN A MEETING SO I
HAVE ABOUT A ONE HE HAD THE
SAME SURGERY BEFORE SO SHE KNEW
IT WAS NOT NORMAL YOU CALL ME
AN AMBULANCE AND WHEN WE GOT TO
BE. REAL NO ONE WOULD HELP ME
FIGURE. THINGS THAT PAIN WAS
NORMAL. AND WE'RE WAITING. THE
DOCTOR CAME IN- AND THEY
DISCOVERED THAT THEY HAD
SOMEONE ON MY NERVES AND THAT
WAS THE REASON BECAUSE I COULD
NOT MOVE SO THEY HAD TO CUT THE
AGING AND THEN AFTER I AM GOING
TO ASK YOU TO WRAP UP. YEAH.
THIS IS WHY THIS BILL AB TWELVE
FORTY SO I'M PARTIALLY LIKE
MINE ARE ALL TOO COMMON. I
APPRECIATE YOU LISTENING TO ME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I WILL NOW MOVE ON TO DIFFERENT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
TWELVE OH FOUR AGAIN FOR THE
GALLERY SCENE ON PUBLIC ALAN
SMITH ROOM ONE TWELVE SCENE. NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE-
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
TO WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY.TWELVE OH
FOUR- NAME OR POSITION POSITION
ONLY. THANK YOU. IN LATE
JANUARY FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY TWELVE OH FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH
TONE PHONE. WHEN YOUR LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FINE EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WHEN THE LINE NUMBER
ONE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CALLED MORTAL MAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. THANKS TO A LINE
NUMBER ONE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON LINDA WAY
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. SIX ONE ONE NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WITH THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. THANKS TO A LINE
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON YES
PAL AND ON BEHALF OF HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THANKS TO
A LINE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT AFTERNOON
JANICE O'MALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS LINE.
POLITE NUMBER NINETY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DIMITRIUS C. WERE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. THEN ONCE MORE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE ALL FOR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIRPERSON AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO WARNING
QUEUE RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NO MOVE TO OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
TWELVE BEFORE WE DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION- BARBARA GLASER FROM
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
BETWEEN A GOOD SOLID ALSO FROM
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. BETWEEN THE TWO OF
YOU I'LL GIVE YOU FOUR ANDA
HALF MINUTES BECAUSE OF TO GIVE
YOU EQUAL TIME- MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING THEM ON TO THE
LINE AND WE'LL GUESS WE'LL
BEGIN WITH BARCLAYS- MEMBERS.
THIS IS BARBARA GLASER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION- I WILL BE THE ONLY
ONE SPEAKING TODAY TRINA IS ON
THE LINE OKAY ERIC TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS FOR. OKAY WE'VE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE ON THE AMENDMENT THAT
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT'S
ACCEPTING TODAY THEY ARE STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. HOWEVER
WE REMAIN CONCERNED THAT THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS ARE ONLY
ON HOSPITAL. HOSPITALS AND
HEALTH SYSTEMS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ARE ALL COMMITTED TO
IMPROVING HEALTH IN THE
COMMUNITY STATE FAIR. BOTTLES
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS ARE
CERTAINLY IN A UNIQUE POSITION
TO ADDRESS HEALTH INEQUITIES
AND DISPARITIES. HOWEVER THE
INEQUALITIES THAT EXIST IN
HEALTH CARE ARE MORE THAN JUST
A HOSPITAL ISSUE. ACCESS TO
QUALITY HEALTHCARE THE CRITICAL
FACTOR THAT MANY IN HOSPITAL
AND HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS WORKED
HARD ON BUT WE NEED ALL
PROVIDERS COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING ALL OF THE REASONS.
WHY HELPING EQUITIES EXAM. I
HOSPITAL- ENTITY TO THE- AND
IMPLEMENTING A HEALTH EQUITY
PLANS WITHOUT PARTICIPATION BY
OTHERS IN THE HEALTH CARE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SOCIAL
SERVICES DELIVERY SYSTEMS WILL
ONLY SHOW A PORTION OF THE
ISSUE. ADDITIONALLY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS SEEKING TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND AND IDENTIFY WAYS TO
ADVANCE. TO THE BAND'S RACIAL
EQUITY SUPPORT FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. PART OF THIS
EFFORT THE CENTERS FOR MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID SERVICES IS
LOOKING TO DEVELOP STANDARDS
FOR DATA COLLECTION QUALITY
MEASURES. BY RACE ETHNICITY
ETHNICITY DISABILITY STATUS L.
G. B. T. Q. PLUS INSERT YOUR
ECONOMIC STATUS. WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT OUR STATE EFFORTS
ALIGN WITH THE NATIONAL
ACTIVITY AND UNICORN DATA SETS
IN METHODOLOGY FOR MEASURING
HEALTH DISPARITY IN ORDER TO
IMPROVE OUTCOMES. A NEW
AMENDMENT THREE NEW ISSUE. THE
AMENDMENT PRETTY SUPPOSED TO
PRIMARK THAT MAY NOT ALIGN WITH
FEDERAL EFFORTS. WE HAD
ENVISIONED THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WOULD LOOK AT WHICH
MAJOR TO COLLECT WHO TO COLLECT
FROM IN OTHER EFFORTS AT BOTH
THE FEDERAL AND STATE LEVEL
WELL WE SUPPORT AN AMENDMENT TO
CONVENE A HEALTHCARE EQUITY
ADVISORY COMMITTEE COMPRISED OF
A DIVERSE GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS. WE RECOMMEND IT
TEMPERED SPOKE UPON DEVELOPING
A PRIMARK DANCING HEALTHEQUITY.
LASTLY AB TWELVE OH FOUR HAVE
POTENTIAL CONFLICT WITH AT
ELEVEN THIRTY WHICH IS THE
APPLICATION THE OFFICE OF
HEALTHCARE PORTABILITY WITHIN
AUSTIN. THE OFFICE HEALTHCARE
PORT BUILT AND PORTABILITY WILL
BE CHARGED WITH THE DOCKING A
SINGLE STANDARD STANDARD MAJOR
PROTECTINGHEALTHCARE EQUITY
ACROSS PLANS INSURERS HOSPITALS
AND PHYSICIAN ORGANIZATION.
GIVEN THAT EIGHTY TRIBAL COURTS
ALSO ASKING NOW SHE SAID WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM ADVISORY
COMMITTEE TO DEVELOP EQUITY
MEASURES FOR HOSPITAL.
POTENTIAL FOR CONFLICT BETWEEN
AUSTRALIA SINGLE SIDED STANDARD
MAJORED IN THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE FROM THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE MAY BE TROUBLE FOR.
THIRTY THREE HEY TERRY OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL HOWEVER WE REMAIN
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND A
SPONSOR SIGNED A TWELVE OH
FOUR. AND AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE THE
COMMITTEE AND THE SPONSORS FOR
WORKING WITH THAT THAT'S FAR
THANK YOU. THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WILL NOW BRING IT TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE- FORGET
THE PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ON
PUBLIC HOURS MOVED TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE SAYING NO AND IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE- LET'S MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON TO THE LINE
WITNESSES WHO SHOULD TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE OH
FOUR. MANY MORE SUCH POSITION
ONLY THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE AN OPPOSITION
AB TWELVE ALL FOR PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH
TONE PHONE AGAIN THAT
OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE ALL FOR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WHEN YOU GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE OH NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE MIND HER ON
BEHALF OF MEMORIALCARE HEALTH
SYSTEM IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. AND ONCE AGAIN MADE
JOHN IF YOU ARE AN OPPOSITION
AB TWELVE ALL FOR PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIRPERSON WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU. RIGHT THANK
YOU- NOW LET'S BRING IT UP
THANK. MY POINT IS WE DID HAVE
ONE JOB WE JUST DOUBLE. ONE
MORE MOMENT. TWENTY ONE NUMBER
ONE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I THINK THAT YOUNG I AM A
PARENT HERE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THE BILL. OKAY THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. AND AT THIS TIME NOW
THE CHAIRPERSON SONIC RIGHT
THANKS VERY MUCH MODERATOR-
SEVERAL EXPERTS WILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH WORKING COMMITTEE AND-
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS- LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY SAYING
NONE- THE AGAIN AND SO I THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND- THIS IS SO VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE ADDRESS
EQUITY ISSUES- APPRECIATE THAT
THERE ARE. THAT MANY OF THEM
YEAH CAN BE BEYOND THE HOSPITAL
BUT HOSPITALS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT INSTITUTIONS THERE
OFTEN THE LEADERS AND
HEALTHCARE IN MANY COMMUNITIES
AND- SET THE TONE AND SO I
THINK THERE. THAT IS CERTAINLY
THEY HAVE A VERY IMPORTANT
PLACE TO PLAY AND THAT FOCUS
GIVEN TO. THE FOOTPRINT THEY
HAVE ON HEALTH CARE IN THE
COMMUNITY IS VERY IMPORTANT-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO- CLOSE. JUST
ONE I THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK IN FOR YOU
MISTER CHAIR. AND WE DID HAVE
MEDICAL GROUPS IN THERE BUT IT
WAS AMENDED OUT OF PROBES AND
THE ASSEMBLY- SO WE'LL CONTINUE
TO WORK. ON THE BILL AND PUSH
IT FORWARD AND THINK THAT- IN
ORDER TO REALLY. ADDRESS RACIAL
INEQUITIES IN ANY SYSTEM WE
NEED SUNLIGHT ON THAT DATA TO
AND TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IS GOING
ON SO WE CAN CREATE. EVIDENCE
BASED POLICIES TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES SO WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN IPHONE. THANK YOU IS
THERE A MOTION ON THE BILL.
OKAY I SEE BOTH THE CENTRE
LAVINE ADMIN BOTH OF YOUR HANDS
UP SIMULTANEOUSLY- THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. HAND HI. PAM I'M
MELINDA'S. A HI EGGMAN I CAN
SOLACE. ROVE HER TADO WHEN I
LEAVE I LEAVE I I'D LI MON.
ROSS ROSS I RUBIO. WINNER.
HELLO SO USUALLY IF THE VOTE IS
FOR ZERO BUT THE BILL ON CALL
THANKS SO MUCH SEVEN WEEKS.
OKAY AND S. C. S. THAT SOME
MEMBER MAYOR SUE CHEESE FROM
THE BACK. LEAVE SO OKAY YES ALL
RIGHT SO LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT BY SUMMER MAHER CG
WELCOME PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS I'M HERE TO PRESENT AT
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. WHICH IS
A BILL THAT- WILL REQUIRE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS TO
COLLECT AND SHARE PUBLIC HEALTH
DATA. USING STANDARDIZED AND
DISAGGREGATED DATA- BASED ON
RACE ETHNICITY AND LANGUAGE. WE
SAW THERE IN THIS PANDEMIC. THE
TREMENDOUS DISPARITIES- IN THE
IMPACT OF COVER NINETEEN NOT
ONLY ALONG RACIAL LINES BUT
WITHIN RACIAL GROUPS ALONG-
APNIC LINES. BUT THIS WAS MOST
STARKLY EVIDENT IN THE ASIAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES WHERE. ACCORDING TO
A USE- RECENT UCLA- HEALTH
POLICY RESEARCH REPORT. THE
RATES FOR NATIVE HAWAIIANS AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS WAS MORE THAN
DOUBLE THE AVERAGE- FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND THIS WAS
MASKED BY THE DATA A PROVIDING
INDICATING THAT THE RATES FOR
ALL ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
WAS LOWER THAN THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE AND SO THIS. IS JUST
ONE OF MANY EXAMPLES OF HOW WE
NEED TO HAVE. MORE DATA DRIVEN
PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSES TO
INSURE THAT WE ARE EFFECTIVELY
DEPLOYING- OUTREACH AND
RESOURCES INCLUDING
VACCINATIONS TESTING AND
TREATMENT. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
WITH NO NO VOTES NO OPPOSITION-
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
I HAVE- DR KIM RHODES.
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF EPITOME
EPIDEMIOLOGY AND TO CLOCK CHIEF
DEPUTY AT THE ASIAN HEALTH
SERVICES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THANKS SO MUCH
CENTER MESSAGE THE MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE KIM
RHODES FROM UCSF SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE AND TWO QUOTES FROM
ASIAN HEALTH SERVICES- I GUESS
WE'LL TAKE THEM IN THE ORDER
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS LISTED THEM
SO BEGIN WITH THAT KIM RHODES.
TWO MINUTES APIECE. I THANK THE
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE HELP COMMITTEE- MY NAME
IS DR KIM WROTE THEM A
PHYSICIAN DISPARITIES
RESEARCHER AND FOUNDER OF THE
MOTOR HEALTH PARTNERS THE
COMMUNITY LED TO THE NINETEEN
KEPT THE CARE AND VACCINATION
COLLABORATIVE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE FOCUS ON
INCREASING HEALTH EQUITY IN THE
CONTROL THE PANDEMIC THROUGH
DIRECT SERVICE DELIVERY AND
pCOMMUNITY ADVOCACY ABOUT
CAPACITY BUILDING. AS YOU HAVE
JUST HEARD THE PANDEMIC HAS
REVEALED SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITIES FOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND DISAGGREGATED DATA
COLLECTION IS GOING TO BE
CRITICAL TO UNDERSTANDING THE
ROOT CAUSES OF THESE
DISPARITIES- IF WE DON'T
COLLECT AND MAKE THE DATA
AVAILABLE FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT- THEY WILL BE
HAMSTRUNG IN THEIR ABILITY TO
EQUITABLY AND EFFICIENTLY
ALLOCATE RESOURCES AND IN THEIR
ABILITY TO DEVELOP SURGICALLY
TARGETED PRECISION PUBLIC
HEALTH INTERVENTION. AT AN
EXAMPLE OF THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC AS YOU JUST HEARD
AGGREGATED DATA WITH TELLING US
THAT- API CODE INFECTION RATES
WERE LOW BUT PULLING IT APART
IF WE HADN'T WE WOULDN'T NEED
TO SIGNIFICANTLY ELEVATED T.
THREE AND T. B. POLITY RATE IN
THE PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY
BECAUSE IT WAS HIDDEN. IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY- AGGREGATING
RATES FOR THE BLACK COMMUNITY
CONTACT TO INITIALLY MISSED
INTERVENTION ON THE AFRICAN
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY AND MANY OF
THESE IMMIGRANTS SERVE AN
ESSENTIAL WORKER JOB DRIVING IN
THE RIGHT SURE DID GET CONNIE
WHICH IS AT A VERY HIGH RISK
GROUP THAT DID NOT RECEIVE
TARGETED MITIGATION AFRICA
UNTIL EARLY IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE A YEAR INTO THE PANDEMIC.
USING AGGREGATED DATA THE
VACCINE EFFORT WE WOULD HAVE
MISSED SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER
RATES OF VACCINATION THE
FILIPINO COMMUNITY AND WHY DOES
THIS MATTER I REALLY WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT BECAUSE FILIPINO
PEOPLE REPRESENT TWENTY PER
TWENTY PERCENT- THE- ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER SUBGROUP IN
CALIFORNIA BUT 3240% OF THE
KOBE DASH. AND TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND. I TO ME- COUNTRY TO
THE- I THE FRONT LINE OF HELP
PHILIP P. ONLY READ. FOUR PER
OF THE NEW WORK. BUT IT
REPRESENTED PERCENT OF THE
NURSES WHO DIED FROM KOBE. THAT
WE FAIL TO ADVANCE THIS
LEGISLATION ON DISAGGREGATED
DATA COLLECTION- WE WILL BE
LIMITED MISDIRECTED AND
RESOURCES WILL BE INEFFICIENTLY
DISBURSED. AND WE MAY ALSO SEE
DIMINISHING VACCINE ACCESS AND
REDUCTION AND MITIGATION
STRATEGIES NEEDED. TO BE CODED
IN THE HARD HIT BUT HIDDEN
POPULATION. ADD MORE
TRANSMISSIBLE DELTA VARIANT
GAINS A FOOTHOLD IN CALIFORNIA
WE MUST REALLY COME TO
UNDERSTAND THAT PERSISTENCE OF
THE PANDEMIC IN ANY COMMUNITY
IS THE RISK OF PERSISTENCE OF
THE PANDEMIC FOR THE REST OF
THE STATE. IT IS FOR THE
TREATMENT THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS I'M AT
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
NOW THE BRING ON. TO CALL
AFFIRMATION HEALTH SERVICES-
YOU HAVE A MINUTE AND ABOUT.
THIRTY ACTUALLY TWENTY FOUR
SECONDS. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
THE CARD AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF ASIAN HEALTH SERVICES THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER THAT
PROVIDE MEDICAL DENTAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THE
FIFTY THOUSAND PATIENTS IN
ENGLISH AND FOURTEEN ASIAN
LANGUAGES WE PROVIDED OVER
FORTY THOUSAND FREE COVER TASK
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
BACK NATION IMPORTANTLY WE
PROVIDE CRITICAL CORPORATE
SERVICES IN THE LANGUAGE OF OUR
COMMUNITY SPEAK GET PAID ONLINE
WHICH IS NOT COLLECTED IN A
SYSTEMATIC MANNER. IN FACT
THERE REMAINS A DEFICIENT
COLLECTION AND LISA
STANDARDIZED DISAGGREGATED RACE
ETHNICITY DATA FOR COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR MASKING DISPARITIES
FACED BY MANY VULNERABLE GROUPS
ESPECIALLY DURING THE PANDEMIC
AS A RESULT THE UNDERSTANDING
OF THE IMPACT OF COLD IT
REMAINS LIMITED FOR EXAMPLE WE
KNOW THAT ASIAN AMERICANS HAVE
TWO TIMES THE CASE THE TALLY
RATE IN CALIFORNIA EIGHT POINT
1% VERSUS THREE POINT 9% IN THE
ENTIRE STATE. THE RISING ANTI
ASIAN RACISM HAVE. EXASPERATED
HE'D BEEN LOOKING. THERE ARE
COOL BUT- A AUTHOR ABLE TO
COLLECT THE DATA. WE HAVE THE-
AND FOUND DIDN'T THE MARK AND
HAD. CALL THE POP TO THE RATE
THAN OTHER AMERICA. WHICH ARE
ABLE TO DO. OUT WEEK INTERACT.
THANK YOU LIKE QUALITY DATA
HAVE BEEN THAT APPLICATION TO
MATCH TO DETERMINE HOW. WHAT
YOU ARE COMPETING. INCLUDING
LANGUAGE UNDERSTOOD THE NEED
FOR A SHOW AT NYC'S POPULATION
GROUPS THAT ARE GEOGRAPHICALLY
DISPERSED. WITH FIFTY FOUR
ORGANIZATIONS FROM AROUND THE
STATE REPRESENTING EIGHT ASIAN
AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER BACK
NECK AND BLACK COMMUNITIES WE
PURCHASED. A DELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE
ON TO THIS KNOW WHAT THIS IS A
PART OF A. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT BECAUSE THE PUBLIC
GALLERY SCENE ON THE PUBLIC
GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO ROOM AND
ONE TWELVE SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE. TWELVE AT LEAST I SEE ON
MY MATERNAL IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
THERE'S NO ONE ROOM TWELVE- GO
MOVE ON TO THE- TELEPHONIC ONE
MODERATE PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO. ON
EIGHTY SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR A. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
WHEN FOLLOWED BY ZERO WE'LL
BEGIN WITH WINE ONE EIGHTY TWO.
THANK YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE
EIGHTY TWO. PART OF EIGHTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT. YES OKAY START
YOUR MEMBERS CAPTAIN OFFERED
WITH THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT THANKS A
LOT THANKS LINE. ONE ONE SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SIXTY
FIVE YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE ON
MUTE. AUTHORITIES WENT AWAY
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN PART THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. ONE SEVENTY NINE
YOUR OPEN. I COULD MORNING
AGAIN TURN LYING ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. BY
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE- YOU. ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
ONE MORE TIME. I WILL MOVE
ALONG THE LINE NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ME TOO IF THEY
WERE A NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
BOTH WORKERS COMP POINT CHAPTER
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. BUT THANK YOU ONE
FIFTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN.
ARTIFICIAL BEGIN VERY WITH THE
CALGARY ACCESS COALITION AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. ONE EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. Y. MORE EIGHTY
THREE YOU ARE OPEN. ONE EIGHTY
THREE WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FORTY
ONE YEARS. HELLO YOUR OPEN
PLEASE BEGIN. I THANK YOU MR
BURNS WITH AN ORGANIZED
RESPONSE LAUGHTER INDUCING
MOSHE UNITED HEALTH AND STRONG
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY THIRTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU EXLINE.
ONE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KATHLEEN HANNA AND A HALF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA NORTH
COMPREHENSIVE CANCER CENTER AND-
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I WILL GO TO ONE- LINE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SIXTY
ONE CAN YOU HEAR IT. FARMAN
FLEW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AGENCIES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU EXLINE. WE WILL GO
IT'LL BACK TO LANE ONE EIGHTY
TRY THAT ONE AGAIN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS EDDIE WHO
WAS ASIAN RESOURCES INC- WERE
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THIRTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. ONE EIGHTY SIX YOU
ARE OPEN. HI THIS IS STRICTLY
WITH THE ASIAN PACIFIC PARTNERS
FOR EMPOWERMENT ADVOCACY AND
LEADERSHIP OFTEN HONEST APPEAL
IN YOUR INSURANCE DEPARTMENT AT
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU
THANKS LINE. THE FINAL REMINDER
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO IN
LINE ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOU ARE
OPEN. BY SEVENTY SEVENTIES ON
MUTE. MOVING ONLINE ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. MR JIRGA NO MORE
PARTICIPANTS IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL
NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY THIRTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT WE DO NOT HAVE A
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
REGISTERED FOR TESTIMONY SO GO
TO THE PUBLIC GALLERY. SCENE ON
PUBLIC ALEX MOVED TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. SAY NO ONE MOMENT FOR
MY MONITOR I GOOD- MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES TESTIFY AND
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU I TO
SHOW OPPOSITION FOR A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE
FILED BY ZERO TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO A. B. ONE THREE
FIVE EIGHT. NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SAYING NONE. THE RED CITY THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I DO KNOW THAT THE
CATEGORIES THAT WE'RE
REQUESTING OUR BROADER THAN
THOSE IN THE CENSUS IS
CERTAINLY HERE TO TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT AS TO SOME THE REASONS
FOR THAT- BUT- CERTAINLY WE Y.
TRIED DEFIED THE AREAS WHERE WE
HAVE TO SEVERITIES. I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I- I WOULD- RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I BUT I DO WANT TO NOTE
FOR THE RECORD THAT- I HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH SENATOR-
WINNER YES WELL LAST EVENING
AND- AND HE- WANTED TO-
EXPRESSED CONCERNS ABOUT-
INCLUDING DATA FOR THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITIES AND I- COMMITTED TO
HIM THAT I WOULD. WORK WITH
THEM TO- SEE IF EITHER THIS
BILL OR ANY- FUTURE BILLS-
WOULD BE NECESSARY TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDS OF
LGBTQ COMMUNITIES ARE ALSO
ADDRESSED SO WHAT'S THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL OKAY
WELL THANK YOU AND- I KNOW THAT
WAS A CLOSE I'LL JUST COMMENT
THAT IF YOU DECIDE TO DO SO IN
THIS BILL YOU WOULD BE DOING
WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU- OKAY IS THERE A
MOTION ON THIS BILL. THE MOVE
BY CENTER LABOR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. PAN HI CAN I AM MELINDA'S
EGGMAN. GONZALEZ GROVE FURTADO.
LLEVA I. BELIEVE THAT I AM THE
MON ROTH IRA ROTH IRA RUBIO.
RUBIO I WINNER. RIGHT THE BILLS
CURRENTLY FOUR ZERO WILL PUT
THE BILL ON CALL RIGHT AND I
THINK I SEE SIMILAR GABRIEL-
WELCOME. ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOURTEEN TWENTY
TWO BY SOME MEMBER GABRIEL
WELCOME PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
ASSISTANCE WE WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AND I
ALSO WANT TO START BY THANKING
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION FOR THEIR OPENNESS
TO DISCUSSING THESE IMPORTANT
MATTERS. AND FOR WORKING WITH
US TO ADDRESS THEIR REMAINING
CONCERNS. I'M PLEASED TODAY TO
PRESENT AT FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
WHICH WOULD MPROVE PATIENT
CARE AND SAFETY AND INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY. BY
STRENGTHENING THE PROCESS
AROUND PROGRAM FLEXIBILITY
REQUESTS. AS AN INITIAL MATTER
LIKE TO NOTE THAT STAFFING
RATIOS HAVE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
IN PROTECTING BOTH NURSES AND
PATIENTS. AS RESEARCH HAS
DEMONSTRATED THEY CAN LITERALLY
SAVE PATIENTS LIVES WHILE ALSO
PROTECTING NURSES FROM INJURY
AND ILLNESS. I ALSO KNOW THIS
FIRST HAND FOR MY MOM IN
EXCEPTIONALLY COMPASSIONATE
REGISTERED NURSE WHO SPENT
YEARS CARING FOR EVERYONE FROM
NEWBORN BABIES TO ELDERLY
CANCER PATIENTS. AS MY MOM
TELLS IT THERE WERE TIMES WHEN
HER HOSPITAL WAS SO LEAN WE
STAFFED BUT SHE WORRIED THA
EVEN TAKING A QUICK RESTROOM
BREAK WOULD PUT HER PATIENTS AT
RISK. UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS
GROWING EVIDENCE IN RECENT
YEARS SOME HOSPITALS HAVE
SOUGHT TO USE PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITY REQUEST TO
CIRCUMVENT STAFFING RATIOS
THEREBY PLACING PATIENTS NURSES
AND THE COMMUNITY AT RISK. AT
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO SIX TO
DRESS THIS ISSUE BY MAKING A
NUMBER OF COMMON SENSE REFORMS
TO PROGRAM FACTS ABOUT THE
REQUEST. MOST IMPORTANTLY
GIVING OUR FRONT LINE NURSES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
INPUT ON CHRISTMAS CRITICAL
HOSPITAL SAFETY DECISIONS.
EIGHTY FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO ALSO
INCREASES TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND PUBLIC
OVERSIGHT AROUND THE PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITY PROCESS. CONSISTENT
WITH THE BASIC NOTION THAT
DECISIONS WHICH IMPACT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY. SHOULD NOT
BE HIDDEN FROM PATIENTS OR THE
PUBLIC. AS WE HAVE ALL OBSERVED
OUR FRONTLINE HEALTH CARE
HEROES HAVE GIVEN SO MUCH TO
OUR COMMUNITIES OVER THE PAST
YEAR. AT A BARE MINIMUM WE OWE
THEM THE BASIC COURTESY OF AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A VOICE IN
DECISIONS. WHICH CAN HAVE A
HUGE IMPACT ON THEIR HEALTH
SAFETY AND LIVELIHOODS IN
ADDITION TO THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THEIR PATIENTS. AND
THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE.
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL SUPPORTED
BY ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE A
LONG HISTORY. OF FIGHTING FOR
WORKERS AND SERVING OUR
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING SEIU
CALIFORNIA YOU NOT ASK ME AND
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. WITH ME TODAY IS
ANALOGY FROM S. A. U.
CALIFORNIA AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANKS
VERY MUCH SENATOR GABRIEL-
MODERATOR PLEASE BE ON THE LINE
MATT LUCE FROM SEIU. CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES- PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS MET WITH JAY
ABOUT THE SEIU CALIFORNIA THE
PRODUCT WAS SPONSORS AT
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO. FIRST I
LIKE TO THINK THE CHAIR AND
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
FOR BEING A CHAMPION FOR NURSES
AND OFFERING. A. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO ONE CREW
TRANSPARENCY UP PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITY REQUESTS AND SURE
THAT NURSES ALWAYS HAVE A VOICE
IN DECISIONS THAT IMPACT THEIR
WORK. WHICH WILL STRENGTHEN
NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS THE
BILL IS A CRUCIAL STEP TO
ENSURE THAT PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITY- QUESTION UP ON FOR
MY PATIENT CARE AND SAFETY.
OPEN A PUBLIC HEALTH CURRENTLY
CONSIDERS IN GRANTS PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITY REFLECTS YOU
HOSPITALS WHAT HOSPITAL WOULD
LIKE TO MEET A STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT THROUGH ALTERNATIVE
METHODS. ARE BILL FOCUSES ON A
SUBSET PROGRAM POSSIBLY REFLECT
THE IMPACT NURSING CARE.
ENSURES THAT NURSES HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK UP WHEN C.
PH CONSIDERING THESE REQUESTS.
THE BILL PROVIDES FOR A THIRTY
DAY PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD SO
THAT NURSES ADVOCATES FOR THEIR
PATIENTS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO DISCUSS THE POTENTIAL
IMPACTS. ON PATIENT. CARE FROM
THE PROGRAM FLEXIBILITY. WE SAW
DURING THE NINETY PENNED THEM
THAT FLEXIBILITY- REQUESTS WERE
GRANTED WITHOUT PROPER
NOTIFICATION OF NURSES AT THE
BEDSIDE AND THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT NURSES ARE NOTIFIED ABOUT
THESE CHANGES THAT MAY IMPACT.
THE BILL STRIKES A BALANCE
BETWEEN- THAT NECESSARY PUBLIC
COMMENT IN EXPEDIENCY WHEN IT
IS WARRANTED BY PROVIDING FOR
EXPEDITED PATHWAY SO BACK. UP
EMERGENCY OUTSIDE OF HOSPITALS
CONTROL HE PH CAN GRANT
TEMPORARY PROGRAM FLEXIBILITY
WITHOUT A PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD
WE HAVE MORE CLOUT RELIEF WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS AND WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WE HAVE BEEN TOLD
THAT THEY WILL HURT THEIR
OPPOSITION. AT FOURTEEN TWENTY
TWO IS NEEDED TO BRING
TRANSPARENCY TO PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITY REQUESTS ENSURES
THAT NURSES CAN ADVOCATE FOR
THEIR PATIENTS WHEN THE STATE
CONSIDERS THESE REQUESTS. FOR
THESE REASONS RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU VOTE BY. AT FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO THANK YOU. THANKS
FOR MUCH WELL NOW THE TO THE
WITNESS IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
FORTY TWENTY TWO BECAUSE THE
PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ON THE
PUBLIC OUT OF THIS WITH THE
ROOM ONE TWENTY TO SAY NO ONE.
ROOM ONE TWELVE LET'S MOVE ON
TO THE PUBLIC TO THE TELEPHONIC
LINE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF EIGHTY
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO. THE
SCIENCE SUPPORT FOR A. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND ONE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO JENNIFER MALLON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
AND NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
OH ONE FOR EVERYBODY ELSE GOING
TO HELP ONE ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT. ONE FILED BY ZERO.
GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAIR MEMBERS
PAT WHALEN ELIGIBLE SNAP FEAR
ON BEHALF OF YOUR ACCIDENT IS
THERE SUFFICIENT CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT THANKS VERY
MUCH. WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT TECHNICALLY
IT'S NOT AN OPPOSITION BUT IS
THERE SOMEONE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPICES SITUATION
WHO WISH TO MAKE SOME REMARKS.
OKAY. THE MODERATORS OR ANYONE
I THINK I HAVE ALEX ON OVER THE
LAST NAME IS- FROM THIS OR
SOMEONE FROM THE CROWD FOR
HOSPICE ASSOCIATION WISH TO
TESTIFY. IF THERE IS WITH THE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER ONE
SIX. THIS TIME I DON'T SHOW
ANYBODY KILLING OKAY ALL RIGHT
THEN WE'LL JUST CONTINUE TO
MOVE ON TO- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SO BEYOND THE PUBLIC
GALLERY SO WE HAVE NO OTHER WE
DON'T HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS FOR TESTIMONY THEN.
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE PUBLIC
GALLERY SCENE ON THE PUBLIC
GALLERY THIS MOVE TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE C. KNOWN ROOM TWELVE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR- WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO NAME
WORKSTATION POSITION. THANK YOU
YOU'RE AN OPPOSITION AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WHERE TO GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
ALICE HAWTHORNE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION JUST
CONFIRMING THAT WE ARE MOVING
OUR OPPOSITION- WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS WE THANK THE AUTHOR
HIS STAFF AND THE SPONSOR POOR
WORKING TO RESOLVE OUR ISSUES.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. THANKS
LINE. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRPERSON WITH NOBODY IN Q.
RIGHT THANK YOU ET'S BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SAY NONE- AGAIN I- THE SUMMER
GABRIELLA THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH OUR STAFF AND- TO-
ON THE AMENDMENTS AND- LOOKS
LIKE YOU'VE REMOVED YOUR
OPPOSITION- SO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. YEAH THANK YOU MR
CHAIR PJ YOU APPRECIATE YOUR
STAFF RESPECTFULLY REQUEST IN
ABOUT RIGHT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. I SEE IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SEND A ROCKET TO KEEP IT MOVES
QUICKLY- THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS- CANCELED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PAN HI. CAN I
MELINDA'S. EGGMAN EGGMAN.
AIKENS AULUS. GROVE HER TADO
LLEVA HI LLEVA EILEEN MOANED
BROTH HI ROTH I RUBIO. RUBIO I
WINNER. THE CURRENT LOTUS FIVE
ZERO BUT THE BILL ON CALL THEY
VERY MUCH OKAY NOW MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE EIGHTY
FOURTEEN FORTY THREE BY CENTER
MCCARTY GIVE US A MOMENT TO
TIDY UP THE PODIUM. WELCOME.
ALL RIGHT PLEASE BEGIN. THANK
YOU SENATOR MISTER CHAIR I
THINK ON THE LAST BILL CORRECT.
YOUR LAST ROUND SILVER
PRESENTATION YES AND LUNCH
HOURS NEXT SO I THINK THIS IS A-
REFILL. THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH US AND- WENT OUT OF THE
GATE THANK YOU AND YOUR TEAM IT
WILL ACCEPT. THE COMMITTEE MET
THEN MENSA THANK YOU. FOR
HELPING US CLARIFY THESE ISSUES
SO THIS IS THE BILL IT'S KIND
OF A COMBO HEALTH BILL IN
PUBLIC SAFETY. ALLOWING CITIES
TO EXPAND THEIR COMMUNITY
POLICING IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
WE KNOW THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
BEING CALLED UPON MANY TIMES TO
ASSIST WITH INDIVIDUALS.
EXPERIENCING NON VIOLENCE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISES WHICH WE
HAVE SEEN MANY TIMES LEAD TO
TRAGIC CONSEQUENCES. ALTERNATES
TO POLICE RESPONSE FOR
NONVIOLENT MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
CALLS. CAN PROVIDE REAL
MEANINGFUL AND FRANKLY MORE
APROPRIATE CARE- WE CAN HAVE
MORE SOCIAL WORKERS- LIKE MY
CENTER HERE FROM STOCKTON AND
HEALTH CARE EXPERTS WORKING TO-
INTERVENE PROVIDING RESOURCES.
AND RELIEVE SOME OF THE BURDEN
FROM OUR POLICE DEPARTMENTS-
THIS BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
COUNTY TO DEVELOP TRAINING AND
WRITTEN POLICY. IS TO ALLOW
MOBILE CRISIS TEAMS AND MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS TO WRITE.
IN TRANSPORT PEOPLE PURSUANT TO
THE HEALTH AND WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS CODE FIFTY ONE
FIFTY- THIS IS RELATED TO OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO- AND WITH ME TO
TESTIFY AS A DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO. CONSUELO
HERNANDEZ AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU ABOUT THE CASE THANK
YOU SO MUCH SIS MMO CARTY-
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING US A
LINE CONSUELO HERNANDEZ FROM
THE CITY SACRAMENTO. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
THIS IS CONTROL HERNANDEZ'S THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STATED I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR THE CITY- WE HAVE SPONSORS
OF AB FOURTEEN FORTY THREE AND
I WILL MAKE THIS BRIEF SINCE WE
ARE THE LAST BILL- LAST YEAR
THE CITY COUNCIL DIRECTED THE
CREATION OF THE STAFF CREATED
THE OFFICE OF COMMUNITY
RESPONSE TO ESTABLISH AN
ALTERNATE RESPONSE MODEL FOR
NINE ONE ONE CALLS- WE THE
OFFICE WILL BE COMPRISED OF
CITY STAFF TO. ADDRESS ISSUES
SUCH AS MENTAL HEALTH
HOMELESSNESS- RESPONDING TO
SCHOOL ISSUES AND SUBSTANCE AND
SUBSTANCE USE- CITY STAFF
WILLING PEOPLE TO THE MOST
SUITABLE SERVICES TARGETED TO
THEIR NEEDS SUCH AS MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES SUBSTANCE ABUSE
HOUSING MEDICAL AND FOOD- ONE
KEY AREA FOR OUR CITY IS CALLS
FOR SERVICE RELATING TO MENTAL
ILLNESS AND FIFTY ONE FIFTIES.
FOR EXAMPLE IN TWENTY TWENTY
THE SACRAMENTO POLICE
DEPARTMENT RECEIVED ALMOST
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND CALLS FOR
SERVICE RELATING TO MENTAL
ILLNESS IN FIFTY ONE FIFTY SO
AS WE'RE DEVELOPING THIS
DEPARTMENT- WE IDENTIFIED SOME
AREAS THAT WE FELT WOULD
BENEFIT FROM SOME CLARIFICATION
AND CURRENT LAWSUIT AB FOURTEEN
FORTY THREE WOULD SET SOME
PARAMETERS AROUND THE CITY'S
WORK WITH- SACRAMENTO COUNTY TO
IMPLEMENT OUR PROGRAM. IT WOULD
ALSO CLARIFY THE DESIGNATING A
NON PEACE OFFICER PROFESSIONAL
INCLUDES BOTH WRITING THE HOLD
AND TRANSPORTING THAT PERSON TO
AN APPROPRIATE FACILITY AND
LASTLY IT WOULD EXTEND TO
MEMBERS OF A MOBILE CRISIS TEAM
THE SAME LIABILITY PROTECTION
CURRENTLY PROVIDED TO PEACE
OFFICERS PERFORMING FUNCTIONS
UNDER FIFTY ONE FIFTY. WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANKS VERY MUCH-
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE WITNESS
AS A AND EIGHTY FORTY FORTY
THREE BEACON PUBLIC GALLERY
SCENE ALL THE PUBLIC GALLERY
THAT'S MOVED TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
SEEN ON ROOM TWELVE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHO WOULD TESTIFY. IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. FOURTEEN FORTY
THREE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. FOURTEEN FORTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE.
ONE CAN SUPPORT FOR A. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR
SURE PERSON WE HAVE KNOWN IN Q.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THAT'S WHEN
IT WOULD NOW MOVE ON TO THE
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY FORTY
FORTY THREE WE DO HAVE OR TO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS AND
TESTIMONY TYLER RIND. FROM THE
COUNTY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA SO PLEASE BRING HER
RIGHT ON THE LINE YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES- PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TIRING THE
WITH THE COUNTY TO HIP HOP
TRACK TO THE VERIFICATION I'LL
KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF. WITHOUT
COLLABORATIVE CONVERSATION AND
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS THE BEACH DAY FOR
YOU TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION AT
FOURTEEN FORTY THREE. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE BAIL WHILE
MEETING THE NEEDS OF THE
THIRTIETH DR MANAL. ALSO HAVE
OFFERED IMPORTANT
CLARIFICATIONS WITHIN FIFTY ONE
FIFTY PATRICK REGARDING THE
TRANSPORTATION OF INDIVIDUAL
QUITE ON A FIFTY ONE FIFTY.
FIVE COUNTY DESIGNATED
PROFESSIONAL AND PROVIDE
IMPORTANT LIABILITY PROTECTIONS
FOR DESIGNATED. INDIVIDUALS
WRITING CALLED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU TAILORING THE- EMIT MOVE ON
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN FORTY
THREE- BUT BECAUSE OF THE
GALAXY NOTE PUBLIC ALICE MOVED
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE C. KNOWN
ROOM TWELVE- MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
WHO SHOULD TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY FOURTEEN
FORTY THREE. NAME OR POSITION
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN FORTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE.
ONCE AGAIN OPPOSITION TO AB
FOURTEEN FORTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIRPERSON OF KNOWING
QUEUE AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK
YOU LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE OR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CENTER ADMIN. BUT THANK YOU
BUT- I I'VE BEEN TREATING IDEA
NO THIS IS A ONLY FOR
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IS THAT
CORRECT AND THAT'S WHAT DROPS
THE OPPOSITION AND IF THIS IS
ONLY FOR SACRAMENTO COUNTY
COULD THEN BE USED AS A MODEL
FOR OTHER COUNTIES IF THEY
SHOULD FIND THEMSELVES. NEEDING
THE SAME KIND OF RESOURCES-
WOULD SEPARATE LEGISLATION HAVE
TO BE INTRODUCED. THAT'S
CERTAINLY OUR HOPE BUT I THINK
THAT THE AMENDMENT TODAY
FOCSES JUST ON SACRAMENTO WHEN
WE STARTED IT WAS MORE BROAD.
AND SOMETIMES THAT'S ENOUGH THE
PATH WE HAVE TO TAKE. OKAY
THANK YOU AND I WOULD I WOULD
MOVE THE BILL. RIGHT IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER ADMIN. OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY
SAYING DONE SUMMER MCCARTY
THANK YOU SOMUCH FOR.
ACCEPTING THEM INTO WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF- IS C.
REMOVED YOUR OPPOSITION.
HOPEFULLY AS WE BOTH REPRESENT
THE CITY SACRAMENTO AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTY THAT THE
SERBIAN MODEL MOVING FORWARD
WITH THE LIKE THE CLOTHES.
THANK YOU ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
RIGHT THANK YOU. RIGHT SO AGAIN
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SO- CENTER
ADMIN THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON.
JUDICIARY CONSULT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CAN HI CAN MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S I A HUMAN RIGHT
EGGMAN EIGEN SOLACE.
CONSOLIDATES I GROW. HER TADO
HI FOR TITLE I LLEVA. HI LEAVE
A HIGHLY MON. ROSS ROSS I RUBIO
RUBIO I. EIGHT SEVEN WHAT DO I
HAVE EIGHT. THE PHONE WAS
MISSING. BUT WE HAVE A LOT OF
NUMBERS RIGHT. RIGHT OKAY RIGHT
RIGHT OKAY SO THE BILL
CURRENTLY SEVEN ZERO WILL PUT
THE BILL ON CALL. ALL RIGT- SO
WE'VE NOW COMPLETED ALL THE
PRESENTATIONS ON THE BILLS
HOWEVER MANY OF THE NATIONAL
BILLS WERE PRESENTED
SUBCOMMITTEE SO WE'LL JUST GO
FROM THE TOP OF THE AGENDA WILL
NEED SOME MOTIONS FOR SOME OF
THESE. SO BEGIN WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY SEVENTY- IS
THERE A MOTION ON I. EIGHTY
SEVENTY SO MOVED BY CENTER LEVI
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. PAN HI CAN I MELINDA'S
MELINDA'S I AIKMAN HI A MAN I
CAN SOLACE HI THEMSELVES A
GROUP OF HER TADO HI TATO I
LLEVA HI LISA I LI MON. ROSS
ROSS I RUBIO. RUBIO I WINNER.
OKAY THE TECHNICIAN. THE
MOBILE. RIGHT SO THAT THOSE
CURRENTLY EIGHT ZERO PUT THE
BILL ON CALL. LET'S NOW MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY THREE
FORTY SEVEN BY SOME MEMBER OR
ARRANGE A LOT IS THERE A MOTION.
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY I THINK
I HEARD SENATOR TADO THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HAN HI CAN I MELINDA'S EGGMAN
HI EGGMAN AIKEN SOLACE HI
THEMSELVES I GROW FURTADO HI
HER TITLE I LEAVE A LEAVE I
LEAVE MON HI LEON I ROSS ROSS I
RUBIO RUBIO I. ALL OF THAT.
ZEROCHAN STATE OFFICES THAT
WERE DONE OKAY SO THAT THAT
BUILD OUT EIGHT ZERO. OKAY
AGAIN ITEM NUMBER THREE- WE'RE
HOLDING OVER TILL NEXT WEEK
FOR- FOR VOTE AND- AND THEN
MEANT WELL THE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR FOR ONE BY SOME
MEMBER MAZE IS THERE A MOTION.
OKAY I EXCEL CENTER LEAVES
HANDED HER THE VOICE BY WASN'T
ALWAYS. WHAT DOES IT MEAN
CENTER GONZALEZ AND CENTER
LEAVE AS MOVED TO THE VILLAGE
DO PASS THE FIRST REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PAN HI CAN
I MELINDA'S MELINDA'S I AIKMAN
HI IKMAN I CAN SOLACE. AND
SELL US ON A GROWTH HER TADO
FOR TITLE I LEAVE I LEAVE I
LEAVE MON. HI LEE MON I ROSS HI
ROTH I RUBIO. I RUBIO I. NO
YEAH. SO THAT BILL IS OUT. NINE
ZERO RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER. FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT THREE EIGHT THIRTY FIVE
BY SIMMONS AREA AND IS THERE A
MOTION. OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR LEYVA THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. ITS OWN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CAN HI AND
I'M MELINDA'S. PULLING
MELINDA'S NO AIKMAN HI A MAN I
CAN SOLACE HI AND SO AS I GROW
HER TADO HI. HER TITLE HI LISA
HI LISA I LEE MOON. LIMONEIRA
ROSS I RUBIO. RUBIO I. THAT
BILL IS OUT EIGHT ONE RIGHT
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER SIX AT
TEN THIRTY EIGHT BY SUMMER
GIBSON- CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
MELINDA'S. GROVE. ROTH ROTH I
WINNER. THAT'S RIGHT THAT BILL
IS OUT EIGHT ZERO NEXT ITEMS
I'M NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY ELEVEN
FORTY FOUR BY SUMMER ROBERT
RIVAS CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
GONZALES GONZALES I GROVE ROTH
ROTH I WINNER. OKAY THAT BILL
IS OUT NINE ZERO NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY SOME MEMBER TO
CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS IN SOLID.
GONZALES I GROW FURTADO. HER
TITLE BY ROSS ROTH I WINNER.
THAT BILLS OUT EIGHT ONE NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER NINE EIGHTY
TWELVE OH FOUR BY SEPTEMBER
WAKES CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS
MELINDA'S MELINDA'S NO.
GONZALEZ GONZALES I GROW HER
TADO HER TITLE EILEEN MOANED
THE MON I RUBIO. RUBIO I WINNER.
THAT BILL IS OUT EIGHT ONE
SIX ITEMS I AND NUMBER TEN
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT BY
SUMMER MAYOR SU CHI CONSULT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS MELENDEZ EGGMAN EGGMAN
AIKEN SALAS GONZALEZ I A
GROUP OF HER TADO FOR TITLE
III WE MOAN LIMON AYE WIENER
OKAY THAT BILLS OUT EIGHT
ZERO NEXT ITEMS I AM NUMBER
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOURTEEN TWENTY
TWO BY SUMMER GABRIEL CONSULT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS MELENDEZ MULLIN IS NO
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROW
FURTADO HER TADO EILEEN
MOANED LIMON AYE WIENER
THAT BILLS OUT EIGHT ONE SIX
ITEMS ITEM NUMBER TWELVE EIGHTY
FOURTEEN FORTY THREE BY SUMMARY
CARTY CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS
GROW ME MON IMAN I WINNER
YEAH OKAY THAT BILLS OUT NINE
ZERO NOW LET'S GO BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB SEVENTY SEVEN
PER SALAS CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS
GROVE LIMóN LIMóN AYE WIENER
THAT BILLS OUT NINE ZERO I
THINK THAT'S IT A DIFFICULT
OKAY I BELIEVE WE'VE GONE
THROUGH ALL THE ITEMS OF THE
AGENDA -- THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH -- I THINK ALL MEMBERS
I KNOW IT'S BEEN BOUNCING
AROUND I ALSO WANT TO THANK
OUR -- COMMITTEE STAFF WORKED
VERY HARD BUT -- TO GET
ALL THE AMENDMENTS AND --
TOGETHER TODAY ONE THINK OF
THE TECHNICAL STAFF AND OUR
MODERATORS SO IT'S ALWAYS
A CHALLENGE YOU KNOW ALWAYS
CHALLENGING AND TO TRY TO BE
SURE WE WANNA BE SURE THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS FULL ACCESS TO OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS NOW I THINK
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS PARTICIPATE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
ARE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY INDIVIDUAL HEARING
RECORDS THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
I THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION
WE HAVE NOW CONCLUDED THIS
AGENDA OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH -- THIS HEARING
IS NOW ADJOURNED THANK YOU